EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DECENCY AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCE THE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND IT AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. AND I DO WANT
TO ADD THAT TODAY BECAUSE OF
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WE ARE
ONLY BEING STREAMED NOT
TELEVISED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
UNDERSTANDING. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE EIGHT. THREE
SIX FIVE SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NMBER YOU WILL WAIT ON
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE ON YOU DID AND
YOU ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY. AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST NEED THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING AND- THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE HEARING ALL THE
BILLS ON OUR SCHEDULE. AFTER
THE INITIAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. WE WILL
BE LIMITING PUBLIC COMMENT TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTED
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THIS REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER S.
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA. FIVE BILLS
ARE ON CONSENT S. B. FOUR
TWENTY S. B. FOUR NINETY ONE SB
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT S. B. EIGHT
OH FOUR. N. S. B. EIGHT TWO
SEVEN. TWO BILLS HAVE BEEN
PULLED FROM TODAY'S HEARING BY
THE AUTHOR. S. B. SEVENTY FIVE
BATES AND SB SEVEN SIXTY FOUR-
BURKE. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BRADFORD CHOI BOGUE HERE ABOUT
HERE CALM LONGER HERE I'M
LONGER HERE SKINNER WINNER
WINNER HERE CORMS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. THANK YOU OKAY NOW
LET'S HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR WELCOME SENATOR LEYVA
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS. I WOULD
FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL IT IS MUCH
APPRECIATED AND ALSO I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AND
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. SB FIFTY THREE ALSO
KNOWN AS A FLASH ACT WILL SET
LEGAL PROTECTION PROTECTIONS
FOR TECHNOLOGY USERS WHEN THEY
RECEIVE UNSOLICITED SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT IMAGES AND VIDEOS
BETTER KNOWN AS CYBER FLASHING
SPONSORED BY BUMBLE THIS
MEASURE WOULD CREATE AN
INFRACTION PUNISHABLE BY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOR THE FIRST
OFFENSE AND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOR EACH SUBSEQUENT
OFFENSE. FOR KNOWINGLY
TRANSMITTING UNSOLICITED LEWD
OR SEXUALLY EXPLICIT MATERIAL
EXCUSE ME FOR KNOWINGLY.
TRANSMITTING SUCH UNSOLICITED
LEWD OR SEX OR SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT MATERIAL BY ELECTRONIC
MEANS THE PLEASURE COULD ALSO
CREATE A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION AGAINST ANY PERSON WHO
KNOWS OR REASONABLY SHOULD KNOW
THAT THE LEWD IMAGES
TRANSMITTED ARE FUN. ACCORDING
TO THE PEW RESEARCH CENTER 53%
OF YOUNG WOMEN AND 37% OF YOUNG
AMERICAN MEN HAVE BEEN SENT
UNSOLICITED EXPLICIT MATERIAL
WHILE ONLINE. ALSO THE MAJORITY
OF WOMEN WHO RECEIVED UN
PROMPTLY SAID UNPROMPTED
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT IMAGES
REPORTED BEING SENT THIS
MATERIAL THROUGH VARIOUS SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS SUCH AS
SNAPCHAT INSTAGRAM LINKED IN
TWITTER AND FACEBOOK THIS
BEHAVIOR ALSO OCCUR OCCURS VIA
DATING PLATFORMS. TEXT MESSAGES
AND EMAIL IN SOME CASES
UNSOLICITED SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
MATERIAL IS EVEN AIRDROPPED IN
PUBLIC SPACES TO- SIX
SPECTATING RECIPIENTS MEMBERS
CYBER FLASHING IS ABUSIVE AND
IT IS WRONG. NO CALIFORNIANS
SHOULD EVER BE SENT A SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT PICTURE OR VIDEO
WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT AND WHEN
IT HAPPENS IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HOLD THOSE PERPETRATORS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR
AND MAYBE WE CAN EVEN HELP THEM
HAVE BETTER BEHAVE. HERE WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ALL
THE REMOTELY IS WHITNEY WOLFE
HERD THE FOUNDER AND CEO OF
BUMBLE INCORPORATED THANK YOU
SHAUNA CHRISTOPHER. THANK YOU
SENATOR LEYVA WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO OUR WITNESSES AND TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT- WE WILL HEAR FIRST
FROM WHITNEY WOLFE HERD PLEASE
ARE YOU ON THE LINE MA'AM. I AM
HELLO EVERYBODY THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME. PLEASE PROCEED ASK I
BEGAN. PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
OUT OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS F THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS MY FULL
SUPPORT FOR ACT THE FIFTY THREE
BY PASSING THIS BILL CALIFORNIA
WELL ESTABLISH A MUCH NEEDED
DETERRENT AGAINST HER BABY FORM
ADDITIONAL HARASSMENT AND
PLANNED A STRONG SIGNAL THAT
JEOPARDIZING ONE MENTAL
WELLBEING CANNOT BE THE COST OF
CONNECTING. TO MODERN DAY
TECHNOLOGY SO ALLOW ME TO STATE
UP FRONT THAT I AM NOT ASKING
YOU TO CALL THE CHALLENGE CORPS
BUMBLE. HAVING BEEN THE TARGET
OF ONLINE HARASSMENT MY FILES I
FOUNDED BUMBLE TO PROVIDE A
SAFE SPACE FOR PEOPLE TO CREATE
HEALTHY AND EQUITABLE
RELATIONSHIP SHE MISSION IS
BUILT INTO OUR PRODUCTS THROUGH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR OWN
PROPRIETARY TOOLS WE
AUTOMATICALLY DETECT BLOWER AND
WARN OUR CUSTOMERS WHEN THEY
MADE THE AND REPEATABILITY
IMAGE OR A LOOSE BELT. WITH DAN
AND POWER OUR CUSTOMERS TO
DECIDE IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO
VIEW IT WE ALSO PROVIDE THEM AN
EASY WAY TO REPORT DEFENDER SO
THAT WE CAN KEEP OUR ENTIRE.
COMMUNITY IN DAD I AM ASKING
YOU TO CALL THE BILL ON OF
WOMEN WHO ARE THE OVER. AND HI
HARASS EACH HOUR LIMIT COUPLE
HELLO BUT THEY ARE WITH
UNWANTED. AND IN SOME. WHERE SO
ON ALL CORNERS OF THE- IN THEIR
EMAIL BOX SOCIAL MEDIA
PROFESSIONAL NETWORK SITE SHE
EVEN DROPS DIRECTLY TO THE HOME.
FREQUENTLY THESE PHOTOS ARE
PART OF A LARGE AFTER. IN BALI
OTHER TIME PHOTOS DON'T SEEM TO
BE CONNECTED TO ANYTHING AT ALL.
OUR LIVES ARE COMPOUND
COLLECTION HELD THE FIFTY NEEDS
AND FEELINGS AND BIOLASE. SURE
THERE CUT OF THAT THE FEELING
ARE NOT. STAR NUMBER OF TALKING
THAT WE RECENTLY SURVEYED SAID
THAT IT MAKES AN- ALL OF THE
OTHERS ONLINE AND MOBILE
VULNERABLE WHEN USING THE
INTERNET. SO THINK ABOUT THAT
AT A TIME WHEN COOLEY NINETEEN
THIS CRISIS HAS REVEALED ARE
EITHER DEPENDENT ON TECHNOLOGY
AN ACT FOR WHICH THERE IS NO.
LEGAL PROHIBITION NOR. OR CALL
WHEN IT HAVING A NOW. AND HOW
ASPECT. I FIFTY THREE CAN
CHANGE THAT THANK YOU SENATE
ARE A LOT FOR ALL THAT BILL AND
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU TAKE THE
TIME HEAR YOU TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- IS WHITNEY WOLFE
HERD I'M JUST AS A REMINDER I
ALLOW ME TO- READ LITTLE
DISCLAIMER HERE- DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE COMMITTEE CHAIRS
MAY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE FIFTEEN MINUTES WILL BE
ALLOTTED FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND JUST SO THAT WE
MOVE FORWARD WE ARE ALLOWING
YOU TWO AND A HALF MINUTES HER
ADD TESTIMONY. BOTH IN LEADING
AND IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT
AND IN OPPOSITION FIVE MINUTES
TOTAL ON EACH SIDE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS WHAT IT WILL PER
NETWORK NAY MOVED FORWARD WITH
Q. SHAUNA CHRISTOPHER. ARE YOU
AN ONLINE. YES I AM PERFECT
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
HERE AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KIANA CHRISTOPHER I WORK IN THE
SCHOOL COUNSELOR IN SAN DIEGO
I'M ALSO A SEX THERAPIST IN
TRAINING AS WELL AS THE FIRST
YEAR JANIE LOCKED IN AND- I
INSPIRED TO ONE DAY RUN FOR
ELECTED OFFICE I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE WITH YOU TODAY MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB FIFTY THREE BY
SENATOR CONNIE LEYVA. THIS DEAL
IS URGENTLY NEEDED. I KNOW I
HAVE PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED
RECEIVING UNSOLICITED LEWD
PHOTO. UNLESS ACTION IS TAKEN I
NEAR WILL ALSO BECOME THE LIVED
EXPERIENCES OF THE USE I
COUNSEL AND MENTOR AND EVEN MY
OWN TWO DAUGHTERS. I HAVE
RECEIVED UNWANTED AND UNWELCOME
PHOTOS AND THIS KIND. ADULT
THEY HAVECOME TO ME YOUR EMAIL.
MEDIA AND IN MESSAGES THE
APPEAR WITHOUT REGARD TO WHERE
I AM WHAT I AM DOING. WHAT MY
MENTAL STATE WHAT MENTAL STATE
I AM IN OR WHO I MIGHT BE
AROUND. THEY APPEAR WITHOUT
REGARD TO MY FEELINGS ARE TO MY
CAN OR TO MY CONSENT. THE END
WELCOME IMAGES ARE NOT ONLY IN
TRUTH IS THERE ARE STILL
DIFFICULT TO BE RAISED FROM MY
MEMORY. THE IMAGES LEAVE ANY
IMPRINT ANY FEELING OF DANGER
THAT SOMETIMES MAKES IT
DIFFICULT TO PROCEED WITH
PASSED IN THAT MOMENT. AND THE
PROVIDER OF TRAUMA. I CAN HEAR
IT IS DESPICABLE VIOLATION TO
INDIVIDUAL ASSAULT. AS A RESULT
OF THIS BY AVOIDING DIGITAL
COMMUNICATION FOR EXTENDED
PERIODS OF TIME JUST CALLED ME
A MINUTE NETWORKING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MY
PROFESSIONAL ADVANCEMENT. NO
ONE SHOULD HAVE THESE
EXPERIENCES WITH EXPLICIT
IMAGES IN THIS MATTER IT IS
DIGITAL HARASSMENT PLAIN AND
SIMPLE. I DON'T BELIEVE THE
ISSUE ABOUT LEWD COMING UP ALL
TO OFTEN IN MY PROFESSIONAL AS
AN EDUCATOR. GIVEN MY OWN
EXPERIENCES I FEEL A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PREPARE YOUNG
GENERATIONS OF WOMEN FOR THE
HARSH REALITIES OF MODERN
TECHNOLOGY TO SHIELD THEM
AGAINST THE RELATED LANGUAGE
POSSIBILITY THAT THEY TO WILL
BECOME VICTIMS OF THIS TYPE OF
HARASSMENT. AS THEY GO OUT INTO
THE WORLD. I DO NOT WANT THEM
OR MY TWEEN AGE DAUGHTER
PRINCESS DARLIN OR DAUGHTER
RIANA TO BE EXPOSED TO THE
SEVEN ALARM. THEY SHOULD NOT BE
FORCED TO STEP INTO RENDON'S
BEHAVIOR AS THEY SEEK TO
CONNECT WITH PEOPLE THE WORLD
IN ITS OPPORTUNITIES. I BELIEVE
STRONGLY THAT OUR GOVERNMENT
NEEDS TO PROTECT US AND IN A
CLEAR MESSAGE THAT THIS
BEHAVIOR IS HARMFUL DANGEROUS
AND IT SHOULD NOT BE TOLERATED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS CHRISTOPHER FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. WE WILL NOW
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO THREE. C.
NINE WE WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO CERTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY THREE. SEEN NONE.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ARVEST.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PRINT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY THREE WE WILL BEGIN.
SPORE COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. E. THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO BACK COMMAND AGAIN
ONE. ZERO IN LINE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS CHIANG
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MATURE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION THE COURT
OF SB FIFTY THREE THANK YOU. AN
ONLINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
YOU'RE MY COULD HELP. BY SHARE
MEMBERS ALEX SORENSON STRATEGY
THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF OF BLUE
TO HELP THE TRUMP SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AN ONLINE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. ONE OFTEN ON BEHALF OF
INTERNET ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THIS IS AN ONLINE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY ONE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING MEMBERS
DESERVE MICHELLE THOMAS SHOP
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. IN
LINE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. COOL HI
MY NAME'S HANNAH WHITE
REPRESENTING MYSELF I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE CHECK THE
LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY THREE PLEASE. SURE
FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. FIFTY THREE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. TECH COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
NOT FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM. ANY OPPOSITION WE DO
HAVE ONE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. THIS IS AN IBM
THESE PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON AND I'M
SPEAKING AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION WELL WE APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS TO SB FIFTY
THREE I'M WE RECOGNIZE THE
PROBLEM HERE AND THAT THE ISSUE
WE MUST REMAIN OPPOSED I AM
ALSO A TRAUMA SURVIVOR HOWEVER
I SHARE ALL OF THESE CONCERNS
OF THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. SB FIFTY THREE
CREATES YET ANOTHER NEW CRIME
I'LL BE AT THE NUMBER ACTION
EPA HAS PROPOSED THE CRIMINAL
INFRACTION BE DELETED AND ONLY
AMEND THE CIVIL CODE. TO ADD
THIS BEHAVIOR AS THE TORT. A
TORT REQUIRES THAT HARM B.
CREW. ANY INFRACTION DOES NOT
REQUIRE THIS PROVES. A COURT
WOULD ALLOW THE CIVIL COURTS TO
HANDLE THE ISSUE RATHER THAN
ONCE AGAIN INVOLVING THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM A CIVIL
MATTER COULD INVOLVE LAWYERS
HOWEVER ATTORNEYS FEES ARE
RECOVERABLE AN INFRACTION
ALLOWS YOU KNOW ATTORNEYS AND
MOST OF THIS CENTURY WOULD NOT
EVEN KNOW THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
A BENCH TRIAL. I STATE THIS
BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE OF FORTY
YEARS AND- CRIMINAL DEFENSE.
THE COURT WOULD ALLOW THE MONEY
JUDGMENT TO GO TO THE VICTIM
AND INFRACTION FINE COULD GO
BACK INTO THE SYSTEM COFFERS.
GPA IS FURTHER CONCERNED AT THE
IMPACT ON YOU. YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
SCIENTIFICALLY KNOWN TO BE MORE
IMPETUOUS AND SUSCEPTIBLE TO
PEER PRESSURE. YOU TO ENGAGE IN
THIS PRESCRIBED BEHAVIOR SHOULD
BE EDUCATED NOT CRIMINALLY
PUNISHED. LASTLY AN INFRACTION
COULD ACCORDING TO CASE LAW BE
USED AGAINST THEM INDIVIDUAL
AND IMMIGRATION PROCEEDINGS- IN
MAKING THIS BILL AS WRITTEN
POTENTIALLY DEVASTATING TO AN
IMMIGRANT. THERE HAS BEEN
CONCERN ABOUT WHETHER THIS
INFRACTION WOULD SHOW UP ON A
RAP SHEET AND I AM CONFIRM WITH
MEMBERS OF MY ASSOCIATION THAT
IT WOULD FOR THESE REASONS THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION REMAIN. OPPOSED TO
SB FIFTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS
COLE HOUSTON. WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO ZERO THREE SEVENTY
WITNESSES SEEN NONE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WHO WAS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIFTY THREE.
SEEN NINE. THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY THE OTHER
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PUMP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIFTY THREE
WE WILL BEGIN. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO U. S. B. FIFTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO. COMMAND AGAIN. ONE NINE
ZERO. THANK YOU MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
PARDON COMMENTS COMING THROUGH.
WOULD YOU MIND CHECKING THE
LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIFTY THREE PLEASE. FOR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
SIXTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
BENVIE ROAD. BACK COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS DO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. SENATOR
KAMLAGER THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I WAS JUST WONDERING FOR MURDER
IF YOU FROM WOULDN'T MIND
EITHER IN YOUR CLOTHES ARE NOW
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO THE CRIMINAL PUT
PROVISIONS AND THEN ALSO- HOW
THIS IMPACTS- JUVENILES IN
TERMS OF- THE POSSIBILITY OF A
CRIMINAL RECORD. I'M HAPPY TO
ADDRESS IT NOW THANK YOU-
CENTER CALL MARKER SO WE HAVE
BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OF
THE EIGHTY EIGHT THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S EXCUSE ME AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH THEM WE DID TAKE SOME
AMENDMENTS IN THIS BILL WHICH
YOU PROBABLY HAVE ACCESS TO AND
SHE SAID THEY DID NOT REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION WE'RE STILL
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TALKING WITH
THEM I KNOW THEY'RE GOOD
THEY'RE- IDEA IS TO ADDRESS IT
CIVILLY- THAT'S REALLY NOT WHAT
I'M INTENDING FOR THIS BILL TO
DO BUT AGAIN WE WILL CONTINUE
TALKING TO THEM. AND AS FAR AS-
JUVENILES IT WOULD BE THE SAME
WAY AS WITH ANY OTHER AT THE
HELM JUVENILES ARE TREATED NOW
WITH ANY OFFENSE IT AND I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW NO ONE
WANTS ANOTHER ANOTHER CRIME ON
THE BOOKS BUT THIS IS ABOUT
WOMEN AND THIS IS ABOUT WHEN DO
WE FINALLY VALUE WOMEN IN
SOCIETY. USED TO BE THAT WOMEN
WERE FLASHED IN THE PARK NOW
THIS IS CYBER FLASHING THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO KEEP UP WITH
THE TIMES AND WHEN YOU TALK TO
YOUNG WOMEN MUCH YOUNGER THAN
ME THEY WILL TELL YOU THAT
THEY'VE BEEN ON A BUS THEY'VE
BEEN SOMEPLACE AND SOMEONE
DROPS INAPPROPRIATE AIRDROPS
INAPPROPRIATE PICTURES TO THEM
IT IS PERVASIVE IT HAPPENS
ANYWHERE THERE YOU HAVE A PHONE
OR YOU'RE ON THE INTERNET AND
THIS IS JUST ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT WOMEN ARE NOT CONTINUE TO
BE THE OBJECT OF SOMEONE'S
SEXUAL GRATIFICATION WE KNOW
THE PEOPLE WHO USED TO FLASH IN
THE PARK DID IT BECAUSE THEY
GOT ENJOYMENT OUT OF IT. NOW WE
KNOW THE PEOPLE THAT SEND THESE
DELUDE IMAGES TWO WOMEN ARE
GETTING SOME SORT OF
GRATIFICATION OF IT THIS BILL
IS JUST TRYING TO AS MANY BILLS
HAVE DONE FINALLY TAKE AND SAY
WOMEN YOU ARE. VALUED WE HEAR
YOU WE SEE YOU AND WANT TO STOP
THIS BE. THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION. ANY OTHER FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER COME UNDER.
OKAY THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
COMMON QUESTION FROM SENATOR
SKINNER. AS A MATTER. THE
MANAGER WAS JUST A- LOOKING AT
THE AMENDMENTS IN LOOKING AT
THE TEXT OF THE BILL FROM. I. I
WAS THINKING A LOT ABOUT
WHETHER THEY SHOULD JUST BE
CIVIL. AND. I THIS IS TRICKY
BECAUSE IF IT'S. WHEN IT'S AN
ADULT TO MAYBE THE PERPETRATOR
OF THIS. IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
SEVERAL MEN OUT OF A GRADE OF
YEAH I MEAN SOLVE TRICKY BUT-
THE THREAT OF IT BEING CRIMINAL
AGAINST MAYES- IT'S NOT I DON'T
THINK PEOPLE. ARE AWARE OF WHAT
WE PUT IN PENAL CODE BEFORE THE
ACT HOWEVER IF THE WORD GETS
OUT. THAT SUCH AN ACTION COULD-
FIVE HAVE THIS CRIMINAL HAS PUT
IT ON YOUR RECORD. IT MAY
AFFECT SOME OF THESE ADULTS NOW
HOWEVER WHEN IT COMES TO
JUVENILES THAT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S EVER GOING TO BE IN
THEIR MINDS. AND I. I'M VERY
HESITANT ABOUT CREATING MORE.
MORE ABILITY FOR THERE TO BE A
CRIMINAL RECORD AGAINST
JUVENILE SENSE AND AGAIN I'M
NOT IN ANY WAY MINIMIZING THE
IMPACT ON ANY OF OUR YOUNG
WOMAN IF ONE OF. EITHER A
JUVENILE MALE. DOES SOMETHING
LIKE THIS TO A JUVENILE YOUNG
WOMAN THE IMPACT OF HER STILL
IT IS IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
AGE THAT. THE MAIL WAS AND NOW
I'M JUST TALKING GENDER
SPECIFIC THIS COULD ALSO HAPPEN.
IT COULD BE YEAH THE BOYS COULD
DO TO BOYS GIRLS COULD DO A TWO
BOYS ANY NUMBER. SO I BY I'M-
FOR THE PURPOSES OF MY POINT.
ARMS AND- IT'S. HOW TO REGULATE
JUVENILE BEHAVIORS HARD. AND
THE CONSEQUENCE OF RECORDS IS
REALLY REALLY SERIOUS ON A
JUVENILE AND I DON'T KNOW.
WHETHER THERE'S ANY POSSIBILITY
AND I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS
EXPLORED. WHETHER THERE COULD
BE SOME KIND OF DIFFERENT. FIVE
DOING THIS B. TREE THIS TREE
TERMINALS DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE
FOR ADULTS I'M FINE BYE BYE
PRECIADO. WHERE THE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ARE AND I AM NOT IN
ANY WAY MINIMIZING THIS I
COMPLETELY APPRECIATE FOR THE
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ARE COMING FOR
BECAUSE- TOO OFTEN NO MATTER
WHAT ARE GOOD INTENT IS WE KNOW
THE CONSEQUENCE OF HIS EIGHT.
JUST GOING TO BE FAR MORE
LIKELY FOR. THE ADULT MALE OF
COLOR TO GET THE CHARGER THE
CONVICTION THEN THE WHITE MAN-
HOWEVER I THINK FOR ADULTS DID
DID DID THIS DESERVES TO BE A
CRIME. AND SO I JUST CURIOUS
WHETHER THERE WAS ANY
DISCUSSION OR EXPLORATION OF
WHETHER WE COULD DO THIS
DIFFERENTLY FOR A JUVENILE. BE
VERY CANDID THE ISSUE ABOUT
JUVENILES LITERALLY JUST CAME
UP BEFORE I GOT HERE TO BRING
UP THE BILL SO WE'RE ALL HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TALKING ABOUT THAT.
AND YOU KNOW I WORRY ABOUT ARE
JUVENILES TO BUT I ALSO WORRY
ABOUT WHAT THE BECOME IF THEY
AREN'T TOLD THAT THIS BEHAVIOR
IS NOT OKAY AND THEN DO THEY
CONTINUE. TO PRACTICES BEHAVIOR
INTO ADULTHOOD SO COULD WE NIP
IT IN THE BUD- AND REALLY I
HEAR YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT
JUVENILES I DO WORRY ABOUT THAT
TO A MORE THAN HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TALKING ABOUT THAT.
BUT I JUST. WE WORRY SO MUCH
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO
THE MAN. BECAUSE THESE ARE
PREDOMINATELY CRIMES COMMITTED
AGAINST WINNER SANTA CRIME BUT
THERE. ARE THERE ARE THERE
WOMEN WHO RECEIVING THESE
PICTURES AND WE'RE SO WORRIED
ABOUT THIS ABOUT A MAN AND
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO HIM
WHAT ABOUT THE WOMAN WHO HAS TO
CONTINUALLY AND THE WOMEN. WHO
HAVE TO CONTINUALLY RECEIVE
THESE WINDOW WE VALUE WOMEN
WHEN DO WE SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO PUT A STOP TO
THIS WEEK. IN ALL ASPECTS OF
LIFE WE'RE GOING TO VALUE WOMEN
AND WE'RE GOING TO SAY THAT YES
MEANS YES AND NO MEANS NO.
WRONG WITH YOU THERE. I JUST I
AM. I DON'T THINK. THAT FOR
JUVENILE OF HAVING IT BE A
CRIME IS THE WAY TO SEND A
MESSAGE AND BECAUSE THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE SO. GREAT THAT
CRIMINAL RECORD THAT AND I-
THIS IS OUR LAST POLICY HEARING
RIGHT I'M I'M SORRY THAT I DID
NOT HAVE A LOOK MORE CAREFULLY
SO THAT I MIGHT HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO CALL OUR DOUBLES BEEN IN
PRINT FOR AWHILE AND WE
LITERALLY JUST GOT THE I
CONCERNS FROM BOTH OF YOU SO
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING ON IT
BUT- WE WORK WITH WHAT WE WERE
GIVEN AND WORK IT ON TEAM LABOR
BUT WE CAN INSTANTLY CHANGE
THINGS. I APPRECIATE. I JUST
WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE IN IF
THERE IS A WAY FOR. THE
COMMITTEE IF WHAT YOU KNOW IF
THIS MONTH FOR YOUR PROCEED
WITH THIS IF THERE'S A WAY FOR
THE COMMITTEE PERHAPS MAKE A
SUGGESTION. THAT THE AUTHOR
MIGHT CONSIDER AS IT MOVES
FORWARD. HOW TO TREAT AND I'M
NOT SAYING THAT THERE WOULD BE
NOTHING IN HERE FOR JUVENILES.
BUT THAT THERE WOULD BE YOU
KNOW SOME KIND OF PROCESS BUT
DIDN'T NECESSARILY CREATE. THAT
RECORD. THEN TECH CRIMINAL FOR
A RECORD. FIVE SO I'M NOT.
ADVOCATING THAT THERE BE NO
CONSEQUENCE FOR JUVENILE WHOLE
ENGAGED IN THIS WHICH IS A
DIFFERENT- REPAIR ALWAYS
WILLING TO LOOK AT ANYTHING
HERE ON THIS RIGHT NOW THIS
MINUTE YES I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE
CAN DO BUT WE ARE MORE THAN
WHAT I THINK ARE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY STAFF FOR PRETTY GOOD
EXPERTS ON THIS SO BY A MY
RAISING IT HOPEFULLY THEY- CAN
COME UP WITH SOMETHING AND-
MAKE A SUGGESTION. HOPEFULLY
YOU WILL IN FACT YOU WOULD
CONSIDER ABSOLUTELY. OKAY RIGHT
THOSE ARE THAT'S MY QUESTION
AND CONCERN. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER- AND I BELIEVE. WE
DON'T HAVE ANYONE HOMES HERE
AND THAT AND THE COMMITTEE SO
WELL I WOULD MOVE THE BILL OKAY
I WILL MOVE IT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS AND I'M GLAD THAT
THE YOU KNOW I'M GOOD I'M HAPPY
WITH THE AMENDMENTS AND I DO
WANT TO CONSEQUENCE. ESPECIALLY
TO ADULTS SAY ABSOLUTELY WANT A
CONSEQUENCE RIGHT PRECIADO
THROUGHOUT THE BRING IT I JUST
WANT A DIFFERENT ACTION FOR
JUVENILES. BUT I REMOVE IT NOW
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER-
CENTER LEAVE I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION REGARDS THE- AND I
KNEW IT NOW THIS IS I AND I
UNDERSTAND I CAN UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS THEY HAVE WITH THE
WITH THEIR TEENAGERS SPECIAL
WITH THE CULTURE OF YOUR
PRESSURE AND HOW THEIR BRAIN IS
WORKING DEVELOPMENTALLY WHERE
THEY ARE- DURING HIS TEEN
YEARS- PERHAPS- A WARNING OR
EIGHTY- NOT SURE. MAYBE FOR A
FIRST OFFENSE YOU KNOW A
WARNING SPECIALLY BECAUSE IT BE
VERY DIFFICULT FOR. YOUNG
ADULTS TO KNOW WHAT EXACTLY IS
THE LAW OF COURSE YOU KNOW IT
INFORMATION FLOWS REALLY
QUICKLY- THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA
SUPPORT BUT IN THE MEANTIME.
MAYBE A WARNING AND- AND I'M
NOT SURE HOW THAT WOULD LOOK
LIKE. BUT THEN- HAVING AN
OPPORTUNE TO SAY OKAY. THIS IS
NOT OKAY MOVING FORWARD HE WILL
HAVE THAT PENALTIES ON THAT AND
JUST SOMETHING TO EXPLORE- ON
THAT END- AND IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE I. I HAVE A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD SON AND- IT'S
INTERESTING HOW. YOU KNOW WE
REFERENCE THE YOUNG GIRLS BUT I
THINK YOU KNOW SENATOR SKINNER
INTERCOM MARGARET SPOKE ABOUT
YOUNG MEN AND I HAVE TO TELL
YOUNG WOMEN ARE VERY VERY
AGGRESSIVE IN TODAY'S TIME AS
WELL AND SO- I HAVE. THAT YOU
KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE FROM OTHER
MOTHERS AND SO FORTH HEARD HOW
AGGRESSIVE SOME YOUNG WOMEN ARE
WITH REGARDS TO SENDING IMAGES
TO YOUNG MAN- IN THAT EVER IT
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO TRY TO
VERY CHALLENGING TO BOTH RAISE
A YOUNG LADY AND A GENTLEMAN.
IN TWO DAYS TIME SO- I COMMEND
YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS IN IN IN
PURSUING THIS BILL AND- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
ENDEAVOR. ON BEHALF OF EVERYONE
WHO DOESN'T APPRECIATE
RECEIVING THESE KIND OF MATCH
THAT HAVE. IMAGES ON TAT END
AS HUNDRED EARLY BUT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU-
COMMAND VICE CHAIR. AND YES I
HAVE HEARD IT IS VERY DIFFICULT
TREATS CHILDREN IN THIS DAY AND
AGE I COULD NOT AGREE MORE- AND
I HAVE HEARD THAT SOME WOMEN A
YOUNG WOMEN ARE MORE.
AGGRESSIVE THAN THEY USED TO BE
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT YOUNG
WOMEN DO NOT GROW UP TO BE
RAPISTS. AND WHEN WE STOP YOUNG
MEN FROM DOING THESE THINGS WE
MIGHT BE POTENTIALLY STOPPING A
BEHAVIOR THAT COULD GET WORSE-
CURRENTLY TEAR POINT. YOU DO
HAVE TO SAY NO SO IF I SAY NO
DON'T SEND ME THE PICTURES AND
NO ONE SENDS MANY MORE PICTURES
EVERYTHING'S FINE BUT IF YOU
CONTINUE TO SEND ME THOSE LEWD
PICTURES AFTER I'VE SAID NO.
THAT'S WHEN THE FINE IS
IMPOSED- GOOD TO CENTER SKINNER
TO YOUR POINT SHOULD APPROACH
WRITE IT DOWN BUT I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. AND WE DON'T
WANT. OUR YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE
CAUGHT UP IN THE SYSTEM WE KNOW
THAT THEY DON'T ALWAYS KNOW
THAT THINGS ARE PUNISHABLE BY
LAW. BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
OVERWHELMINGLY WOMEN ARE THE
RECIPIENTS OF THESE PHOTOS
WOMEN ARE THE ONES WHO HAVE TO
LIVE WITH THE TRAUMA. AS MY
WITNESS. SHONA CHRISTOPHERSON
ED YOU CANNOT UNSEE THESE.
IMAGES AND I LOVE THAT SHE SAID
THE SHOW NOT BE NORM. AND I
BELIEVE BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE.
THESE LITTLE ELECTRONIC DEVICES
AND IT'S SO EASY TO DO THESE
THINGS BUT WE- WE START
INTERNALIZING AS- YEAH THAT
HAPPENS IT'S NO BIG DEAL. BUT
IT IS A BIG DEAL SO I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES- CAN.
QUESTIONS AND CONSIDERATION OF
THE BILL. AND HAVE ALWAYS HAPPY
TO LOOK AT ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS AND WITHOUT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR SKINNER. MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIFTY THREE LABOR DAY PASSED
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD A TROUBLED BY TROUBLE
GUY COM LONGER SKINNER. SKINNER
AYE WIENER ALL THE ROLE OPEN
YES WE WILL PUT THAT BUILT ON
CALL FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER. WE WILL NOW MOVE ONTO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO- ACTUALLY.
ALL. WE WILL BE MOVING ON TO
ITEM THREE SB THREE SEVENTEEN
BY SENATOR STERN WE'RE GOING TO
BE CHECKING TO SEE IF HE IS
READY. TO PRESENT. THE ONLY.
THE. ON.
THE HOBBIT. THE. A LOT
OF.
WE STILL HERE. HELLO YES WE
ARE CURRENTLY WAITING TO SEE IF
OUR NEXT SENATOR IS ON ABLE TO
JOIN US SERRANO I'M SORRY. ARE
YOU WILLING TO TESTIFY. YES I
AM. SHE. OKAY MA'AM IF YOU ARE
ON ZERO WE NEED YOU TO HAVE
YOUR DEVICES ON MUTE. THANK YOU.
THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WILL BE ED TAKING A
RECESS FOR ABOUT TWENTY
MINUTES- WHILE WE WAIT TO HAVE
OUR NEXT- SENATORS- COME IN
THAT PRESENT THEIR BILLS SO WE
WILL RETURN AT. TWO FORTY SEVEN
LET'S RUN IT UP TO TWO FIFTY.
WILL BE BACK AT TWO FIFTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME WE
ARE NOW BACK WITH THE SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
RESUMING WITH SENATOR. WELCOME
SENATOR ALSO. THANK YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL AND SB FOUR
EIGHT ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS CHAIR VICE CHAIR. AND
MEMBER I WAS PREPARED TO SAY
MEMBERS BUT MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. YES I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AS BEFORE EIGHTY ONE A
BILL THAT WILL RETURN TO JUDGES
THE ABILITY TO STRIKE OR
DISMISS SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS AND ALSO
CREATE A CAREFUL PROCESS FOR
YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS. TO HAVE
THEIR SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS
REASSESSED BY A JUDGE IN
NINETEEN NINETY CALIFORNIA
PROPOSITION ONE FIFTEEN REMOVED
FROM JUDGES THE ABILITY TO USE
ANY OF THEIR JUDICIAL
DISCRETION. AVAILABLE
PRECEDENCE OR MITIGATING
FACTORS TO ASSESS WHETHER A
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE CHARGE TO
AN INDIVIDUAL IS NECESSARY OR
APPROPRIATE TO THE CASE AT HAND
OR THE NEEDS OF PUBLIC SAFETY
AS A CONSEQUENCE THIS CREATED A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL PROCESS. THAT
PREVENTS ANY KIND OF SENTENCE
CONSIDERATION AND APPLIES TO
NEARLY EVERY SINGLE CASE THAT
RESULTED IN A SENTENCE OF LIFE
WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE. FOR VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ABUSE OR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
OR INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE EIGHTEEN
AT THE TIME OF THE CRIME
INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
ACCESSORIES OR INCIDENTAL TO A
CRIME THERE IS NO OPPORTUNITY
FOR A JUDGE TO CONSIDER ANY OF
THESE RELEVANT MITIGATING
FACTORS. THIS PROHIBITION IS A
RELIC FROM MY TOUGH ON CRIME
ERA THAT SERVED ONLY AS A
BARRIER TO THE FURTHERANCE OF
JUSTICE AND REHABILITATION IN
OUR COURT SYSTEM. HIS BEFORE
ANYONE ALSO INSTRUCTS JUDGES TO
GIVE ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATION
TO THE STRIKING OR DISMISSAL OF
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES. TO
YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS THAT
COMMITTED THEIR OFFENSE AT AGE
TWENTY FIVE OR YOUNGER AND HAVE
SERVED FIFTEEN YEARS OF THEIR
SENTENCE. THE LEGISLATURE IS
ALREADY TAKEN A NUMBER OF STEPS
TO ALIGN PUBLIC POLICY WITH
MAINSTREAM RESEARCH AND
EVIDENCE ON THE DAHLE
DEVELOPMENT. THAT RESEARCH IS
CLEAR THAT AREAS OF THE BRAIN
PARTICULAR PARTICULARLY RELATED
TO JUDGMENT AND DECISION MAKING
ARE NOT FULLY DEVELOPED UNTIL
THE EARLY TO MID TWENTIES. THAT
HAS LED TO THE ADOPTION OF LAWS
THAT KNOWLEDGE A YOUTHFUL
OFFENDERS DIMINISHED CRIMINAL
CRIMINAL CULPABILITY. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY THEIR INCREASED
POTENTIAL FOR GROWTH AND
REHABILITATION. IT IS
APPROPRIATE AND NECESSARY THE
JUDGES INCORPORATE THESE FACTS
WHEN ASSESSING THE SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE ENHANCEMENTS OF A
YOUTHFUL OFFENDER AS BEFORE
EIGHTY ONE THEREFORE INSTRUCTS
JUDGES TO INCLUDE AN EVALUATION
OF THE RELEVANT SOCIAL
DEVELOPMENTAL AND BIOLOGICAL
MITIGATING FACTORS AND PRESUME
TO DISMISS A SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES ENHANCEMENT. WHEN
THE CASE INVOLVES AN OFFENDER
THAT WAS TWENTY FIVE YEARS OR
YOUNGER AT THE TIME OF THEIR
OFFENSE AND HAS SERVED FIFTEEN
YEARS OF THEIR SENTENCE. UNDER
SB FORTY ONE JUDGES WOULD BE
TRAINED FULL DISCRETION TO
ASSESS ALL OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THE CASE AND TO MAKE THEIR
DECISION TO ENSUREAN OUTCOME
THAT PROVIDES FOR THE
FURTHERANCE OF JUSTICE AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. THIS BILL ALSO
INCLUDES A REQUIREMENT THAT A
COURT PROVIDE INFORMATION TO
THE SURVIVORS AND SURVIVING
FAMILY MEMBERS OF THE VICTIM.
ARE OFFERED INFORMATION ABOUT
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO ADDRESS
THEIR NEEDS AS THIS COURT
PROCESS PLAYS OUT. THE
JUDICIARY HAS A ROBUST PROCESS
IN PLACE- THAT IS ABOUT TO
ENSURE THAT THE NEEDS OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY ARE MET. THIS
BILL LET'S NO ONE OUT OF
PRISON- ABSOLVES ANYONE FROM
THEIR SENTENCE OR THEIR
OBLIGATION TO FACE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEIR
ACTIONS IN EVERY SINGLE CASE AN
INDIVIDUAL WOULD FIRST. NEED A
JUDGE TO DECIDE OR TO DISMISS
OR STRIKE A SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. SHOULD THAT MAKE
THEM ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE THEY
WOULD THEN NEED TO APPEAR
BEFORE A PAROLE BOARD. AND
DEMONSTRATE THEIR SUITABILITY
FOR PAROLE AND FINALLY THE
pOVER ANY PAROLE CASES THIS IS
NOT A SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE
WILL BE ABLE TO SLP THROUGH
THE CRACKS. THERE ARE ABUNDANT
GUARDRAILS IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THIS PROCESS PLAYS OUT UNDER
STRICT SCRUTINY AT EVERY SINGLE
STAGE. TOP ON CRIME IN ONE SIZE
FITS ALL POLICIES HAVE NOT
SOLVED THE PROBLEMS FACING THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM NOR ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES. SB
FORTY ONE CREATES A CAREFUL
MODERATE PROCESS TO ALLOW
JUDGES TO EVALUATE AN
INDIVIDUAL'S BACKGROUND AND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES SURROUNDING THEIR
OFFENSE SO THAT THEY CAN
EXERCISE THEIR DISCRETION ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS. MY
WITNESSES TODAY WILL BE GUNNER
JOHNSON A CRIME SURVIVOR
IMPACTED VICTIM. AND OUTREACH
DIRECTOR AT PROJECT REBOUND CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO AND
PROFESSOR HEIDI RUMMEL OF THE
USC GOULD SCHOOL OF LAW POST
CONVICTION JUSTICE PROJECT
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU
SENATOR TO ROSTER FOR
PRESENTING YOUR BILL ON SB
FORTY ONE WE WILL NOT CONTINUE
TO ARE AT LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES- IS GONNA JOHNSON THE
LINE. I AM PLEASE PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY YES ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU. YOUR QUESTION
BRADFORD AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME'S GONNA JOHNSON I'M
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY ONE FIND A SURVIVOR OF AN
ATTEMPTED MURDER I LOOK IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT TRYING TO
PEOPLE MY BEDROOM WITHOUT A
WORD ONE OF THEM SHOT ME TWICE.
BUT I WAS THE FORTUNATE ONE
BOYFRIEND PATRICK KLEIN WAS
SHOT AND KILLED BUDGET
SURVIVING VICTIM WITNESS I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY PURCHASE
SPENDING A CRIMINAL PROSECUTION
WHICH RESULTED IN BOTH
PERPETRATORS BEING TERMS TO
LIFE IN. PRISON WITHOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE. TWENTY
FIVE YEARS LATER THIRTY CALIBER
BULLET REMAINS LODGED RIGHT NOW.
RANGERS WERE SEVERE BUT THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT OF THE
CRIME DURING LONG AFTER I HEAL
PHYSICAL. CHAMA PROPELLED ME
INTO A DOWNWARD SPIRAL I BECAME
ADDICTED TO OPIATES WHICH I WAS
EXPOSED TO FOR THE FIRST TIME
WHILE RECOVERING FROM GUNSHOT
WOUNDS. SO MY USE OF OPIATES
WAS INITIALLY FOR MARKETS-
INTRINSYC GRADUALLY BEGAN TO
RELY ON THEM TO MEDICAID PARTS
LIKE A LOGICAL LOOMS. I LIVE
WITH THE SURVIVOR'S GUILD ON
TREATY PTSD AND THAT'S WHAT YOU
SEE DRUGS UNTIL I GOT SOBER
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO. IT'S A BY
THE HOURS INTO THE ANGER KERRY
BOTH OF THE MEN THAT HARM. I
DECIDED TO WRITE LETTERS BOTH
MEN. COMMISSION NINETEEN SHOT
ME RESPOND AGAIN THAT'S WITH
THIRTY AMEND LETTER THAT
PROVIDED ME SOME INSIGHT TO
THIS TRIAL TRAUMA. DEEPER MORE
INSTEAD TO TAKE TO TURN HIS
LIFE AROUND. TWENTY FOUR YEARS
AFTER THE CRIME. I COULD SEE
THE SINCERITY IN HIS LETTER I
THOUGHT HE DESERVED A CHANCE A
RELEASE. THAT HE WAS GOING TO
DIE IN PRISON. I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT EVERYONE
CHANGES WHAT I AM SAYING
HOWEVER IS THAT DURING MY OWN
PROCESS TO GROW BY LEARNING.
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO CAUSE
TREMENDOUS HARM CAN BECOME
HEALTHY ADULTS WHO HAVE A LOT
TO OFFER SOCIETY. CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT LAW GIVES SECOND
CHANCES TO USE UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN CENTS A LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE. I SUPPORT SB FORTY ONE
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS SOMEONE WHO
DISPLAYS MEANINGFUL CHANGE A
CHANCE TO PROVE TO THE COURT.
THE PROBOARDS THEIR FAMILY
JACQUI TIDY THAT THEY CAN BE
CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS. SB FORTY
ONE WOULD REQUIRE YOUR SERVING
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE TO PROVE
WHAT THEY HAD DONE THE WORK
YOUR CONSIDERATION WOULD STILL%
REQUIRE. THEM TO CHILDREN IN
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. I SAFER
KNOWING THAT JUDGES ARE HAVE
DISCRETION TO GRANT WHETHER PER
DRAMATICALLY TURNED LIFE AROUND.
AFTER SHE ON ON USE AT THE OF
TWENTY FIVE OR BELOW AT THE-
THANKS. SB FORTY ONE THE BOARD
THE GOVERNOR TOLD ME DECIDED
THEIR FIRST SHOULD EVER. WHO
THANK YOU SIR BYE AUTHORIZED
TECHNICAL BOARD HERE CAN I KNOW
JUST OUR- PROPHECY. SB FORTY
ONE PROVIDE CONNECTS WHICH ARE
FORMS. THAT OUR- TO KILL SOME
THROUGH. KEPT ARCHER FROM YOU
ARE. I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
FORTY BECAUSE I HAVE WITH THAT
WHO COMMIT VIOLENT CRIME CAN BE
INTO THE- PROPOSALS PEOPLE. WE
ALL BENEFIT WHEN THEY ARE ABOUT
OPERA TO CHARGES. ARGUED ABOUT
I THANK YOU SLICE. THANK YOU
SOME FOR YOUR TESTING. AND THE
BENNETT MISTER JOE. WHO NOT
CONTINUE WITH. RUMMEL ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. HI AND THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED YOUR WITH YOUR
PERSON BRAD. I WANT TO PRISON
BRADFORD COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. MY NAME IS HEIDI
RUMMEL AND I'M A LAW PROFESSOR
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I DIRECT THE COPD
CONVICTION JUSTICE PROJECT.
AFTER TWELVE YEARS I SERVED AS
A FEDERAL PROSECUTOR KRISTEN
WASHINGTON DC AND LATER IN LOS
ANGELES. I PROSECUTED THE MOST
SERIOUS CRIME RAPE MURDER GANG
VIOLENCE HUMAN TRAFFICKING I
HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE IMPACT
OF VIOLENCE ON VICTIMS
SURVIVORS AND ON OUR COMMUNITY.
I SUPPORT SB FORTY ONE BECAUSE
IT RETURNS DISCRETION TO JUDGES
IN A BALANCED WAY. SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY IN EVERY CASE
WHERE DISTRICT ATTORNEY PURSUED
A SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE
ALLEGATION LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE
THE MANDATORY SENTENCE. BOB
CALIFORNIA LAW HAS TWENTY
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
INCLUDING THIRTEEN DIFFERENT
FELONIES ELEVATE A MURDER LIFE
SENTENCE TO AL WHAT MURDER BY
AN EXPLOSIVES OR BY POISON OR
BY SHOOTING A GUN FROM A CAR AS
PART OF THE STREET GANG FOR
FINANCIAL GAIN IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE ROBBERY AND BURGLARY
KIDNAPPING OR CARJACKING OR
ANYONE OF NINE OTHER FELONIES.
TODAY THERE ARE NEARLY SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE DESERVING L.
LOCK SENTENCED TO DIE IN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS. SOME DID
NOT KILL OR INTENT TO KILL SOME
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES. MOST
WERE TEENAGERS OR USE AT THE
TIME OF THE CRIME. AND TWO
THIRDS OF BLACK COMMITTEE NEXT.
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE SHOULD NOT
BE A MANDATORY SENTENCE BASED
ON THE DA'S FILING DECISION AT
THE OUTSET OF THE KING. SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU ARE LESS
CULPABLE. AND HAS PASSED
MEASURED LAWS TO SUPPORT SECOND
CHANCES FOR PEOPLE IN PRISON
WHO HAD DONE THE HARD WORK TO
REHABILITATE. NONE OF THOSE
LAWS ARE GET OUT OF JAIL FREE
CARDS AND NEITHER IS DISPELLED.
SB FOUR EIGHTY ONE ASSEMBLY
RETURNS DISCRETION TO JUDGES TO
STRIKE A SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE.
AFTER WEIGHING ALL THE RELEVANT
EVIDENCE THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ARGUMENT. THE
VICTIMS FAMILY MEMBERS
STATEMENT. AND EVEN WHEN A
JUDGE EXERCISES THAT DISCRETION
THE PERSON REMAIN CONVICTED OF
FIRST DEGREE MURDER SERVING A
TWENTY FIVE YEAR LIFE SENTENCE
AT A MINIMUM. WITH THE ONLY
POSSIBILITY FOR RELEASED TO THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS WITH
THE APPROVAL OF THE GOVERNOR.
ROLE REQUIRES THE BOARD AND THE
GOVERNOR TO MAKE A RIGOROUS
PUBLIC SAFETY DETERMINATION.
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM RATE IS
20% RECIDIVISM RATE FOR THOSE
RELEASED TO PAROLE IS LESS THAN
3% SB FOUR EIGHTY ONE BALANCES
PUBLIC SAFETY WITH CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO SECOND CHANCES
FOR THOSE WHO DO THE HARD WORK
TO CHANGE THEIR LIVES I
STRONGLY URGE AND I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
MISERABLE WILL NOT CONTINUE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOUR EIGHTY ONE. HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEEING NONE
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES
IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR EIGHTY ONE SEEING NONE
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY AT
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOUR EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
I COMMANDED CAN. ONE ZERO.
THANK YOU LINE TWO HUNDRED.
NINE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. IN LINE. THREE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN AIRLINERS OKAY. MISTER
NAZARIAN FAMILY TONIGHT AND
LYFT WITHOUT INSURANCE SUPPORT
AND FLEET FOR A- STE. BLIND
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. OUR STELLAR CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY ONE FROM
THE INSIDE OUT DURING THAT
TRANSITIONAL HOMES AND
CALIFORNIA. IMPACTED FAMILIES
PROJECT. BLIND OF FOUR HUNDRED
SEVEN YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MCDANIEL
ON BEHALF OF THE PLACE AGREES
IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. LINE
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON SENATORS MY NAME IS GINA
HERNANDEZ SUNLAND FUEL AND
INITIATE CHANCES TO SAVE THE
COMMITTEE TIME A LIST OF NEARLY
FOUR HUNDRED SUPPORTERS OF SB
FORTY ONE HAS BEEN FORWARDED TO
EACH COMMITTEE MEMBER AND
STRONG SUPPORT SB FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR HUNDRED SIX
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL SANTOS FROM FONTANA
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB.
FOUR EIGHTY ONE. ONE THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. NO CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ESPANA AS WITH
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION A
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND POPS APART
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS JIM WEINBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE THREE
HUNDRED NINETY NINE HERE MY
KIDS OPEN. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. FIND A ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY YOUR MARKETS OPEN. HI
YES MY NAME IS CELINA BASKET
CITY OF LOS ANGELES RESIDENT
AND I AM SUPPORT SB. FORTY ONE.
BLINDNESS THREE HUNDRED NINETY
ONE YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN. I NEED
THIS IS VIRGINIA QATADA I'M
FROM CLOVIS CALIFORNIA CALLING
IN SUPPORT AND SENATE BILL
FORTY ONE THANK YOU. PINE THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HELLO. WHAT WE CAN
HELLO THANK YOU SORRY ABOUT
THAT HI MY NAME IS ABLE GRAYSON
INSURANCE CENTER ON BEHALF OF
THE YOUNG WOMAN'S BEEN A CENTER
CROWDS POST YOUR NAME PROUD CO
SPONSOR THIS EVENT BEFORE YOU
WENT TO SAY THE COMMITTEE TIME
WITH INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
I'LL BE READING OFF THE LIST
THE ORGANIZATIONS WILL GIVEN
AFTER PERMISSION. IF THEY THEIR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SO WE HAVE
CHILDREN'S THE FENCE LINE THE
CALIFORNIA FOR THANK YOU JESS.
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER W.
HEY WOULD YOU TO SILICON VALLEY
DE BUG FRESNO BARRIOS UNIDOS.
ANKARA HOPE INTERNATIONAL
MINISTRIES INCORPORATED
INITIATE JUSTICE AND PROJECT
YOUR FAMILY HAD A AND L. WHILE
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS THE CALL FAMILY CHILD
CARE YOUNG WOMAN FREEDOM CENTER
COMMITTEE UNITED FOR STARTED
THIS IS. CRAP SO WHAT COALITION
HAILING DIALOGUE AND ACTION
KERN COUNTY BUT TO SUPPORT TO
THE BEFORE A DEFENSE AND THE
NEED THAT CARE VIA. D. A. Y.
THE J. HILLS PROJECT COMMUNITY
DINNER PROTECT THE PROJECT. THE
W. P. ELLENBERGER ELEMENT PART
A. L. COAST COMMUNITY DEVELOP
CENTER HI FOR GREAT PRESENT
FROM THE AND OUT CORPORATE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. PLAN
FOR HER TWENTY ONE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. AMERICAN
POLITICIANS THAT ANNA. AT.
EIGHT FOUR EIGHT ONE. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED NINETEEN YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. BOB. ONE FOUR HUNDRED
NINETEEN YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
BLIND FOUR HUNDRED NINE YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. LINE. FOUR
HUNDRED NINE. BLIND THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ON THE IBM
FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I'M
THE COURT. AT THE. FORTY ONE.
ONE FOUR HUNDRED FOUR YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. HI MY. THANKS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS MR JI ADA AND I'M
AT- I AM IN LOVE CALIFORNIA FOR
SB. FORTY ONE. BLIND THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE NEAR MY
COULD OPEN. LINE. THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE. WINDS THREE HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
CLAUDIA GUTIERREZ I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FORTY ONE
YEAR. WINDS. THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE. PINE THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. NINE TWO HUNDRED
NINETEEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
KARLEY TERRIBLE DAILY READERS
AND THERE AND I AM A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB. FOUR EIGHTY
ONE. LINE. THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT. MY NAME IS DIANE VON-
FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA AND
I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHT ONE. BLIND A THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT. HI MY NAME
IS OLENA BONNIE AND I AM FROM
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I AM A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE. FORTY
ONE. ONE FOUR HUNDRED TEN. HI
THIS IS AMERICANS ALONG COUNTY.
SIGN A GOOD. FOR ONE. NINE
THREE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT.
NINE THREE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. MY NAME
IS IN THE CONTRACT- LAS VEGAS
NEVADA WHEN I STARTED TO PORT
SB EIGHT FOUR EIGHTY ONE THANK
YOU. BLIND. FOUR HUNDRED. HELLO
MY NAME IS IRENE CALDERON
RECHARGING OF THE BEIJING
CORRECTIONS OFFICER FROM INDIO
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FORTY ONE. BLIND.
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTEEN. HI THIS
IS THE ONLY RODRIGUEZ HI I AM A
MEMBER OF FAMILIES UNITED AND
L. Y. AND POINT AND BE FORTY
ONE AND I AN ALLEY COUNTY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BLIND ONE.
EIGHTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS ANA
LIRA AND I AM CALLING FROM
FRESNO CALIFORNIA I AM AND
CALLING TO SUPPORT SB FOR EACH
ONE THANK YOU. BLINDNESS. THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO. HI KI<c.cyan>.</c>
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. HI MY NAME
IS BLANCA MUSTANG AND I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH FAMILY UNITED TO
END OF LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE AND
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR EIGHTY ONE AND I URGE YOU
TO BOTH YES ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU. A LINE OF. HUNDRED
FIFTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M A
MARINO CALIFORNIA CONSTITUENTS
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. BLIND.
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY YOU WANT
TO GET ON THE DAY. HELLO HELLO
WE AREA. BOB WITH BIGGER
SUPPORT S. B. FORTY ONE THANK
YOU A GOOD DAY. BLIND HOW
TWENTY. HI MY NAME SHOWS UP AN
APOLLO. A PROLIFE FOR MEASURE
SOUP S. B. ANYONE THANK YOU.
FINE. FOR HUNDRED TWENTY TWO.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMANDA CAL IN
TERMS OF AS. FOUR ONE AND URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES. CONCRETE.
BLIND. FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
GREEN I'M CALLING PAPER JUST
TWENTY NINE AND I'M INSTRUCTED
BEFORE T. R. F. BEFORE I'M
SORRY SB FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN I'M.
FOR EIGHTY ONE. PINE. FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR. YES TRYING
TO LOG ON SANTA CLARITA CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. NINE FOUR HUNDRED
FIVE. BLIND FOUR HUNDRED FIVE
YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. PINE. FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN. HI MY
NAME IS THE ONLY A DEAD MAN
WITH SILICON VALLEY DE BUG IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHT
ONE THANK YOU. BLIND. FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE- HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU
OKAY MY NAME IS ANITA HILL. AND
I'M FROM LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA
AND I'M IN STRONG FOR A BI. I
MEAN I'M SORRY. SB. FOUR EIGHTY
ONE THANK YOU. ONE FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE. HI MY NAME IS IAN
ALLEY BRODY AND I STRONGLY HAS
TO BE FOR ONE THANK YOU. ONE
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT. HI MY
NAME IS CLAUDIA ESPINOZA I AM
FROM RECEIVE I CAN. AND I AM SO
SUPPORTER OF SB. EIGHTY ZERO.
AND ALLOW. FOR HUNDRED FORTY.
WHEN I AM SB HE WENT DOWN. AND
LINE FOR HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN.
FIND FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. THIS STEVEN
GREEN- I'M IT'S SUPPOSED
SUPPORT OF FORTY ONE. THANK YOU.
LINE FOUR HUNDRED FIVE IT MIGHT
GET OPEN. CRISTINA MENDOZA WITH
FAMILY UNITED AND L. YOU FOR
EACH ONE THANK YOU. IN LINE FOR
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN. FILENE
CALL FROM ORANGE COUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF A B. EIGHTY ONE
THANK YOU. IN LINE FOR HER.
FIFTY FOUR. HELLO THIS IS
CHRISTINE CLIFFORD WITH SILICON
VALLEY DE BUG IN SAN JOSE AND I
AM CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS BEFORE ANYONE THANK YOU.
AND MADAM CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND CHECKING THE
LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE WITH OUR
HEARD FROM ALL OF- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY ONE.
SHARE OR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. FOUR EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE
HAVE A FEW MORE PEOPLE QUEUING
UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH LIKE A.
GRAHAM ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE.
IN LINE FOUR HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO
WE CAN HEAR YOU. HI MY NAME IS
TONY COASTAL BEGIN I'M FROM
GLENDALE CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. ONE THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE. FIVE
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HELLO
HELLO WE CAN AREA HELLO THIS IS
VALERIE FROM BUZZFEED BROWN
FONTANA CALIFORNIA I AM
STRONGLY AND OF SB FOUR EIGHTY
ONE THANK YOU. BLINDED. THREE
HUNDRED TWO. HELLO WE CAN YOU
WELL. PRIMARK MISTER FOUR OF.
LONG. WHY FOUR TWENTY NINE.
HELLO MY NAME JOHN I'M AND I'M
CALLING SUPPORT OF AS FOUR ONE
THANK YOU. BLIND. HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE. VENDOR JOHNSON
CENTER CAL STRONG SENATE BILL
CLINTON. BLIND. FOR FIFTY ONE.
HELLO ARE YOU. HELLO WE CAN
AREA. HI MY NAME IS MARI MAYES
CALLS SERVICE WILL COME IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. COM AS
BEING FOR ONE. WHY. FOR
HUNDRED. HELLO HELLO WE CAN
HEAR YOU. HELLO. HELLO WE CAN
HEAR YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY
NAME IS WILL BE C¡ THE NUMBERS
OF SB MORE. PAN LINE. FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY NINE. HELLO MY
NAME IS ADRIAN DAVIS AND ON
BEHALF OF MY HUSBAND WHO IS A
COMMUNITY ALL UP I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT SB FOUR EIGHTY ONE
THANK YOU. PINE THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR. HI MY NAME IS A
REALLY IS MAGGIE I'M CALLING
FROM SERVICES CALIFORNIA AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. TRENDLINES. THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE HELLO
THANK. HELLO THE ALLIANCE
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE GO AHEAD.
HELLO WE CAN AREA. HI MY NAME
IS SEAN TURNIP HELLO COUNTY. SB.
FOUR EIGHTY ONE. MADAM CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER CA AT THE
TIME. THANK THE MISTER MAHER.
HAVING HER FROM ALL SUPPORT WE
WILL NOW FOR THE SAME PROCESS
AND HERE FROM CAN OFFICE. WE DO
HAVE ONE THE- WITNESS IN UP
MISS MARC AMADOR FROM CHIEF OF
A PALETTE TRAINING DIVISION
SENDING DISTRICT OFFICE MISTER
I'M OUR YOU ON THE LAW. I AM.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY SIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON
BRADFORD AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MARK AMADOR I AM THE
CHIEF OF THE APPELLATE DIVISION
IN THE SAN DIEGO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND I'M
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF MY
OFFICE AND THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FORTY ONE. I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
IT IS CAN HOW THE PASSAGE OF
THIS BILL. DUE TO ITS RETRO.
PROVISION WILL RE TRAUMATIZE
MANY MANY INNOCENT PEOPLE. HAVE
ALREADY GONE THROUGH THE WORST
PAIN IMAGINABLE. BUT BILIC
TAKING OF THE LIFE OF A LOVED
ONE. AT THE TWENTY PLUS YEAR
HOMICIDE PROSECUTOR I'VE SPENT
COUNTLESS HOURS WITH FAMILIES
OF MURDER VICTIMS. THERE'S
NOTHING AS DESTRUCTIVE TO A
FAMILY AND THE COMMUNITY AT THE
MURDER. MY MEMORIES ARE GOOD AT
SITTING WITH A FAMILY MEMBER
WAS SITTING WITH THE FAMILY
WHOSE TEENAGER WAS SHOT AND
KILLED. THE FAMILY IS IN DEEP
MOURNING THEY'RE VERY KEEN.
CHECK THE CLEANING THE TO THEM.
FIND OUT. AN EMPATH. TALKING
WITH THEM EVERY OF THE THROUGH
THE GROUP LINK. PER MILLE
JUSTICE PROP THAT AND THE MORE.
HELLO THEY USUALLY MUST SIT AND
TESTIFY IN AMER TRIAL. BY AFTER
GUILT BY. OF MURDER AND A
SPECIAL CIRCUIT THE PROFIT
OBVIOUSLY COMMON IN A HEARING
WHERE AGAIN THE ADDRESS COURT
AND ALL OF THE WAITING. AND
THAT IN PROCESS. BUT P. AND
TRAUMA. JUDGE BY NEEDS AN TO
THE MURDER THEIR LOVE ONES TO
LIFE THE- OF PAROLE. NO TRUE
EMOTIONAL QUOTE BUT IS CLOSE TO
THE GAS FOR THE- OF THEM THE
LEGAL OF COMPILED. VICTIMIZE
ANOTHER FAMILY AGAIN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION SPEAK
UP. BY NOW WITH THE INTERNAL
CASE ON BEHALF OF THE VICTIMS
OF CRIME UNDER ARTICLE ONE
SECTION TWENTY EIGHT IT'S ALSO.
THE ARMY'S OF THESE MURDER
VICTIMS RELY ON THE PROMISE
FROM THE STATE THAT THE MURDER
WON'T GET OUT BUT IT'S A NAPKIN
SB FOUR EIGHTY ONE WHAT UP AND
NOW BELIEVE. PEOPLE CONVICT OF
MURDER WITH SPECIAL. AS WE ALL
KNOW ARE THE WORST OF THE
WORST. AND TO ALLOW EVERYONE OF
THOSE CONVICTED AND SENTENCED
TO PETITION THE COURT. FOR
RESENTENCING WOULD UNFAIRLY
REOPEN THE WOUND UP THOUSANDS
OF VICTIMIZED PERSONS IN
CALIFORNIA. IF THAT. BY THE
TICKET THAT PROTESTS AROUND
NOTED WHICH WAS SIX PEOPLE SIR
A LOCKING CALIFORNIA PRESENTS
AND ALL OF THOSE PETITION ABOUT
THOUSANDS AND OF. I AM MEMBERS
OF THE- WELL A BE REACH. IF WE
CUT THE RETROACTIVITY AFFECTIVE
THE BILL IT UNNECESSARY AND
WRONG. FOR THOSE SERVING L.
WHAT MAY BE WORTHY OF LESSENING
THEIR STAND HIM. BACKPACKING
CHANCE WE ALL BELIEVE. THAT
STATE WITHOUT THERE ARE. IN OUR
LETTER NOT BE WE OUT EXAMPLES
OF GOVERNOR NEWSOM. CENTER OF
MURDER A LOT. EVEN THAT THEY
DESERVE IT. AND THOSE WHO WHO
DID THIS WHEN ARE EIGHT TO
TWENTY FIVE AND JUSTICE. BEEN
THERE TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM. THIS
BILL DOES JUST APPLY TO EACH TO
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD WHO
COMMITTED MURDER. EVERY THAT
THE MURDER. SERVING WALKED
INCLUDING KILLERS MAY MURDER
CHAU KILLERS CAUGHT KILLER.
WHENEVER AND WHATEVER AGE THE
COMMUNITY CRIME. FINALLY HAVE
BEFORE ONE GET THAT BAD POLICY
BUT THE PROVIDE EVERY. EVERY
PER. ALL CAN BE OF DEGREE. THE
OP OF WHAT'S BEST CIRCUMSTANCE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET NEW HERE.
SPEAKING OF IN THEIR SAN. IT
WILL OPEN THE FLOODGATES TO
MANY I'M DESERVE CONVICTED MY
DURING FRIEDMAN THEIR- AT THE
TOP OF. IT WILL BRING
TRAUMATIZED THEM MEMBERS AND
FRIENDS OF THE MURDER- AS I
STATED BUT ALSO IT WILL
OVERWHELM AND ALL BACK WHILE
JUST THEM. WHAT HUNDRED DIDN'T
AT FRANKLY THOUSANDS OF. YOU
CAN GET A SIGNIFICANTLY OF
WORKLOAD OF UP DEFENDER IMAGE.
AND JUDGE. TO DO THEIR BEST YOU
WOULD HOPE IT DEMOCRATS BACK
THAT WE ALREADY- ALLOWING THE
PETITION TO GO FOR WITH THE-
WITH THE FIRST SERVING OUT WHAT.
IS THE IDEA. EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF PAGES AS YOU BE CALL THE
SALE MEMBERS OF THE MURDER
VICTIM AND ALLOW THEM. THAT
THEIR LAW NIGHTMARE IS NOT OVER.
IT IS BEING BROUGHT TO COURT
AGAIN. FINALLY THE LEAD TO
BUYERS CHANGE THE LAW AND ALLOW
PER JUDITH THIS. TO FORGET
SPECIAL CERTAIN. INCLUDING
GOING. THAT'S ONE THING. EIGHTY
EIGHT BY ME CAN PRINT THE DAM
THE BILL THAT POP. AFTER THE
PRESIDENT. IN AN AND- THING.
BUT YOU'RE THROUGHOUT THE OPEN
UP THOUSANDS OF. IN OF FIRST
DEGREE MURDER BUT CERTAIN. WILL
BE THERE QUITE YET MANY OF THEM
UP BY GUILTY. AND ACCEPTED
THEIR SENTENCE. FOR THE UP TWO
ONE TRIAL IS JUST GOING TOO FAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MISTER AMADOR
FOR YOUR TO. WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON WITNESS HEARING ROOM FOR TWO
THREE. SCENE NINE ARE THERE ANY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WISHES TO
IN OFFICE. TO ASK FOR A ONE. C.
NINE. WE WILL NOW ON TO WERE TO
TEST VIA TELE. ORVIS MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PUMPING
WAITING TO TEST IN OPPOSITION
SB FOUR EIGHTY ONE WE WILL
BEGIN. IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD M.
PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF WAITING TO OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE ONE PERSON SHOWING UP.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR. JUST
ONE MOMENT. OKAY IT WILL GO TO
LINE FOR FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOUR TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
THERE'S NO OTHER PEOPLE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE CHECK LINES ONE MORE
TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE CELLS
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM THE
LOCAL OPPOSITION WITNESSES. ONE
FOUR FIFTY EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS
BRANDY KENDRICK THEN I LIKE TO
SUPPORT SB FORTY ONE THANK YOU.
THEN AGAIN IF YOU WANT IT. UPS
FOR TO ANYONE PLEASE PRESS THEN.
ZERO AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR I WANNA THANK
ALL OUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FOR THEIRS THEIR
TESTIMONIES TODAY. WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS- ENTER COMMITTEE.
DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS- HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. SKINNER SKINNER THANK YOU.
SIR MATT WILL ACT. I.
ABSOLUTELY WORKING FOR THE THAT.
COMMITTEE WAS WRECKED ANY MAN.
READ THROUGH. SO BUT- NO SO I
WOULD. MOVE THE BILL DOWN I
PLEASE THE CENTER BRING IT THE
FOR US AS HEARD IN THE TESTING.
THERE ARE. MANY MANY
INDIVIDUALS IN- CALIFORNIA WHO
WERE SENTENCED TO LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE. BETWEEN THE AGES OF
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE.
INTERESTINGLY WELL THIS BILL
DOES NOT DEAL SPECIFICALLY FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE FELONY MURDER-
FOR REFERRAL ANY MURDER STATUTE
WHICH WE HAVE HEARD RECENTLY
COMMITTEE WITH ANOTHER SENATORS
BILL AND WHICH DO NOT A BILL I
AUTHORED. ON CHANGE THE STATUTE
OF A FEW YEARS AGO. A. B. A
WOMAN WAS JUST RELEASED WHO HAD
SERVED THIRTEEN YEARS WAS
SENTENCED WITH LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE. A CRIME THAT SHE WAS
SENTENCED FOR. WAS OCCURRED
WHEN SHE WAS YOUNGER THAN
TWENTY FIVE SHE WAS SENTENCED
FOR LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE. BUT
WHEN THEY DID THE RE HEARING
UNDER THE REVISED FELONY MURDER
STATUTE THE DETERMINED THAT SHE
HER. SENTENCE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
FOR YEARS AND FOR YEARS ONLY SO
SHE'S NOW BEEN SENT HOME. NOW
CERTAINLY THE ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT- CENTER DRAWS
WAS ADDRESSING ME NOT. IF THE
STATE THIS IS NOT THE SAME BUT
IT IS CERTAINLY IT ADDRESSES
THE FACT THAT. THERE WAS A
PERIOD OF TIME WHERE. WE
ENGAGED IN WHAT WE NOW
UNDERSTAND THIS BEING I AM
VERY- EIGHT EIGHT OR CALL IT A
TOUGH ON CRIME APPROACH THAT
DID NOT FACTOR. THINGS SUCH AS
A PERSON'S AGE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THE SO MANY
THINGS AND WE CREATED. I DO WE
PROLIFERATED OVER CENSUS AND WE
ENCOURAGED A REALLY OVERZEALOUS
NOUS OF PROSECUTORIAL BEHAVIOR.
AND THE RESULT FOR THIS WE HAVE
THE LARGEST NOT ONLY RAW
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE SERVING LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE IN THE US BUT
THE HALFPIPE PROPORTION EVEN TO
OUR PER CAPITA. THE HIGHEST
LIKE BEYOND ANY OTHER STATE.
MANY OF WHOM AS THE SENATORS-
BILL SHOWS WERE GIVEN OUT SENSE
DURING THE PERIOD OF THEIR AGE
OWN BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
FIVE. SO I THINK THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT CHANGE I
REALLY APPRECIATE CENTER DRUGS
ARE YOU BRINGING IT BEFORE US.
AND AS I INDICATED I MOVED THE
BILL. THIS. THANK YOU FIVE WITH
THE APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU. I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- FROM SENATOR DORADO-
LET ME JUST BEGIN BY ASKING
DEBTS. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
HERE THAT THE BILL IS CONTRARY
TO THE VOTERS WHAT THE BORDERS
ENACTED AND IT LOWERS THE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR HEINOUS
CRIMES- I'M SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR
THE SECOND PART IS LOWER THE-
APPS OR THE ONE. SO THIS BILL-
HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND TO THE
FACT THAT THIS BILL WOULD BE IN
CONTRARY TO WHAT VOTERS ENACTED
INTO LAW WORST CRIMINAL
PENALTIES FOR HEINOUS CRIMES.
WELL THAT WAS IN NINETEEN
NINETY IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
CAP CALIFORNIA PROPOSITION ONE
FIFTEEN. BY IT WITH THE
NINETEEN NINETY AND IT DID TAKE
AWAY- IF YOU TALK ABOUT THE
SAME THING REMOVE FROM THE
JUDGES THE ABILITY TO USE THEIR
DISCRETION. AND I. I BELIEVE
SOME MANY OF US BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS A TIME WHEN IT WAS JUST
A- YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
TOUGH ON PEOPLE. YOU KNOW JUDGE
DOESN'T HAVE ANY RIGHT TO- USES
HIS OR HER DISCRETION OR ANY
OTHER FACTORS SO THAT ISNOT
WORKING THAT'S OR FINING IS NOT
WORKING AND THAT'S WHY MAKING
THIS CHANGE BECAUSE- IT'S NOT.
WORKING ANYMORE TO GIVE THE
KIND OF CONSIDERATION S. AND IN
SOME WAYS WITH YOUTH BY GIVING
CONSIDERATION OF WHETHER AT IN
THEIR TERMS OF THEIR
DEVELOPMENT. IS NOT GIVING
CONSIDERATION TO- INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES IS NOT GIVING
CONSIDERATION TO IF YOU ARE AN
ACCESSORY OR INCIDENTAL TO THE
CRIME- RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE JUDGE TO
CONSIDER THOSE. IF IT'S PUT
FORWARD- WITH THESE KIND OF-
ENHANCEMENT SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE ENHANCEMENTS. OKAY.
AND THEN THE OTHER QUESTION IS
SAYS- IT IGNORES. THIS BILL
WOULD IGNORE THE COURTS
EXISTING DISCRETION IN CASES
WHERE THE DEFENDANT IS ACTUALLY
A MINOR. PENAL CODE ONE NINETY
POINT FIVE ALREADY ALLOWS THE
JUDGE TO IMPOSE A SENTENCE OF
TWENTY FIVE TO LIFE IN CASES
WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL IS UNDER
EIGHTEEN- WORDS HE'S CONVICTED
OR SHE'S CONVICTED OF THE
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES OF
MURDER. HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND.
I AM A MANAGER IF I COULD- ASK
ONE OF OUR EXPERT WITNESSES
EITHER PROFESSOR- RUMMEL. I CAN
RESPOND TO THAT BRIEFLY- ACREE
RIGHT TO THIS BILL WOULD BRING
DISCRETION WOULD ALLOW
DISCRETION FOR JUDGES AS THEY
DO WITH PEOPLE UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN COULD DECIDE WHETHER
TWENTY FIVE TO LIFE OR LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE IS THE
APPROPRIATE SENTENCE ON JUSTICE
WHO RECENTLY POINTED OUT IN.
THE NIGHT OF OR- THAT TELL HAS
TO BE PULLED ISSUE CURRENTLY
UNDER CURRENT LAW BECAUSE
JUDGES HAVE THAT QUESTION A
PEOPLE UNDER A AND DO NOT HAVE
THAT THE- FOR AGED EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE HOME THE
LEGISLATURE HAS RECOGNIZED IN
AND NUMEROUS OTHER BILLS ARE
ALSO LESS CULPABLE AND GREATER
HAVE A GREATER CAPACITY FOR
REHABILITATION. FOR THIS BILL
DOES NOT REMOVE THE SENTENCE OF
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE IT SIMPLY
GIVES THE JUDGE'S DISCRETION
AND GUIDANCE ON WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. AND ONE O'CLOCK.
OKAY AND THEN- HOW YOU RESPOND
US SENATOR TO ROSTER TWO THE
FACT THAT THIS BILL WILL
ELIMINATE THAT THIS QUALIFIERS
OF MURDERING VICTIMS WHO ARE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS OR
FIRE FIGHTERS AND OF INFLICTING
TORTURE ON VICTIMS. MAYBE IT
MISTER JOHNSON COULD YOU.
RESPOND TO THAT. HE MAY NOT
STILL BE ON THE LINE CONNOR
OKAY. PROFESSOR COULD YOU
RECYCLE THE BOND BREAK ROOMS
SURE IT DOESN'T MEAN. THE
SPECIAL BECAUSE THEY REMAIN IN
LAW AND BRIDGE HAS DISCRETION
TO LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE IN CASE
YOU WHERE THE SPECIAL. ARE
ALLEGED. ONE TO. OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH. PROFESSOR RUMMEL
RIGHTS PROFESSOR ROMAN THANK
YOU. YES THINKING. GREAT THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS BY MEMBERS. C. NINE DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIS ROGER.
GIVE SENATOR SKINNER OKAY THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER DO
PASSED BUT FIRST RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON SB FOUR EIGHT ONE. SB FOUR
EIGHT WONDER OTHER TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD ON
RADFORD I CHOI BOGUE NO TROUBLE
NO CALM LONGER HI I'M MY OR I
SKINNER. HI IN OUR AYE. MEAN
THE ROLE OPEN FOR. THE MEASURE
OF THREE VOTE TO LEAVE THE OPEN
FOR ABSENT. NEXT UP I SEE WE
HAVE COLLINS FILE NINE S. B.
EIGHT THREE OR YOU PREFER FOR
THAT. WITH THAT. OKAY THE
MEASURE IS TODAY ALL RIGHT SIR.
IT'S. IS NUMBER. ONE I DON'T
ALSO. THE NEW JONES YES.
SENATOR JOHN. FIVE- IS A BILL
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR A
LITTLE TIME IN THE IN THE
CLOSING DAYS OF THE LAST
LEGISLATIVE SESSION A GRAVE
INJUSTICE WAS DONE BY THIS
LEGISLATURE TO RAPE VICTIMS IN
CALIFORNIA. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TO THIRTY FOUR BY SOME
WOMEN- TANG WAS GUTTED AND
AMENDED TO INCLUDE PROVISIONS
TAKEN FROM BUDGET TRAILER BILL
AB EIGHTY EIGHT. THESE
PROVISIONS WERE REMOVED FROM
THE BUDGET BILL AND GET IT
AMENDED INTO AB THIRTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR. WHICH ARBITRARILY
LORD THE AGE FROM SIXTY TO
FIFTY. FOR CONVICTED CRIMINALS
INCLUDING RAPISTS AND OTHER
VIOLENT SEXUAL OFFENDERS TO
SUDDENLY BE DECLARED. ELDERLY
AND THAT'S BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR
EARLY RELEASE FROM PRISON TEN
YEARS SOONER THAN THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN. ADDITIONALLY THE GOT
THE MEN BILL FORCED THE VICTIMS
OF RAPE TO HAVE TO RELIVE THE
TRAUMA OF THEIR ASSAULT AT MANY
MORE PAROLE HEARINGS. AT THESE
HEARINGS VICTIMS OF RAPE OR
FORCED TO SIT WITHIN FEET OF
THEIR ATTACKERS AND RECAP FOR
THE PAROLE BOARD THE HORRIBLE
DETAILS OF THE RAPE THEY
EXPERIENCED. AN OUT AS SINCE
IMPACTED THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AB THIRTY TWO THIRTY
FOUR DID NOT COME THROUGH THIS-COMMITTEE. FOR CAREFUL
THOUGHTFUL REVIEW BY YOUR
COMMITTEE- BY YOU THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE NOR BY ANYONE
FROM THE PUBLIC AT AN OPEN. AND
TRANSPARENT HEARING. IN FACT AB
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR WAS NOT
HEARD BY ANY SENATE COMMITTEE.
IT WAS SIMPLY GOT IT AMENDED
AND RUSHED TO THE FLOOR IN A
MATTER OF DAYS. NO RAPE VICTIMS
ARE ALLOWED TO TESTIFY AGAINST
THE BILL THE VICTIMS RIGHTS
ADVOCATES FOR ALLOWED TO
TESTIFY AGAINST THE BILL. IT'S
AS IF THE SENATE SIMPLY
DISCOUNTED THAT THESE RAPE
VICTIMS EVEN EXISTED AT ALL.
TODAY THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE HAS A CHANCE TO RIGHT
THE WRONG THAT WAS DONE TO RAPE
VICTIMS A CHANCE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
SHOULD NOT BE FORCED. TO
REPEATEDLY UNDER THE TRAUMA
RELIVING THEIR ATTACK. WHEN
ASKED WHY VIOLENT SEX OFFENDERS
SHOULD BE GIVEN ELDERLY PAROLE
BACK WHEN THE AGE WAS SIXTY THE
EXCUSE OFTEN HEARD IS THAT SEX
OFFENDERS CANNOT PHYSICALLY RE
OFFEND. AT AN OLD AGE. ANOTHER
DAY AGES BEEN REDUCED TO FIFTY.
AND AS WE ALL KNOW FIFTY YEARS
OF AGE IS HARDLY. ELDERLY THE
EXCUSE THAT THESE VIOLENT SEX
OFFENDERS ARE NOT PHYSICALLY
CAPABLE OF RE RE OFFENDING NO
LONGER WORKS AND WE HAVE SEEN
COUNTLESS CASES OF VIOLENT SEX
OFFENSES WHERE THE PERPETRATOR
IS AGE FIFTY OR OLDER. IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT MOST OF
THE RAPISTS AND OTHER VIOLENT
SEXUAL OFFENDERS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY GETTING OUT WHEN
THEY TURN FIFTY. HOWEVER IF YOU
WILL. AND BY MAKING EVERY FIFTY
YEAR OLD RAPIST ELIGIBLE FOR
EARLY RELEASE YOU ARE FORCING
NEEDLESS PAROLE HEARINGS. WE
ARE FORCING NEEDLESS PAROLE
HEARINGS TO OCCUR AND AGAIN
FORCING EVEN MORE TRAUMA ON
RAPE VICTIMS. YOU WILL HEAR
TESTIMONY TODAY FROM TWO
OUTSTANDING WITNESSES ONE IS A
RAPE VICTIM AND SURVIVOR WHO
HAS BEEN THROUGH THE TRAUMA OF
A VIOLENT SEXUAL ATTACK. AND
HER LIFE UP ENDED AFTERWARDS.
AND NOW FACES THE THREAT OF
HAVING TO RELIVE THE ATTACK AT
COUNTLESS PAROLE HEARINGS. YEAR
AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR. OTHER
WITNESSES A FORMER DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WHO HAS
APPEARED AT SEVERAL PRO PAROLE
HEARINGS ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE AND IN SUPPORT OF
VICTIMS. I ASKED THE WOULD
CAREFULLY LISTEN TO THEIR
TESTIMONY TODAY. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR WITNESSES
THE FIRST IS DON A VICTIM OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT. AND THE SECOND
IS RICHARD SACHS THE FORMER
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
WE'LL SPLIT FIVE MINUTES
BETWEEN YOU TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES SO- OVER THE FIRST
WITNESS- PURCHASE OUR CORPORATE
HEAD IS IT MR SACHS A FIRST
WITNESS WILL BE DONE SIR OKAY
OKAY DONT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM TESTIFYING TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR FOUR
FIVE. AS A SURVIVOR OF VIOLENCE
AND- IN NINETEEN FIVE THE
SERIAL RAPIST BROKE INTO MY
HOME WHERE HE REPEAT RAPED AND
SEX ASSAULT ME AT KNIFE POINT.
AFTER THE SEVENTH VICTIM HE WAS
APPREHENDED AND SUCH SENTENCED
TO THREE AND TWENTY SIX YEARS
TO LIFE PURSUANT TO THE ONE
STRIKE SACRAMENTO. WE WERE
ASSURED IT SAID IN THAT HE
WOULD NEVER QUALIFY FOR PAROLE.
WHEN THE YOUTH OFFENDER LAW AN
ACT ONE STRIKE SECRETARY WORKS
FROM ELEGY. OUR THE ONE STRIKE
EXCLUSION NOT CURRENTLY BEING
ENFORCED AND THIS OFFENDER WAS
RECENTLY GIVEN HIS INITIAL
PAROLE HEARING. UP UNTIL THE
YOUTH OFFENDER AN ELDERLY
PROLOGUES WERE ENACTED. I AM
STILL BY THE CRIMINALS SYSTEM
BECAUSE THE OFFENDER WAS IN
PRISON FOR LIFE. NOW I HAVE
BEEN STRIPPED OF THAT
PROTECTION. THE MERE INCHES OF
THE HEARING AND THE POSSIBILITY
THAT HE COULD BE RELEASED
BECAUSE HE OVERWHELMING
DISTRESS AND ANGUISH AND I FELT.
ALL OVER AGAIN. THANKFULLY THIS.
NIGHT TIME BUT BATIC'S. BECAUSE
STUFF. WELL THE ENTIRE CRAWL
WITH X. HAVING TO FACE ATTACK
AGAIN RELIVE THE TRAUMA OF YOUR
FALL WAS UNBEARABLE. ALL IT
DEPENDING WHERE THE- I CAN BY
TO KEEP HIM BEHIND BARS NOT
ONLY TO PROTECT MYSELF BUT TO
PROTECT OTHER WOMEN FROM
BECOMING VICTIMS AS WELL.
ATTENDING PAROLE HEARINGS AND
CLEARING THE POSSIBILITY OF HIS
RELEASE IS A LIFE SENTENCE OF
MY OWN. HOWEVER I FEEL AS
THOUGH I DON'T HAVE ANOTHER ON.
I HAVE TO DO AS IN MY POWER TO
KEEP THEM IN PRISON. IF LEAST
HE WILL BE A TO PUBLIC SAY. ALL
WOULD PUT ME BACK THE COMPANY
EVERY WOMAN HELP HIM. A DANGER.
THE RISK OF REPEAT IF IS HIGH
IN THESE OFFENDERS ARE
DANGEROUS TO RELEASE A BY THE
EARLY. EVEN AT THE AGE OF FIFTY
UNDER THE ELDERLY PRO. UNLESS
YOU. AND PER LAWS EXCLUDE
LEVINE SEX OFFENDERS. I WILL BE
FOR TO ENJOY THAT THE- PROTOCOL
A AND- HELLO ME TO- HE FOR SEX
OFFENDERS PUTS BACK ASKED GOAL
OF AND TRAUMA. THERE CAN NO
CLOSURE IF THERE IS A CO THREAT
THAT THERE PERFECT COULD BE.
THERE HAVE TO WORK RELIVE THEIR
ASSAULT. SB FOUR FOR FIVE WOULD
PROTECT VICTIMS HAVING TO AND
THAT THE- TRAUMATIC SCHOOL HE
COSTS. I AM YOU TO STOP BY SEX
OFFENDER ROY FROM BEING VALUE
OVER RIGHT AND VOTE IN FAVOR SB
FORTY FIVE TO PREVENT FOR
THOMAS. AND SUFFER. I'M HERE.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR
YOU CORRECT OKAY. THANK YOU- TO
THE HONORABLE SHARE IN THE
HONORABLEMEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RICHARD
SACHS I RECENTLY RETIRED IN
MARCH FROM THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
AFTER SERVING THIRTY SIX YEARS.
I WAS THE INDIVIDUAL THAT
FORMED AND- STRUCTURED THE A
LIFE PER HEARING UNIT WHICH IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR TAKING THE
POSITION OF THE STATE THAT
BECOMES APT CALL HEARINGS INTO
TERMINALLY SENTENCED INMATES- I
HAVE APPEARED AT THOUSANDS OF
PAROLE HEARINGS- I HAVE BEEN
DOGGED BY THE BOARD. AS THE BOY
OF. THE PERSON WHO TAKES A
REASONED APPROACH ALWAYS AT
THESE HEARINGS THERE HAVE BEEN
MANY HEARINGS IN WHICH WE HAVE
NOT OPPOSE PULL OF THE IN
BASEBALL WE FELT THAT HAVE
EARNED A PAROLE DATE. YEAH AND
I YEAR MAKE SURE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR
FORTY FIVE BECAUSE I BELIEVE
IT'S A COMMON SENSE MEASURE AND
EVEN AGAINST ANY ODDS BASED ON
TRENDS THAT I'VE HEARD AND BEEN
AWARE OF FOR YEARS I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE WITH AN OPEN MIND
CONSIDER THIS MEASURE AND MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD. BECAUSE IT
REALLY DOES MAKE GOOD SENSE
FIRST IT ONLY APPLIES TO A VERY
SMALL PERCENT OF THE INMATE
POPULATION THE ONE STRIKE
SEXUAL OFFENDERS PROXIMITY 3%
THAT'D ONLY EXCLUDES THOSE WHO
WERE SEVERELY TRAUMATISED THEIR
VICTIMS THESE ARE ONE STRIKE
SEX OFFENDERS BY INFLICTING
VIOLENCE SEXUAL OFFENSES MAINLY
AGAINST WOMEN AND IN SOME CASES
TORTURE. WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED THE SEX ONE STRIKE LAW
THE LEGISLATIVE HISTORY I
RESEARCHED AND LOOKED AT IT
SAID THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
HIGHER REPEAT OFFENDING AWAIT
RECIDIVISM AND THEN THEY WANT
TO TAKE THAT CHANCE SO THAT WAS
THE IMPETUS BEHIND THE LAW. AND
THEY HAVE TO COMMIT EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS ACTS TO BE CONVICTED
UNDER THIS SECTION SUCH AS
CHILD MOLESTER UNDER FOURTEEN
TYING AND BINDING THE VICTIM
ATTACKING THEM IN THEIR HOME
INCLUDING TORTURE GREAT BODILY
INJURY USING WEAPONS AT CETERA
ETCETERA THE WORST OF THE WORST
AND SEX OFFENDERS I DO BELIEVE
IN. SHE FOR IN BUT SOME CRIMES
ARE JUST TOO HORRENDOUS IN
NATURE AND TORTURE RAPISTS AND
MURDERERS FALL INTO THAT CLASS
AND CERTAINLY THEY CAN SEEK
CLEMENCY COMMUTATION OF
SENTENCE AND THERE IS OTHER
AVENUES FOR THEM BUT TO
TRAUMATIZE THESE FEMALE VICTIMS
REALLY CONTRAVENES THE SPIRIT
OF MARCZI LAW ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY'RE GETTING A HEARING TO
TWENTY YEARS AT AGE. FIFTY B.
SPECTRUM SHOULD NOT UP TO FACE
THE UP YOU'LL OF THE HERE ON A
BY SEX OFFENDER. WHO
JUSTIFIABLY RECEIVED A LONG
TERM FOR THE PART OF SUCH. AND
FUTURE BUT GIVE THE WELL.
PREPARE OF THEM TO READ FAN.
SOME PEOPLE THE NAME OF THEIR
CLOUD. IT JUST COMMITTED YOUR
WOULD BE MORE ACCESS THEIR
WEAKENED FORTUNATELY THAT IS
PART OF OUR CALIFORNIA MOSAIC
WE HAVE TORTURE SEX MURDERERS
AS PART OF OUR STATE JOSE A CAN
THE STATE. AND THESE ARE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT THIS LAWS
TARGETED AT SO THEY ASK YOU IN
CLOSING PLEASE CONSIDER THE
FACT THAT THEY WERE EXCLUDED
FOR USEFUL IT'S UP IN THE
SUPREME COURT RIGHT NOW IN THE
WILLIAMS CASE ON AN EQUAL
PROTECTION ARGUMENT WE DON'T
KNOW HOW IT'S GOING TO COME
OUT. AND THEY SHOULD BE
EXCLUDED FOR ELDERLY ELDERLY
ALREADY EXCLUDES THREE STRIKES
AND FIRST DEGREE MURDER OF A
PEACE OFFICER BUT IT DOESN'T
EXCLUDE ANY SEX OFFENDERS THIS
SMALL AMOUNT OF SEX OFFENDERS.
THESE ONE STRIKERS AROUND THREE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED OR SO
SHOULD BE EXCLUDED AND I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD TO CONSIDER THAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NOW WILL MOVE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF S. P. FOUR FOUR FIVE. PLEASE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE AND JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR.
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION.
MY NAME IS ANDREA HAD STRONG.
AND MY ORGANIZATION BOB I AM
WELL UNOFFICIALLY I'M A WOMAN
THAT KNOWS TOO MANY WOMEN WHO
HAVE BEEN RAPED AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. FLORENTINO
ADDITION WITNESSES HERE AND
FORTY TWO OR THREE WILL GO TO
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE. MODERATOR
NOW CAN WE GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR FOUR FIVE. IN
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BEFORE FOUR FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE
IN Q. AND A COUPLE OTHERS
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU WHEN
YOU'RE READY. OKAY OKAY ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MA'AM WE SHOP HER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SHE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF FOUR FOUR FIVE THANK
YOU. TWO NEXT WITNESS. THANKS
FOR THE REMINDER FOR EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MATT MISTER CHAIR JIM KERR
BURKE PRESIDENT OF SAN DIEGANS
AGAINST CRIME WE SUPPORT SB
FOUR FOUR FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE TO FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS A MRAL CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY GO COUNTY
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. YES
WE'RE GOING TO NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LARRY
MOORE'S- BE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT ABOUT THE
FOUR FOUR FIVE THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. IN ADDITION WITH
THIS IS MISTER ROBERT- WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. IN THIS AT
THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU. NOW
WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR FOUR
FIVE. WE HAVE A LEAD WITNESS
KEEP OR WHAT LEAGUE IS KEEP
WIDELY AVAILABLE. I AM WHEN
YOU'RE READY HEARING YES WE
HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES MISTER WISELY
IF YOU'RE THE ONLY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. I THINK THERE ARE
TWO OF US AND LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING THE OTHER AMERICA WILL
SOON TO TIME TO GET TO ENOUGH
MINUTES. NO PROBLEM GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR BRADFORD AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KEITH WIDELY I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT ON COMMON LAW. I'M
GONNA MAKE A THREE POINTS AND
IN OPPOSITION- FIRST. THE FIRST
DISTRICT COURT OF APPEAL STRUCK
DOWN THIS EXCLUSION. AND PEOPLE
V. EDWARDS. AND THE SECOND
DISTRICT COURT OF APPEAL JUST
DID THE SAME THING EARLIER THIS
MONTH IN IN RE WOODS. IN
CONTRAST BY GRANTING REVIEW AND
PEOPLE'S V. WILLIAMS THE
SUPREME COURT HAS ALREADY
SIGNALED ITS DISAPPROVAL THAT
LOWER COURTS OPINION UPHOLDING
EXCLUSION. AGAIN THE ONLY TO
PUBLISHED OPINIONS ON THIS
ISSUE PROHIBITING SOLUTION THAT
IS THE SOLE SUBJECT OF THIS
BILL. FURTHERMORE THE PAROLE
BOARD'S OWN WEBSITE SITES
PEOPLE B. EDWARDS AS THE
CONTROLLING AUTHORITY WHEN THE
BOARD MAKES CLEAR AND I QUOTE
AN INMATE MAY NOT BE
DISQUALIFIED AS A YOUTH
OFFENDER BASED ON THEIR
CONTROLLING OF SENSE BEING
SENTENCED UNDER PENAL CODE
SECTION SIX SIX SEVEN POINT SIX
ONE END QUOTE. SO THE PROBOARDS
POSITIONED US COMPLETELY
UNDERMINES THIS BILLS CLAIM
THAT IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
CURRENT PRACTICE IN YOUTH
PAROLE HEARINGS IT'S EITHER AN
INTENTIONAL MISREPRESENTATION
OR THE AUTHORS ARE SIMPLY
UNINFORMED EITHER WAY THE BILL
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL IT COULD
NEVER BE ENACTED- SECOND POINT
IS THAT THIS BILL MAKES THE
FALSE ASSUMPTION THAT-
ELIGIBILITY EQUALS RELEASE. WE
NEED ONLY LOOK AT. NOW COMES TO
KNOW THE TRUTH. WITH AN 18% OF
SCHEDULED ELDERLY PAROLE
HEARINGS AND TWENTY TWENTY
RESULTED IN PROGRAMS IN CASE
YOU THINK THAT WAS A FUNCTION
OF COVERT NINETEEN LAST YEAR-
YOU SEE THAT THE PRIOR YEAR WAS
SIMILAR. I DON'T THINK ANY OF
US REALLY EXPECTS THAT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT STACKED PAROLE
BOARD IS LIKELY TO GRANT PAROLE
THESE CASES AT A HIGHER RATE. I
DON'T SEE IT HAPPENING. MY LAST
POINT. IS THAT THE REALLY THE
PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL DON'T.
CITE RECIDIVISM RATES OF PAROLE
GRANT RATES. BECAUSE THEY KNOW
NEITHER OF THOSE DATA POINTS
SUPPORTS THE BILL. THIS BILL IS
SIMPLY ABOUT TARGETING A GROUP
OF PEOPLE THE AUTHORS DON'T
LIKE OUR LAWS DO NOT PERMIT
THAT. URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON AS
BEFORE FOR FIVE BECAUSE IT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. AND BECAUSE
IT'S ABOUT FEAR MONGERING NOT
FACTS THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PRIMARY WITNESS ENDS
OPPOSITION OF S. B. FOUR FOUR
FOUR. ME FOUR FOUR FIVE I'M
SORRY. MMHM GOOD AFTERNOON
HIGH- MY NAME IS AMBER ROSE
HOWARD HIGH SERVICE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIANS UNITED
FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET WE ARE
IS THAT WHAT COALITION OVER
EIGHTY ORGANIZATIONS AND SHOULD
HAVE BEEN PRETTY WORKING AROUND
THESE SPECIFIC ISSUES- I REALLY
REALLY DO- EACH YEAR YOUR NO
VOTE ON FAR CRY FIVE IS BAD
PUBLIC POLICY- THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE THAT THE CURRENT
ELDERLY PAROLE PROGRAM IS NOT
WORKING IN FACT YOU HAVEN'T
USED IT TO ECHO CAPACITY
MANAGEMENT SOME OF THE
STATISTICS THAT I'M INTO WHAT
YOU JUST JEFF NAMES RIGHT
BEFORE ME. ABBAS DOES NOT ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY ABOUT A PLATE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO PRESERVE
LENGTHY SENTENCES THAT- WOULD
CONTINUE IF THEY- GET TOUGH ON
CRIME ERA WHICH CALIFORNIA
VOTERS HAVE BEEN SHIFTING AWAY
FROM FOR THE LAST DECADE WE
KNOW THAT UNDER THE CURRENT
LAW- CODIFIED- YOU KNOW FOLKS
ELIGIBLE FOR OTHER COLLECTED
TWO YEARS OLD AND WE ALSO KNOW
TO EXPECT THAT THE CONTRACT
THAT PEOPLE OUR AGE THAT WE TEN
YEARS OLDER- WHEN SERVING TIME
IN THE PRESENT AND WE ALL HAVE
BEEN FAMILIAR WITH THE
CONDITIONS ARE PRESENT THAT AS
THEY EXIT. THE TIMING WHETHER
TO GRANT PAROLE- WE KNOW THAT
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
HAVE TO CONSIDER AGE TIMES
THERE- DIFFICULT CONDITION AND
ALSO THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
SOMEONE I'M CONVICTION BEFORE
RELEASE THOUGH AGAIN THAT- THE
CALL DID NOT NEED A EARLY
RELEASE THERE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT HAVE TO BE NAMED THE
CONSIDER CORN COMING GRANTED
THAT RELATE- I THINK WE HAVE TO
REALLY REALIZE THAT YOU KNOW-
THE OTHER PROGRAM DID ARRIVE IF
CALIFORNIANS DESPERATE NEED TO
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL COURT
ORDERS- IN ORDER TO REDUCE OUR
POPULATION- AND THERE ARE
ALREADY EXISTING EXEMPTIONS AND
THE OTHER GIRL- LAW WHICH
INCLUDES PEOPLE CONVICTED UNDER
THE THREE STRIKES LAW.
INDIVIDUALS CAN CONFIRM
AGUIAR-CURRY DEATH AND VOTE
INDICATIVE OF FIRST DEGREE
MURDER KILLING A POLICE OFFICER
SO THEY'RE ALREADY EXEMPTION
FOR THE OTHER GIRL MOM- THAT
THE BOARD OF BROWN HEARING HAVE.
TO CONSIDER WHEN BRINGING FOLKS
FOR. WANT HAVE THE LOWEST RATE
OF RECIDIVISM OF ALL FOLKS
RELIEF FROM THAT COULD NOT GET
THEM THEY ALSO HAVE THE LOWEST
RATE EVER READ- EVEN IF THEY
HAVE ALREADY BEEN OUT OF PRISON
SO I THINK THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT
THIS BILL WE HAVE TO WITH WHAT
IT AIMS DO AND ACTUALLY IN TO
ROLL ON THE PROGRESS THEY WE'VE
ACTUALLY MADE AND CONSIDERING
THE THAT CALIFORNIA CARTERET
CALIFORNIA CORRECT RIGHT AND
PERCENT OF THE UNITED STATES
BRITAIN POPULATE AND I THAT THE
OTHER PRO PROGRAM WITHIN TWO
DIDN'T THOUSAND FOURTEEN-
BECAUSE- WE NEEDED TO ADDRESS
WHAT CALIFORNIA IS DOING- THE
FACT THAT WE CONTINUE THANK THE
SENTENCES- AND THAT WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT EXACTLY ARE THE
RIGHT MECHANISMS- PARTICULAR
FOLKS ARE RELEASED. IN OUR
STATE MALCOLM WE PULL ADDED IS
THE RIGHT WAY TO GO- YOU KNOW
THINK FOR OF THE REASON I ON
BEHALF OF CALIBER UNITED FOR
EVERYTHING BUDGET- AND ALL ARE
GOING THAT WITH US REALLY
REALLY DO YOUR NUMBER HERE- YOU
KNOW WE TO KIND ON PATH THAT
CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE SHOULD
US TOWARD- AND IN THE MOVE THAT
THE LEADS HAS MADE A THE LAST
YEARS YOU CAN COULD PUBLIC
RADIO THAT HE'LL- AND NOT VERY
THERE HON THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
NOW WILL MOVE TO THE ROOM WE IN
TWO AND WHO IS AN ALL OF B. FOR
FIVE SHE KNOWN WITH CAR OVER
FULL ROOM- IN ROOM TWENTY FOUR
THIRD NO WHEN. NOW THE
MODERATOR CAN WE GO TO A LINES
IF THERE'S WITNESSES IN Q.
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. OF S. P. FOUR FOUR
FIVE. IT WAS WHICH SIGN UPS OF
THE FOUR FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN Z. WE DO FIVE IN Q.
CURRENTLY WILL START WITH FOR
EIGHTY SO. PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON GO BACK IN. SO YOU
CALIFORNIA TAX. AND THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR YOU RIGHTS
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK.
THANK YOU COULD THIS. THANKS TO
A LINE TO EIGHTY SIX GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE LESLIE
HOW HE- FOR THE PUBLIC OF THE
OF THE- IN. THANK YOU CAN
EXPECT ONE. APOLOGIZE GO TO
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO A- DANIEL
ON BEHALF OF THE K. ATTORNEY
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN
OPPOSITION. NEXT TO A LINE FOUR
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CANACCORD ARE NON BEHALF IN THE
CAMPAIGN DIFFICULT DEFENDER
OFFICE STRONG OPPOSITE. IN NEXT
TO THE LINE FOR NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SRI LANKA.
NEVER READY AND BY HOW OF OUT
COLDER AND STRONG OPPOSITION SB.
FOUR FOUR FIVE. CONNECTION THE
LINES SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO. YES
MY NAME IS STEVEN GREEN. AND
I'M IN STRONG OPPOSITION THAT
THANK YOU TO BE HONEST OFFICE
THANK YOU. AND JUST NUMBER HAS
ANOTHER WAY TO YOU KNOW. NEXT
TO A LINE FOR SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MI CARRERA
FROM RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA AND I
AM OPPOSED POLITICAL. CAN WE GO
TO LINE FIVE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MICK OKAY
FELLA FROM COMMON LAW POLICY
DIRECTOR I'M OPPOSITION. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN QUEUE AT
THE TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR
OF THIS ISSUE THE CHECK TO LINE
ONE MORE TIME FOR ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. FOUR FOUR
FIVE. ANYONE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR FOUR FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR NOW WILL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THEIR
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
COMMITTEE SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN- FIRST I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR NINE
OPPORTUNITY. TO TO SPEAK AND I-
YOU- RIGHT NOT BEING HERE FOR
HIS AWARENESS OF HIS IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE- HAVING TO
ENGAGE ON A BILL- THERE BUT-
THE AUTHOR DID X. DESCRIBE TO
ME THE SITUATION WORK. AND YOU
KNOW THE THESE- THESE CRIMES
ARE THEIR HEINOUS AND HORRIFIC
ANNA PERMANENTLY. HARMS PEOPLE
AND CHANGES OUR LIFE- AND- YOU
KNOW AND THAT IS TRUE OF A
NUMBER OF CRIMES FOR WHICH BACK
CAN YOU CAN SEEK ELDERLY PAROLE
SOME VERY. SEVERE AND VIOLENT-
CRIMES A HARM PEOPLE AND
PERMANENTLY CHANGE THEIR LIVES.
ON THE QUESTION HERE IS
WHETHER. THESE PARTICULAR
CRIMES SHOULD BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY FROM THOSE OTHER
VERY SERIOUS CRIMES BY BEING
CATEGORICALLY EXCLUDED FROM THE
ELDERLY- PAROLE- PROGRAM- AND
IT- I DON'T. I'D I DON'T THINK
WE SHOULD BE MAKING. THAT
DISTINCTION PUTTING ASIDE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE BECAUSE WE
KNOW WE ARE YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE EXCLUSION OF
THESE PARTICULAR- CRIMES FROM
THE YOUTH- PAPA PROGRAM- SO
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY VERY SERIOUS
ISSUE IN TERMS OF THIS.
UNLIKELY BEING DEEMED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL- BUT IT'S ON A
ON A POLICY LEVEL- IN THE HOLD
THE POINT OF THIS PROGRAM IS-
IF YOU SERVED. AT LEAST TWENTY
YEARS- AND IF YOU ARE- DEEMS-
TO- TO NOT PRESENT- A RISK THEN
YOU CAN BE CONSIDERED FOR- FOR
ELDERLY. PAROLE BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT PEOPLE WHEN THEY REACH A
CERTAIN AGE ARE- MUCH LESS
LIKELY TO COMMIT CRIMES AND-
AND TO ENGAGE IN RECIDIVISM.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THESE
PEOPLE WILL BE AUTOMATICALLY
PAROLED AND I KNOW IT IS. AND
IT CAN BE TRAUMATIZING FOR A
VICTIM TO PARTICIPATE IN A
PAROLE HEARING I'M NOT IN ANY
WAY- DISPUTING THAT OR OR OR
DENYING THAT- BUT THAT'S THE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE THE PEOPLE-
ARE ENTITLED TO A SEAT RELEASE
AND- AND I DO I JUST DON'T SEE.
A REASON TO EXCLUDE THIS ONE
CATEGORY OF CRIMES WHEN THERE
ARE YOU KNOW THE YOU KNOW OTHER
CRIMES THAT ARE THAT ARE ALSO
INCREDIBLY HEINOUS BUT PEOPLE
ARE ABLE IF THEY'RE SERVED AT
LEAST TWENTY YEARS AND MEET THE
CRITERIA CAN BE CONSIDERED BUT
NOT AUTOMATICALLY GRANTED-
ELDERLY. PAROLE AND SO I JUST
DON'T- WHY UNDERSTANDS WHERE
THIS BILL IS COMING FROM AND I.
THINK IT'S COMING FROM THE
HEART- AND- AND I TO I'M
ANYWHERE. OF THE OFFER BRINGING
THIS BILL. IT'S NOT A THAT I OF
SIT. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS
ON THIS. ANJING NINE SYNERGY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL M. AND
M'S CHAIR WITH AND OLD COULD I-
THE OPPOSITION- I THINK LAID
OUT SOME FAIRLY WELL THOUGHT
OUT ARGUMENTS COULD I HAVE MR
SACHS. JUST SPEAK REAL QUICK TO
THE APPEALS I KNOW I THINK HE'S
WERE ON A ON THAT AND THEN I
THINK HE HAS SOME COMMENTS ON
THE CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION AS
WELL WOULD THAT BE OKAY. ARE
VERY BRIEFLY THANK YOU OKAY
MISTER SADDAM SERVICE RECALLS-
AND- GOT ONE QUICK COMMENT
AFTER THAT FOR MY CLOTHES YES
SIR. I COULDN'T WRAP IT UP
RATHER QUICKLY WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO MISTER WHILE. HOUSE
MINDED CROSSED OVER THE YEARS-
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO WHEN A
YOUTHFUL OFFENDER EQUAL
PROTECTION CASE I FEEL DOES NOT
IN ANY WAY. MEAN THAT THE SAME
THING WILL HAPPEN ON AN ELDERLY
PAROLE EQUAL PROTECTION CASE UP
IN THE SUPREME COURT AND WHEN
THE SUPREME COURT TAKES THE
CAKE SHOP ON REVIEW. THEY DO
NOT IT SAYS REYNOLDS ACCORD
INDICATE ANY POSITION JUST FIVE
MILLION TAKING THE CASE ALGONA
RULES SO WE DON'T KNOW. AND YOU
DON'T CROSS THE STATE STREET
HEARING GUEST THIS POINT WOULD
BE- NOT TO APPROPRIATE YEAH YOU
KNOW I DO ALL THE BRIEFING FOR
CDA OVER THE YEARS HAVE BEEN
SORT OF THE LEGAL. ON PAROLE
FOR YEARS AND YEARS FOR THE
WHOLE STATE FOR THE PROSECUTORS.
AND WE DON'T KNOW THE YOUTHFUL
OFFENDERS PLENTY EQUAL PARTS
ARGUMENT END UP IS NOT ME THE
CASE HAS BEEN ASSIGNED THE
RESULT CONSTITUTIONALITY ISSUE
BECAUSE IT'S UNDER REVIEW. AND
THAT PUTS THINGS YOU KNOW SORT
OF IN LIMBO LAND GRANT WHILE TO
WE GET A FINAL RULE. SO THAT'S
REALLY WHAT I WOULD SAY ABOUT
CONSTITUTIONALITY ARGUMENT
THERE ISN'T ANY IMPEDIMENT TO
STOP PASSING A BILL THAT IS NOT
THE DE FACTO UNCONSTITUTIONAL
ON ITS FACE MANY WAITED ALL.
THERE ARE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
POLITICAL AND THOSE DIFFERENCES
WOULD HAVE TO BE LITIGATED
BEFORE ANYBODY CAN SAY IT'S AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL SO I
BELIEVE THAT'S FALSE. AND ALSO
THE GRANT READ ON THESE CASES
FOR HEARING CHILD ABOUT 33% YES
YOU CAN GO DOWN 18% WOULD
ACCOUNT STIPULATIONS TO
INSTABILITY AND WAIVERS OF
HEARINGS BUT THE ACTUAL
HEARINGS HELD. TWENTY NINETEEN
WAS 32% TWENTY TWENTY WAS 35%
THAT'S THE NUMBER THAT GETS
GRANTED. ON PEACE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- JONES JOINED CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER SHE IN LOOK
THEIR THERE'S A LOT OF- PASSION
ARGUMENTS ON BOTH OF THIS IS
AND I YEARS THAT I THINK KNOW
THE BY LINE HERE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE CONSIDER IS A COUPLE
THINGS NUMBER ONE. THIS WAS
LOWERED FROM SIXTY TO FIFTY AND-I WOULD HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL
AGREE FIFTY IS NOT ELDERLY- I
WOULD MAKE THE ARGUMENT THAT
SIXTIES NOT ELDERLY- BUT IT
DIDN'T EVEN COME TO YOUR
COMMITTEE AND IT HAS- SENATORS
THAT- DULY SIT ON THIS
COMMITTEE. AND CONSIDER THESE
ISSUES ALL YEAR- I WOULD TAKE
IT AS AN OFFENSE. THAT'S
SOMETHING WITH WHICH IT WAS PUT
THROUGH LIKE THIS WITHOUT
COMING THROUGH FOR PROPER
REVIEW- BY THIS COMMITTEE IF
THIS COMMITTEE FINDS THAT-
MAYBE MY BILL IS A STEP TOO FAR
HI GREAT I UNDERSTAND THAT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT IS THE
RIGHT NUMBER. TO PUT ON THIS OR
WHAT IS THE RIGHT WAY TO
PROCEED ON THIS. I THINK FOR
VICTIMS. THAT HAVE BEEN AS A
CENTER WIENER POINTED OUT THEIR
LIVES HAVE BEEN CHANGED. BY THE
SITUATION THAT THEY DIDN'T ASK
TO BE PUT IN. BY THESE SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATORS. AND IN A
LET'S. BE CLEAR ABOUT THIS THIS
IS NOT SEXUAL HARASSMENT THIS
IS NOT A- A TEENAGER MAKING AN
INDISCRIMINATE MISTAKE THIS IS
A PERSON WHO PURSUED ANOTHER
HUMAN BEING. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CAUSING HARM IN A SEXUAL MANNER.
AND I THINK THAT THIS TYPE OF
CRIME RISES TO THE LEVEL WHERE
IT NEEDS THIS TYPE OF
DISCRETION AND I WOULD ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE THIS BILL
AND IF WE HAVE SOME WORK TO DO
ON IT GREAT LET'S HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION- AND- LET'S
PROTECT THE VICTIMS. IN THESE.
OR WILL CRIMES I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU ARE WERE SEEKING IN MOTION
ON S. THREE FOUR FOUR FIVE IS
TO PASS A REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS IS
OUR MOTION. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR TO A BALK. AND
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON SB FOUR FOUR FIVE SB FOUR
FOUR FIVE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD. PROUD
NOT BURNING A TROUBLED BY ROBO
GUIDE COM LONGER NO LONGER NO
SKINNER. SKINNER NO WINNER.
WIENER NOW VOTE IS ONE TO
THREE. TWENTY THREE THAT
MEASURE DOESN'T GET OUT WILL
GRANT RECONSIDERATION OF THE
AUTHOR WOULD LIKE. HAVING
LOOKED EVERY CONSIDERATION
THANKS TO RESEARCH ON. THANK
MEMBERS APPRECIATE YOUR IN
CONTENTION. ALL RIGHT NEXT
WITNESS TO ANY WITNESSES.
MEMBERS WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON
CONSENT CAN WE GET A MOTION ON
THE- CONSENT CALENDAR. IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR COM
LAGER- MAN CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ACTUALLY A FIVE ITEM
WILL FALL FOR A NEW MIGHT HAVE
AN OLD AGENDA OKAY- ITEM NUMBER
FIVE ITEM NUMBER TEN ELEVEN
TWELVE AND FOURTEEN THE THAT'S
RIGHT WE DO HAVE FIVE ITEMS ON
CONSENT I WILL STATE THEM SB
FOUR TWO ZERO S. B. FOUR NINE
ONE S. B. FIVE THREE EIGHT SB
EIGHT OH FOUR. S. B. EIGHT TWO
SEVEN ALL LONG CONCERNED. I AM
CONCERNED CALENDAR. BRADFORD HI
BRADFORD AYE INTRO BOKE TROUBLE
AT BOTH GUY CAMARGO HI MY
GRIPES KENNER. SKINNER AYE
WIENER WIENER AYE. FIVE TWO
SPELLS. FIVE ZERO. BUT WE'VE
GOT WE'VE GOT. SENATOR STERN
READY ON JUNE THAN- WE HAVE TO
MEASURES BY SENATOR STERN FIRST
UP IS FILE ITEM THREE SB THREE
SEVENTEEN AS HE PREPARED TO
MAKE THAT PRESENTATION. YES
MISTER. GEORGE OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK-
WITH MY TEAM OUR SPONSORS THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION SB THREE SEVENTEEN
ADDRESSES TWO ISSUES FIRST
EXISTING PROVIDES AND COMPETENT
DEFENDANTS CAN ONLY RECEIVED
TIME SERVED CREDITS FOR GOOD
CONDUCT WHEN IN A COUNTY JAIL
HOWEVER DOES NOT A BY THE TIME
SPENT ONE A TREATMENT FACILITY.
SECONDLY IS JUST EXISTING LAWS
NOT PROVIDING COMPTON
DEFENDANTS ADEQUATE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT WHEN THE
DEFENDANT IS CHARGED WITH A
MISDEMEANOR. DEFENDANTS OFTEN.
AT ALL THEIR PRE TRIAL
DETENTION WAITING IN JAIL FOR
TREATMENT THAT. USER CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM OXY FOR MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT PROGRAMS IS
WRONG. IT'S BEEN A DEFAULT OF
PUBLIC POLICY FOR TOO LONG.
THIS BILL WILL HOPEFULLY REMEDY
ONE UNFORTUNATE IN JUSTICE FOR-
FROM OUR CURRENT SYSTEM BY
ENSURING THAT DEFENDANT
DEFENDANTS WERE FOUND TO BE
INCOMPETENT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE SAME TIME SERVE CREDIT FOR
GOOD CONDUCT IS THEIR COPTIC
COUNTERPARTS. WHILE RECEIVING
TREATMENT ANY TREATMENT
FACILITY OR AN OUT PATIENT. NOT
JUST AS COUNTY JAIL TREATMENT.
CAN GET INTO MORE DETAILS. BUT
JUST TO BE CLEAR NOT ALL
OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE FOR EVERY
DESCENDANTS THEIR DEPENDING ON
THE- SITUATION IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH STATUS EACH DEPENDENT.
DEFENDED A TAILORED APPROACH
REALLY WELL I WAS TO USE
EXISTING TOOLS TO GAIN
COMPETENCY IN A FORTY CYCLE OF
INCARCERATION. AND BETTER TURN
TO MY LEAD WITNESSES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THREE
WE SEE YOU TO LEAD WITH WERE BY.
AND STUFF REGUL- GARCIA ARE YOU
PREPARED. RICARDO GARCIA I AM
PREPARED CAN YOU HEAR ME YEAH
WE CAN HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR-
YOU THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR TAKING THE TIME AND
I WANT TO THANK CENTER STERN TO
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO ALL
OF YOU HERE TODAY JOHN RICARDO
GARCIA OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER. AND I'M
NOT ONLY SPEAKING TO YOU AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE LARGEST AND
OLDEST PUBLIC DEFENDER OFFICE
IN THE NATION BUT ALSO AS A
TWENTY FIVE YEAR TRIAL LAWYER
WHO SPENT THE MAJORITY OF HIS
CAREER REPRESENTING THE VERY
PEOPLE THIS BILL WILL BRING
FAIRNESS. AND EQUITY FOR.
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTEEN
SETS OUT TO ENSURE. THAT PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED PRE TRIAL. IN THE
STATE HOSPITAL OR OTHER
MANDATORY DETENTION. RECEIVE
THE SAME CREDITS AS PEOPLE
INCARCERATED ELSEWHERE. THE
CURRENT LAW AWARDS CONDUCT
CREDITS TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
INVOLUNTARILY INCARCERATED PRE
TRIAL THESE ARE PRESUMED
INNOCENT INDIVIDUALS. THESE
CREDITS ARE OFTEN THE ONLY
BENEFIT TO THE PRE TRIAL
INCARCERATION. PRESUMED
INNOCENT PEOPLE WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS COURT DETAINED
PRE TRIAL BECAUSE OF THEIR
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS ARE NOT
AWARDED THE SAME CREDITS.
SIMPLY PUT A LOT TODAY PUNISHES
CALIFORNIANS SUFFERING FROM A
MENTAL ILLNESS MORE SEVERELY
THAN THOSE WHO ARE NOT ONLY
BECAUSE THEY'RE MENTALLY ILL.
THIS IS UNJUST AND INHUMANE. WE
MUST TREAT AND HELP PEOPLE
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL ILLNESS
WE CAN'T KEEP THEM IN A CAGE.
THIRTY AFTER STUDY SHOWS IT
JAILING THE MENTALLY ILL CAUSES
THEM TO BE COMPENSATE AND FACE
MORE SEVERE COMPLICATIONS IN
THEIR CASE AND LIVES INCLUDING
INCREASED LIKELIHOOD OF RE
OFFENSE. THAT IS THE OPTION
THEY WOULD FACE IF THEY WANTED
TO RECEIVE THE SAME CUSTODY
CREDITS AFFORDED THOSE WHO DO
NOT HAVE A MENTAL ILLNESS. THE
CURRENT LAW IS ALSO FISCALLY
IMPRUDENT. TAXPAYERS MUST PAY
THE EXTRA AND CAR SERRATION
COST. FOR A MENTALLY ILL PERSON
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY DO NOT GET
THE SAME CONDUCT CREDITS AS
OTHERS. MEANING BACK BECAUSE
THEY DON'T GET THE CONDO
CREDITS THEY END UP SPENDING
MORE TIME IN CUSTODY. WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY CHARGED TO THE
TAXPAYERS AND A BURDEN ON THE
INDIVIDUAL. OUR MEN OF STATE
HOSPITAL SAYS THIS INEQUITY
AFFECTS ROUGHLY TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS EVERY YEAR. SENATE
BILL THREE SEVENTEEN WILL
CLARIFY THE CONDUCT CRITICS
STATUTE AND ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF MENTAL ILLNESS THAT
SPEND THEIR PRE TRIAL TIME
INCARCERATED IN THE STATE
HOSPITAL OR OTHER MANDATORY
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT FACILITY
RECEIVE THE SAME CREDITS AS
EVERYONE ELSE. WE SHOULD TREAT
WE SHOULD BE TREATING PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS WITH THE
SAME CARE AND COMPASSION WE
TREAT ANYONE WITH A MEDICAL
CONDITION. I URGE YOU TO VOTE
IN FAVOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NOW WILL
MOVE TO STEPHANIE REGULAR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE REGULAR I'M A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER ASSOCIATION THE
TELEPHONE CARE ACT BE THREE
SEVENTEEN. I'VE ALSO BEEN A
PUBLIC DFENDER FOR TWENTY
YEARS AND IN THE COUNTRY COSTA
COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER MENTAL
HEALTH UNIT FOR THE PAST TEN
YEARS. DESPITE INNOVATIVE
REFORM EFFORTS BY THIS
LEGISLATURE THE DIVERT
INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS FROM CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. YOU WERE
CHARGED WITH MISDEMEANOR AND
FOUND INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL. REMAIN IN OUR JAILS AND
STATE HOSPITAL THAT. I SEE THE
SAME PEOPLE YEAR AFTER YEAR AND
I SEE THE CALL THAT
HOMELESSNESS REPEAT
INCARCERATION AND INADEQUATE
ACCESS TO TREATMENT HAS ON
THEIR PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH. UNDER EXISTING LAW THE
COUNTIES ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
INDIVIDUALS CHARGED WITH
MISDEMEANORS FOR BANNING
COMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL. AND
THE COUNTIES MUST DEDICATE
THEIR OWN RESOURCES TO
COMPETENCY RESTORATION. IS
RESTORATION SERVICES RANGE FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY WITH A FOCUS
ON SHORT TERM STABILITY RATHER
THAN LONG TERM SOLUTION. SOME
CUNTIES USED THEIR COSTLY
INPATIENT PSYCHIATRIC BEDS FOR
RESTORATION. OTHER COUNTIES
COMMITTEES INDIVIDUALS CHARGED
WITH MISDEMEANOR. BERMAN STATE
HOSPITALS DESPITE THE OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED PERSON
WAITLIST AND DAILY COST OF SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX DOLLARS FOR
THE BAD. AND MANY COUNTY HOW
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND THE JAIL
UNTIL YOU REACH THE END OF
THEIR COMMITMENT. WEATHER
STABILIZE AND COUNTY IMPATIENT
BAD RESTORED AND A HOSPITAL ARE
MAXED OUT IN THE COUNTY JAIL.
IN THE END THESE PEOPLE ARE ALL
TYPICALLY RELEASED TO THE
STREET WITH NO CONTINUITY OF
CARE. THIRTEEN SEVENTY POINT OH
ONE AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN IS NOT
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS. BUT THAT
HEALTHCARE. DISPEL OFFICE
COURTS THE FLEXIBILITY TO
EXISTING DIVERSION PROGRAMS
COLLABORATE COURT AND OTHER
COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT
OPTIONS TO TREAT RATHER THAN
INCARCERATED WITH MISDEMEANOR
FOR INTERFERING OF MENTAL
ILLNESS. NFL ALLOWS COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
FOCUS ON EVIDENCE BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SOLUTIONS. ON
BEHALF OF GPA I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AND I ABOUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NOW WE'RE MOVED TO
THE HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE ONE SEVEN
WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
AND THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS
WELL NOW MR MODERATOR WILL GO
TO OUR PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ON
YOUR OWN TO SEE CHECK COMMAND-AGAIN ONE. ZERO PART OF SAYS
RICARDO AGREED TO DEPARTMENT
HEADS- AN ONLINE FIVE HUNDRED
THREE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. YOU
KNOW. AFTERNOON CALDWELL
HOUSTON THE PUBLIC DFENDERS
ASSOCIATION TO KEEP WORKING FOR
ALSO AND FOR THE RECORD. JEFF
THANK YOU ALL. SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER AND THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY. IN
GENERAL DENTISTRY THAT'S FINE.
THANK YOU I THINK SOMEONE NEEDS
TO MEET THEIR DEVICE WE'RE
HAVING A COUPLE CONVERSATION
GOING ON AT ONCE ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I APOLOGIZE MISTER CHAIR WE
JUST NEEDED THEIR LINE- LINE
FIVE HUNDRED TWELVE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
GOING BACK IN STROLLER BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME- JUST SO SHE CHECKED
ALONG ONE MORE TIME FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THREE
SEVENTEEN. SHARE OR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THERE'S
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES LISTED
THERE'S NO ONE HERE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE AND THERE'S SURELY
NO ONE IN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR NOW LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES INTO THIRDS
WITNESSES WITH WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. OF THREE
SEVENTEEN. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE A COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
WITH THEIR LINE NUMBER. IN LINE
FIVE HUNDRED NINETEEN YOUR MIKE
ITSELF. BUT SURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ESPANA ON BEHALF OF
THE ACTUAL ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB THREE SEVENTEEN THANK YOU.
K. MISSING MILLIONS YOU'RE A
LITTLE LATE WERE IN OPPOSITION
RIGHT NOW BUT WE APPRECIATE YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THAT WAS THE ONLY
COMMENT WE HAD IN Q. OKAY WILL
ACTUALLY CHECK LINE ONE MORE
TIME FOR OPPOSITION TO THREE
SEVENTY. FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE OF THEM ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MODERATOR NOW WILL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
IT'S YOUR QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
AS IT RELATES TO AS P. THREE
SEVENTEEN. WHILE IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER WINNER. I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR I
THINK THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE I THINK ONCE CONFERENCE
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT-
BEFORE- THEY SHOULD BE FORCED
TO. GO TO TRIAL AND I THINK
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE ALL THE
REFERENCE SERVICES NECESSARY
THE MIXTURES A PERSON IS
COMPETENT AND GETS THEIR FAIR
DAY ON TRIAL AT COURT I SHOULD
SAY SO. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION IT'S TO PASS. AS
AMENDED- SENATOR STERN DO YOU
TAKE TO COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
YES I DO TAKE APPOINTMENTS
THANK YOU SO IT'S TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATION AS AMENDED-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON SB THREE SEVENTEEN. SB THREE
SEVENTEEN DO PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD. BY
BRADFORD I'D CHOKE I TROUBLED
GUY COM LONGER FROM MARKER AYE
SKINNER AND WIENER. WIENER AYE.
FOUR VOTES HOLDER MEASURES ARE
FOR ZERO WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NOW
SENATOR ARE YOU PREPARED FOR S.
B. THREE SEVEN SIX AM. WHEN
YOU'RE READY OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- FIRST ONE I THINK
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
CLOSELY WITH US ON THIS ONE AS
WELL- THIS MEASURE IS A MUCH
MORE PARED DOWN VERSION OF BILL
WE HAD LAST SESSION AND THIS
YEAR WERE SPECIFICALLY JUST
FOCUSED ON MITIGATING THE RISK
OF DO NOT A DISEASE
TRANSMISSION IN CALIFORNIA- WE
KNOW THAT IT'S NOT JUST COVERED
NINETEEN IT'S COME FROM
SYNODIC. ORIGINS BUT ALL THE
LAST MAJOR ENDEMICS EPIDEMICS
FROM SARS DEMURS- ABLE- AND ALL
YOU KNOW PREVIOUS VIRUSES THAT
HAVE HAD SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS I
HAVE DO NOT ECOREGIONS AND SO
WE FEEL LIKE WE DON'T HAVE
ADEQUATE- WILDLIFE TRAFFICKING
ENFORCEMENT ABILITY RIGHT NOW-
WHEN IT COMES TO- INSURING THAT
THE AT THE BLACK MARKET IN THE
TRADE- WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCE INTERNATIONALLY- ITS
THIRD ONLY TO- HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN THE DRUG
TRAFFICKING INDUSTRY IS THE
TRANSPORTATION AND TRAFFICKING
OF WILDLIFE AND. ANIMALS- AND
SO. WE HAVE A VERY LIMITED AND
OF FOLKS IN DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE- DO THIS TRACKING
RIGHT NOW AND WHO DO THE WORK
SO WE'RE TRYING TO GIVE THEM
SOME CLARITY IN STANDARDS HERE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BE TRANSPORTING WILD
ANIMALS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE SELLING THEM-
GET YOU. HAVE NO RISK OF HIS
UNITED DISEASE TRANSMISSION TO
A PERSON- SO IT ONLY APPLIES A
VERY UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES IF
AND ONLY IF THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT MAKES A FINDING THAT
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE EXISTS. AND
THEY SUGGEST THAT. GENETIC RISK
COULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR A
NOVEL NOT PREVIOUSLY REPORTED
READILY TRANSMISSIBLE DISEASE
SO I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS I'VE BEEN TALKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION- I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT- A POSSESSION STANDARD
WITHIN THE BILL- I AM I ALSO
WITH THE INTENT SECTION OF THE
BILL. SO I'M I'M AMENABLE TO
AGREEING THAT THE CHANGES- TO
AMEND THE BOTH THE INTENSE
ACTION A BILL AS WELL AS TODAY-
TO AMEND- THE PACIFIC
POSSESSION ELEMENT FROM SECTION
THREE OF THE BILL. AS WELL AS
TO REMOVE THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS AT THE SUGGESTION
OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF. AND
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR-
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO YOUR
TO PER. WITH AND SUPPORT WE
HAVE CUMMINGS. AND WE HAVE JUDY
MACALUSO. SO WE'LL START WITH
MISTER CUMMINGS. GOOD AFTERNOON
RENDON CUMMINGS WITH THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. THE
INTERNATIONAL WILDLIFE TRADE IN
ADDITION TO BEING ONE OF THE
PRIMARY DRIVERS OF THE
EXTINCTION CRISIS. WITH A
LIKELY ORIGIN OF THE CUPBOARD
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THAT
CONFIRMED BUT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION EARLIER THIS MONTH
COBIT NINETEEN LIKELY
ORIGINATED NOT THAT. MADE THE
JUMP TO ANOTHER SPECIES AND
FROM THERE TO HUMAN.
TRANSMISSION TRAIN MOST LIKELY
OCCURRED IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
TRADING EITHER WILD CARDS
PERFORMED WILDLIFE. AND THE
FIRST LARGE OUTBREAK OF THE
DISEASE BECAUSE A LIVE ANIMAL
MARKETS. GLOBALLY ABOUT 60% OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASES ARE
CONSIDERED NOT MEANING THEY
JUMP FROM ANIMALS TO PEOPLE I
JUST BELIEVE THAT THE MAJORITY
OF ALL FUTURE EMERGING
INFECTIOUS DISEASE WILL COME
FROM WILDLIFE. THE CODE
NINETEEN OUTBREAK HAS LED HAS
LED NUMEROUS INSTITUTIONS
INCLUDING ELEMENTS OF THE U.
AND NWHL CONTRABAND BY
RESTRICTIONS ON. THE LIKE
WILDLIFE TRADE. RECENTLY THE
AMERICAN CLIMATE SIGN INTO LAW
PRESIDENT BIDEN LET MONTH.
RIGHT THE RESPECT TREE BETTER
THAN CARNAGE. ALLOCATING TO
QUOTE DRESS WHAT LIKE IS EITHER.
BEFORE THEY PANDEMICS. I'M SB
THREE SEVEN SIX THIS COOLEY
COOPER WITH THE IMPORTANT
BATTLE ACT TO. BUILD STREET DUE
TO NOT A INTERESTED BY
TIGHTENING THINGS BETTERING
CHAU APPLY WILDLIFE AND OF
COURSE AND CAL. IF NOT IT'D BE
PEOPLE OR TO AN EIGHT O'CLOCK
MUCH. COMMON SENSE AND THAT'S
APPROACH WE URGE YOU TO TELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE JUDY
MANCO OF. HI THANK YOU CARE I
JUDY MAN CREW SO OF FOR OF
SOCIAL IN LEGISLATION CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS SOME INACCURACIES ABOUT
WHAT SB THREE SEVENTY SIX DOES
AND DOESN'T DO. YOU MAY. BARELY
TREAT- DIFFERENTLY BASED ON
WHETHER THEY ARE CREDITED. AS.
THREE EIGHT EIGHT IT DOES NOT
EGGMAN FIFTY LAW IN CALIFORNIA
AND OTHERS STATES. OKAY THEN AZ
ACCREDITED ZOOS FROM CERTAIN
PERMIT REQUIREMENTS THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE THAT NEWS LIKE
THE ONE YOU WILL HEAR FROM.
CHIU NOT NEED TO HIRE A VA
SANDERS AT THE LAST ON. IN
LOWER CALIFORNIA STANDARDS WE
DO NOT BELIEVE THIS IS
APPROPRIATE BUT IN ANY CASE
THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT. THIS BILL DOES NOT
CREATE A BLANKET PROHIBITION ON
IMPORTATION OF RESTRICTED
SPECIES ARE EVEN SPECIES THAT
POSE A DISEASE RISK WHERE THERE
ARE PROTOCOLS FOR ROBOT
HANSTEEN AFFECTED TREATMENT OR
QUARANTINE THE DEPARTMENT NAY
ALLOW HER MANAGE EVEN TURNED
NINE AZ EIGHT. THIS BILL IS A
PRUDENT AND MEASURED RESPONSE
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS FROM DO
NOT A DISEASES AND OUR NATIVE
WILDLIFE FROM INVASIVE SPECIES
WE HOPE THAT THIS PAST YEAR HAS
DEMONSTRATED THE VALUE AND AN
OUNCE OF PREVENTION WHEN
PROTECTING OURSELVES FROM DO
NOT EXPEL OVER. WE DID NOT ASK
OUR OVER TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS
AND HUNDREDS OF INDIVIDUAL
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL CALL
INTRADAY AND RESPECT COMMITTEES
BEHIND THEIR SUPPORT IS
REFLECTED IN THE PREVIOUS
KNOWLEDGE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NOW WILL COME TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM AND SHE NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVEN SIX PRESENT HERE GO
TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM THERE'S NO
ONE THERE MODERATOR WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES INTO THIRDS
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVEN SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE SEVEN
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. IN
LINE FOUR HUNDRED THREE YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. I'M SORRY WE LOST
LINE FOUR HUNDRED THREE
OUTLINED FIVE HUNDRED THIRTEEN
YEAR MIKE IS UP. IT GIVES YOU
SHARED YOUR SERVICE IS NOT
ROBINSON WE SHOW YOUR INTEREST
LOTS OF LEARNING HOW TO BE
HAPPY YOU MADE SOCIETY STATES
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITH
AN OUTLINE. NINE THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
NICHOLAS SACKETT TODAY I'M
REPRESENTING DEMOCRATS FOR THE
PROTECTION OF ANIMALS MICHELSON
CENTER FOR PUBLIC POLICY PLEASE
FOR ANIMALS IN ANIMAL LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND IN SUPPORT. AN
ONLINE. FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE. MY NAME IS JACK I'M A
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES AND
STRONG SUPPORT SB. THREE SEVEN
SIX. BLIND. FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR. YES HELLO CRISTINA
SYRINGE FOR ANIMAL DEFENDERS
INTERNATIONAL IN STRONG SUPPORT
SUPPORT AS WELL FOR THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS OCEANIC
PRESERVATION SOCIETY NATIONAL
PARK RESCUE PARTNERS AN ANIMAL
PROTECTION AND CONSERVATION
LIBERIA CHIMPANZEE RESCUE AND
PROTECTION AND INDEPENDENT NEXT
DAUGHTERS THANK YOU. AN ONLINE
AT THREE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS SERENA PHELPS I LIVE IN
LOS ANGELES AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SEVEN SIX. IN A
LINE OF FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
LINE FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN.
HELLO HELLO WE CAN AREA YEAH IS
THIS IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE PHOBIA
YEAH I MEAN THEIR OWN QUEUE
THEN- I WOULD LIKE TO GET ON
THE OTHER ON THE OTHER Q. WE
WILL BE CALLING FOR THAT
SHORTLY- THANK YOU AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. WOULD YOU
SAYS HE CHECKED ONLINE ONE MORE
TIME FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SEVEN SIX. OR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THREE SEVEN SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. NECROMANTIC
AND ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER COMMENT COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER. OUR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESS HERE BUT I'M NOT BROAD.
AND WE HAVE CHECKED OUR
CHARLIE'S SUMMIT. AFTER YOU
HEAR MEMBERS MATT BROWN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS WE ARE OPPOSING LESS
AMENDED TO SB THREE SEVEN SIX.
THAT WORKERS ACROSS THE FILM
AND TELEVISION INDUSTRY
INCLUDING HOLLYWOOD ANIMAL
TRAINERS AND HANDLERS WE SHOULD
AUTHORS GOAL OF REACHING THE
UNITED TRANSMISSION OR DVDS WE
BELIEVE AS DRAFTED THE BILL
EXCEEDS THAT OBJECTIVE. SB
THREE SEVEN SIX WOULD REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT EXTENSION
WILDLIFE I WISH WITH ALL THE
ANIMALS THAT YOU NOT BE TO GAS
TRANSPORTED WITHIN ONE IMPORTED
INTO THE STATE RIGHT NOW THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALREADY GRAPPLING
WITH CREDIBILITY TO WEST WILD
ANIMAL PRODUCTION SHOULD NOT BE
IMPORTED OR TRANSPORTED TO THE
STATE. AND ALREADY DOING SO.
BUT ADDING TO GET TANKS. WITHIN
THE CITY WILL WORK SB THREE
SEVEN KICK SOME IT POSSIBLE FOR
MEMBERS. TO DO THEIR JOB AND
CAL. BECAUSE THE MOTION PICTURE.
SCRIPT CALLS FOR DETECTION OF
AN ANIMAL THAT ADDED TO GO
WHERE. THAT PRODUCTION WILL
NECESSARILY HAPPEN DOWN AT
LEAST PART OF THE PROJECT AD
OTHER STATE. QUESTION FOR A
COUPLE OF AMENDMENTS INCLUDING
THE DELETION OF PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO SECTION THREE THE
BILL. PREFERENCE BY SENATOR
STERN REGARDING POSSESSION AND
TRANSPORTATION- WITHIN THE
STATE LIKEWISE ARE ASKING IF
THE DIRECTOR DECIDES TO SUSPEND
EXISTING AUTHORIZATION OR DO
YOU AUTHORIZATION. FOR
IMPORTATION OF A WILD ANIMAL
THAT THEY DO SO BASED ON PEER
REVIEWED SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE.
THAT DETERMINATION IS ROOTED IN
SCIENCE TOGETHER WE BELIEVE
THESE AMENDMENTS WE GET THE
BILL AND A WORKABLE PLACE FOR
MEMBERS AND STILL GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT GREATER LEEWAY. TO
DRESSES DO NOT A TRANSMISSION
OF DISEASES- SHOULD THE NEED
ARISE WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
CENTER STERN AND HOPE TO GET
THAT. I GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN PROTECT OUR MEMBERS JOBS
WOULD STILL NEED. THE BALL
FORWARD ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CHARLIE SALMON.
SERVICE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
MONTEREY YOU AND WHO ARE SO OF
A- WE'RE SORRY YOUR THAT OUR
LETTERS OPPOSITION AND THOSE OF
SEVERAL OTHERS THAT MADE IT
INTO THE PORTAL WERE NOT
PRESENT REPRESENTED IN THE
ANALYSIS THE CO SPONSOR. BUDGET
SPOKE COMPLETELY. CALLS
DESCRIPTION OF BOTH ARE YOU AND
HE'S READING STANDARDS IT COULD
HAVE BEEN MORE INACCURATE
HOWEVER IN THE MANY MEETINGS
WITH SENATOR STERN AND HIS
STAFF WE CONTINUE TO BE TOLD
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND OUR
CONCERNS AND DON'T DISAGREE
WITH THEM YET THE BILL
CONTINUES TO MOVE FROM
COMMITTEE TO COMMITTEE WITHOUT
ONE AMENDMENT. ADDRESSING THOSE
CONCERNS. BIASED AGENDA OF SB
THREE SEVEN SIX IS AN OBVIOUS
ATTACK AIMED AT SMALLER RESUMES
IN LESS AFFLUENT COMMUNITIES.
THAT MIGHT NOT HAVE THE
POLITICAL LOBBY TO ASSURE ITS
FAILURE. BUT YOU DOING SO
ACTUALLY POSES POSES A HEALTH
RISK CALIFORNIANS IN AREAS WITH
NEWS EXEMPTS FROM THE VERY
PROTECTION IT CLAIMS TO OFFER.
THE FACT NEEDS TO BE MADE
PUBLIC IN CLEAR WE'RE ASKING
ALL OF YOU TO PLEASE DEMAND
ANSWERS TO CERTAIN QUESTIONS.
CALIFORNIA FISH AND WILDLIFE
ALREADY HAS A LIST OF ANIMALS
AS TEAMSTERS JUST TESTIFIED.
ALL ZOOS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
BEFORE WE IMPORT THOSE ANIMALS
SO WHY DO WE NEED A NEW LAW FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO SIMPLY ADD
ANIMALS TO THAT EXISTING LISTS.
NEXT WE QUESTION IT SENATORS
DURING ITS OPENING THIS LAW TO
AMEND IT BECAUSE OF THE NEW AND
UNPRECEDENTED HEALTH INSECURITY
THE CALIFORNIA'S. WHY IS HE NOT
AMENDING THE PART OF THE SAME
LAW. WHERE THERE IS A CURRENT
SCIENTIFIC PROOF THAT THE
THREAT ACTUALLY EXISTS. AGAIN
WE'RE LED TO BELIEVE THAT THE
COLLATERAL DAMAGE OF THREE
SEVEN SIX IT IS IT'S ACTUALLY
GENDA THE CLOSURE OF SMALL DO
THE LESS APPEALING COMMUNITIES.
SENATOR STERN FEELS THAT HE
DOESN'T WANT TO ENTER A DEBATE
BETWEEN TWO LITTLE LOGICAL
ORGANIZATIONS BUT IN FACT THOSE
TWO ORGANIZATIONS ARE NOT AT
EACH OTHER. IT'S A DEBATE
BETWEEN THE BILL'S SPONSOR AND
THE SMALLER TRADE ORGANIZATION
WHICH THEY FEEL DOESN'T HAVE
THE LOBBY TO BATTLE THEIR
AGENDA. AS THE ANZ EIGHT EIGHT
RESPECT EACH OTHER AND WORK
TOGETHER ON MANY YOU A LOGICAL
AND CONSERVATION ARENA. FINALLY
WE STILL FEEL THERE IS A
QUESTION ABOUT AN ADDED
PARAGRAPH IN THIS BILL. IT
SEEMS TO COVER. AN IMMENSE AND
AN EXEMPTION FOR THE COLLEGE IN
THE SENATOR'S OWN DISTRICT.
REGARDLESS OF HIS INTENT THE
PARAGRAPH DOES OFFER SOMEWHAT
OF AN EXEMPTION FOR THAT
COLLEGE. AND WE HAVE STAFF FROM
THAT COLLEGE TELLING US THAT
THEY'VE BEEN GUARANTEED THAT
EXEMPTION. JOSIE IN MONTEREY
SUPPORT ALL THROUGH EFFORTS TO
SHUT DOWN WET MARKETS HOWEVER
S. THREE PIECE THREE SEVEN SIX
WILL NOT SHUT DOWN WE'LL SHUT
DOWN OUR COMMUNITY IS BRAND
NEW. AS IT WILL SHUT DOWN
OTHERS CA ACCREDITED LOSING
CALIFORNIA TO INCLUDE SIX FLAGS
DISCOVERY KINGDOM ORANGE COUNTY
IS- AND THE CALIFORNIA LIVING
MUSEUM. WE CONTINUE TO ASK THAT
YOU RECEIVE ANSWERS VERSUS
PROMISES BEFORE MOVING THIS
LEGISLATION. FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW WILL LOOK TO MOVE
TO WITNESSES HERE AND- THE
HEARING ROOM THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES WHO ARE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT I MEAN IN OPPOSITION
NOW WILL MOVE TO OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM AND THERE'S NO ONE THERE
ARE. ARE EITHER IN OPPOSITION-
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN A POSITION OF SB
THREE SEVEN SIX. FOUR COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. THREE
SEVEN SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. BACK COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO AN OUTLINE THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. I APOLOGIZE WE LOST
THREE THIRTY ONE LINE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE YOUR MIKE
ITSELF. HI MY NAME IS LAURIE
PALMER I'M A REGISTERED
VETERINARY TECHNICIAN AND A
LONG TERM NEW EMPLOYEE OF OVER
THIRTY YEARS. AND I DO NOT
AGREE AND DO NOT SUPPORT SB.
THREE SEVEN SIX. IN A LINE FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. YES THIS IS DAVE MCMILLAN
WITH WORLDWIDE MOVIE ANIMALS- I
OPPOSED VERY STRONGLY SB THREE
SEVENTY SIX BECAUSE IT WILL
ADVERSELY AFFECT THE MOTION
PICTURE INDUSTRY. AN ALIGNMENT.
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR. YES
THIS IS BOB DUNNE BUT DUNNE
DENTAL SERVICES I OPPOSE SB
THREE SEVEN SIX DUE TO THE
ONGOING WOULD CAUSE MOTION
PICTURE INDUSTRY IN HOLLYWOOD
THANK YOU. AN ALIGNMENT TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN- MY COULD OPEN.
HI THIS IS JORDAN LEVINSON
PROMOTIONAL BACK CALIFORNIA
AND- I AYE OPPOSED THREE SEVEN
CHECKS I THINK THAT COLLATERAL
DAMAGE TO SMALLER ZOOS IS NOT
WORK THAT THERE'S ALREADY OUR
TO REGULATE WHAT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU. ONE FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
WE CAN HEAR YOU. HI THIS IS A
CALL HANDLING WITH ST MARTIN'S
WORKING WILDLIFE ANIMAL TRAINER
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS I OPPOSE
SB THREE SEVENTY SIX THIS WOULD
BE DETRIMENTAL BE ANIMAL
TRAINER INDUSTRY AS WELL AS THE
ANIMALS LIVING WITHIN OR AROUND
THE PERIMETERSOF LOS ANGELES
THANK YOU. ONE THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO. HI THIS IS KIMBERLY
WRIGHT AND CO DIRECTOR OF.
WHILE THE WONDERS OF WILDLIFE
CENTER AND FOR MYSELF MY NINE
STAFF AND TWENTY VOLUNTEERS AND
INTERNS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
BILL THREE SEVEN TEXT SB THREE
SEVEN SIX IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. LINE. FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE. YES HI MY NAME IS TAMMY
MORRIS HAS WORKED FOR A COMPANY
CALLED BOB DONNED ANIMAL
SERVICES I STRONGLY CLOSE SB
THREE SEVEN SIX. THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE HUNDRED FORTY ONE.
YES MY NAME IS ALI ORTEGA AND
I'M A RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
AND I WORK FOR AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED A LOT OF MIND AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB. THREE
SEVEN SIX. BLIND. FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE. HELLO THIS IS
JACKIE NAVARRO I AM A BIOLOGIST
AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE WILD
WONDERS WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
EDUCATION AND AYE OPPOSED THE
BILL SB. THREE SEVEN SIX. BLIND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TWO. HELLO MY
NAME IS DANIEL BY AND I HAVE
WORKED WITH WILD ANIMALS FOR
OVER TEN YEARS AND BEHALF OF ME
AND MY WIFE ACTUALLY BY WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IN A LINE OF.
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY SIX. LINE
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY SIX THIS IS
JUDY SELBY ALTHOUGH HOLLYWOOD
ANIMAL. WORKED WITH HOLLYWOOD
ANIMALS FOR EIGHT YEARS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL NUMBER S.
B. THREE SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
BLINDNESS. THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO. HI MY NAME IS COREY PEOPLE
ARE SCARED OF THAT NERI
TECHNICIAN IN TARZANA
CALIFORNIA AND A VOLUNTEER OF
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED ANIMALS I AM
IN STRONG OPPOSITION SB THREE
SEVEN SEX. BLINDS. FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN. WELL. ONE FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN OR MY COULD
OPEN. BUT IT WAS JUST A PRETTY
WELL WITH EIGHT. MCMASTER
SALTER AND ENSURING YOUR
PROBLEMS AT B. THREE. PINE.
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE. HI
HILLARY HANKY WITH AVIAN
BEHAVIOR INTERNATIONAL I'M THE
OWNER AND THE CONSERVATION-
ANIMAL TRAINER AND I OPPOSE.
THREE SIX. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
NINETY ONE. HI MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE SHORT TERM DANA POINT
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AT B. THREE SEVEN SIX.
THE LINE. FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT. HELLO MY NAME IS OLGA
BOND I WORK CLOSELY WITH YOUR
ANIMAL SERVICES. ANIMAL TRAINER
AND I QUALITY OF CODE AS THE
THREE HUNDRED AND. SEVENTY SIX.
PLANET. THREE HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ERIC
WELL THE OWNER OF HOLLYWOOD
ANIMALS ANIMAL TRAINER FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS TEAMSTER LOCAL
THREE NINETY NINE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS IT
IS WRITTEN. LINE FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO. LINE FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
ONE FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE.
HI MY NAME IS PHYLLIS THANK
BURKE I WORK WITH BOB DONNAN
ANIMAL SERVICES AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE OPPOSES BILL. THREE
SEVENTY SIX. FIND FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY TWO. PLEASE TRY AGAIN.
KAREN MICHEL HATTON I'M UNDER
OF STUDIO ANIMAL INTERVENTION
I'VE BEEN AN ANIMAL TRAINER FOR
FORTY FIVE YEARS THIS BILL WILL
PUT MOTION PICTURE WORK OUT OF
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB. THREE SEVENTY SIX.
FINE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE.
HELLO MY NAME IS RACHEL
GREENSTONE I WORK FOR HOLLYWOOD
ANIMAL I OPPOSED- THREE SEVENTY
SIX IT IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
LINE THREE HUNDRED FORTY NINE.
MY NAME IS KERRY CLARK AND
WORKED FOR GENERAL JUNGLE
INCORPORATED AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE IT THREE SEVENTY SIX
THANK YOU. WIND. TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN. HELLO. BLIND TWO
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN NEAR MY
COULD OPEN. HELLO WE CAN HEAR
YOU. HI MY NAME IS MIKE MORRIS
I'M A THREE NINETY NINETEENTH
YOUR INTERNAL TRAINER FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB. THREE SEVEN SIX.
BLIND OF FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY.
PINE FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY HEREBY
COULD SOMEONE. NINE FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY NINE. HI THIS IS
HARISH TRACKER AND I WORK FOR
STEVE MARTIN'S WORKING WILDLIFE
AND I OPPOSE AND EAT THREE
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU. ONE FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN. HI THIS IS
CAROLINE DOUGHERTY I'M A
TRAINER WITH STUDIO ANIMAL
SERVICES AND A MEMBER OF
TEAMSTERS LOCAL THREE NINETY
NINE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
THREE SEVEN THANKS IT IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN. THANK YOU. A
LINE OF. FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE. HI MY NAME IS A HUNDRED
MARKETS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB THREE SEVENTY SIX DUE TO THE
HARM IT COULD CAUSE SMALLER TO
THE NONPROFIT AND ALL EDUCATION
GROUPS. NINE THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR. HI MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL CHEN I WORK FOR BOB AND
ANIMAL SERVICES AND I OPPOSE SB.
THREE SEVENTY SIX. BLIND. TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX. HI MY NAME
IS RENEE CARBONE ARE OPEN A
CURTAIN ANIMAL I HAVE- BEEN
OPERATING FOR OVER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA AT THE
STATE AND FEDERALLY WHY DIDN'T
PERMITTED ANIMAL FACILITY. A
NUMBER OF THREE NINETY NINE FOR
ABOUT TWENTY OR TWENTY NINE
YEARS I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
THREE SEVENTY. WYNESS THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE. HI MY
NAME'S CHRISTOPHER POLLARD
NATIONAL TRAINER FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS T HOLLYWOOD
ANIMALS AND ALSO THREE NINETY
NINE TEAMSTER I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. THREE SEVENTY SIX.
BLIND FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY. YES
HELLO MY NAME IS MEGAN VARGAS I
L. M. AND- WILDLIFE EDUCATOR AT
WILD MIND SCIENCE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THREE
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY SIX. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. YES THERE WILL BE A
CHRISTIAN ENVIRONMENT A NEW
MODEL AMBASSADORS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED A. B. THREE
SEVEN SIX. BLINDERS THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MY NAME IS
THAT DAVID ALL SPERRY I'M THE
OWNER OF ANIMALS FOR HOLLYWOOD
AND I'M CALLING IN IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THREE SEVEN
SIX. BLIND FOUR HUNDRED THREE.
LINE FOUR HUNDRED THREE OR MY
COULD OPEN. ONE FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE. HI MY NAME IS JAMIE
WARD I'M WITH STUDIO ANIMAL
SERVICES AND I OPPOSE S. B.
THREE SEVENTY SIX. LINE. THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE. MY NAME
IS GLEN SOLOMON AND JIM IN THE
BUSINESS AFTER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS ALONG WITH MY CO OWNER OF
GOOD DOG ANIMALS AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE
SEVENTY BACK. WIND. FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT. HI MY
NAME IS HEATHER LONG AS ANY
ANIMAL KEEPER AND AN ANIMAL
TRAINER FOR HOLLYWOOD ANIMALS
FOR THE PAST NINETEEN YEARS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THREE
SEVENTY SIX OTHER AS. FIND.
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY SIX. HI MY
NAME IS JAY RAYNER HAUSER FROM
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA OF
ANIMAL AMBASSADORS. I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. THREE SEVENTY.
WINDS THREE HUNDRED THIRTY. HI
MY NAME IS MELINDA I BURKE I'VE
BEEN AN ANIMAL TRAINER FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS AS WELL AS A
TEAMSTER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THAT THE. THREE SIX. NINE FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE. ONE FIVE
WATER. THIRTY THREE. LINE.
THREE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR. HI MY
NAME IS DEAN OF THE BORROW MY
WORK FOR WORKING WILDLIFE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AND. THREE SIX.
FINE FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN.
ONE FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY IN THE
AREA YEAH HI MY NAME IS ARGHA
SCARBOROUGH DI<c.cyan> TIME FOR</c>
ORANGE I WORK FROM AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. FIND. THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY ONE. HI I'M LAURIE KERN
FROM MESA AND I STILL OPPOSE
BILL. THREE SEVENTY. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN. HELLO WE
CAN HEAR YOU OKAY MY NAME IS
BUT YOU KNOW WILD CO OWNER OF
HOLLYWOOD ANIMAL THREE NINETY
NINE TRAINER- TWENTY. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE
COMPANIES ACT THE WAY IT IS
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX. HI MY NAME
IS ADRIAN EDGE OF THE AREA I
WORK FOR HOLLYWOOD ANIMALS AS
AN ANIMAL TRAINER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THREE
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU. NINE
FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH CHASSIS BEEN
IN ANIMAL TRAINER FOR OVER
TWENTY SIX YEARS WORKS FOR
GENTLE JUNGLE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE- WELL. THREE SEVEN SIX.
LINE. TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN.
SLASH SHOOT HELLO WE CAN AREA.
WHAT IS GOING THE DINING BOB
DONE TO ANIMAL SERVICES- I'VE
BEEN A TRAINER FOR OVER THREE
YEARS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
AND SB BELL I. SEVENTY BY. FIVE
FORTY. NINE FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. THE
LINE FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS RENEE CON I AM
AN ANIMAL HANDLER IN WILDLIFE
EDUCATOR WITH WILD MIND SCIENCE
AND I VERY STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
THREE SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
MISTER MODERATOR WE'VE REACHED
OUR FIFTEEN MINUTE LIMIT WILL
TAKE TWO MORE CALLERS AND THEN
WILL CLOSE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. BLIND FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
HI THIS IS MARK JACKSON OWNER
OF A HOLLYWOOD ANIMAL TRAINING
COMPANY- ANIMAL TRAINER
TEAMSTER FOR OVER FORTY YEARS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND
LASTLY. FIVE HUNDRED FORTY SIX.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARSHALL AGAR
OWNER MARK BURDEN ANIMALS
SERVICES I STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL
AT B. THREE THE MUSIC. AND
MEDICARE THAT IS IT FOR COMMON
UP. THANK YOU MUCH BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. INTERCOM
WATER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
SO I WANT TO THANK THE- AUTHOR
FOR- WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THERE WERE A ROBUST- NUMBER OF
CALLS FOLKS CALLING IN ABOUT
THIS BILL YOU KNOW FOR THE
RECORD I GOT A LOT OF FOLKS
CALLING ME ASKING ME TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND I DO WANT TO SAY
FOR THE RECORD THAT I AM THE
BLACK LADY WHO CARES ABOUT
ANIMALS- SINCE THAT WAS A
QUESTION THAT WAS ASKED AND-
WHY AT WHILE I APPRECIATED ONE
CALLING AND I CERTAINLY HOPE
THAT YOU ALL- COLIN WHEN WE'RE-
DEALING WITH BILLS ABOUT
PEOPLE. TO BECAUSE THAT IS
IMPORTANT. SO I'M- MISTER THIS
STERN AYE X. HAVE A FOR YOU I'M
MIGHT BE CONFUSED I ACTUALLY
THOUGHT THIS WAS A BILL ABOUT
LIVE MARKETS- AND I WAS WANTING
IF YOU COULD ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
TEAMSTERS AND BY THOSE FOLKS IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
BECAUSE I WAS SURPRISED TO GET
THE NUMBER OF CALLS THAT I GOT
FROM THEM ADDRESSING ASPECTS OF
THIS BILL THAT THEY WERE IN
CONFLICT WITH AND THAT WASN'T
WHAT MY ASSUMPTION WAS ABOUT
THE BILL FOR ITS INTENDS- AND
SO NOW I'M- SLIGHTLY CONFUSED
AND I THINK IT WOULD ALSO BE
HELPFUL IF YOU COULD GO OVER-
THE SPECIFIC AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU DID EXCEPT BECAUSE I KNOW
THEY HAD ALSO TALKED ABOUT
AMENDMENTS. AND IT SEEMS LIKE
THOSE HAVE NOT MADE IT INTO THE
BILL AND SO I THINK THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL JUST TO CLARIFY THAT
AT LEAST FOR ME BECAUSE MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS THIS WAS
ABOUT ONCE AGAIN LIVE MARKETS
AND WHAT SOLD THERE AND THE
FACT THAT THIS SEEMS TO STILL
BE BLEEDING OUT INTO OTHER
INDUSTRIES- IT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
FOR ME TO GET THAT CLARITY.
STRUCTURE BURGER OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR YEAH I TOO
WAS SURPRISED BY AMOUNT OF CALL
THAT WE WENT THROUGH ALTHOUGH
IT'S LIKE YOU FROM- ONE
PARTICULAR BUSINESS- BUT THAT'S
I AM SO TO ANYONE IN HOLLYWOOD
FILM PRODUCTION- YOU KNOW
WORRIED ABOUT THE CONSEQUENCE
OF A LEGISLATION WE DO BECAUSE-
THAT'S THE BUSINESS THAT PUT ME
THROUGH SCHOOL AND- AND I OWE
EVERYTHING TO THEM SO- TO BE
CLEAR ABOUT. WHAT THE THURMOND
THAT WE TAKEN- SOME OF THE
FOLKS WERE. THAT THIS WILL
SOMEHOW- PENALIZED FOR POSSESS
A PENITENTIAL SICK. SO THAT WAS
ONE REQUEST FROM I GUESS
TEAMSTERS MAYBE SOME OF THE
ANIMAL TRAINER FOLKS THAT ARE
PHILLY WOULD. TO WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE THAT AMENDMENT THERE WAS
ANOTHER MAN. THAT WAS BROUGHT
UP I FOR US TO THAT FINDING OF
THIS RISK OF THE DISEASE- ON
PEER REVIEWED EVIDENCE. AND THE
REASON WE WEREN'T COMFORTABLE
WITH PEER REVIEWED EVIDENCE
VERSES THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
THAT IS THE STANDARD IN THE
BILL RIGHT NOW IS THAT IN A
CASE LIKE COUPLE VERY- IT TOOK
MONTHS AND MONTHS TO GET ANY
PEER REVIEWED STUDIES DONE. SO
WHILE YOU'RE IN THE MIDST OF A
CRISIS IMAGINE IF YOU'RE
IMPORTING DIFFERENT ANIMALS
INTO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SELLING AND TRANSPORTING THEM
OR OTHERWISE. AND THERE'S A
MAJOR NOT A DISEASE OUTBREAK I
DO I DO NOT UNDERSTAND WHY WE
WOULD WANT TO WAIT SEVERAL
MONTHS FOR A PEER REVIEWED
STUDY TO LOOK AT THE- DISEASE.
OUTBREAK IF. THE DIRECTORS
AFTER MADE A WRITTEN BAY ON
SITE EVIDENCE THAT WAS THAT
RICK'S. SO THE IS NOT SUPPOSED
JUST SINGLE OUT SAY LIVE AND
MARKETS WE DIDN'T WANT TO- YOU
KNOW JUST CALL ONE IS. SET IT
WAS MORE ABOUT. TRANSPORTING
IMPORTING SICK ANIMALS IN THE
CALIFORNIA. I HATE THE IS NOT
TO BORROWER ALI FROM BEING ON
THE A BEAR OR A LOT. IN A FEW-
I KNOW THERE'S A LONG HISTORY
MAY BE OF MISTRUST BETWEEN SOME
OF THE ADVOCATES WHO ARE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. MAYBE SOME
OF THE FOLKS IN HOLLYWOOD WHO
LIKE TO TRAIN ANIMALS OR WANT
TO SEE MORE ANIMALS IN OUR FILM
PRODUCTION BUT- IT. WE'RE NOT
CALLING OUT THE THOSE
PRODUCTION STUDIOS OR THESE
SMALL ZOOS OR THE LIVE ANIMAL
MARKETS ARE ANY OF THEM IN
PARTICULAR IT'S REALLY JUST
SAYING. IF THE CITY OF W.
DIRECTOR SEES THERE'S A SERIOUS
RISK OF A DISEASE THEN YOU'VE
GOT A LIST THAT ANIMAL ON THIS
RESTRICTED SPECIES LIST- SO.
THAT'S THE THAT WOULD BE MY-
I'M VERY OPEN LIKE IF WE WANNA
DRILLED AND- WHAT THAT SIGNED
EVIDENCE SHOULD BE DEBT IT
WOULDN'T WE WANTED WOULD WANT
TO BE SAY AN ARBITRARY DECISION
FROM CDFW. OR SOMEHOW THEY
BECAME CAPTIVE OF ONE
PARTICULAR GROUP AND DECIDED
THEY SUDDENLY WANTED TO SHUT
DOWN ANYONE WHO WANTED TO PUT A
LINE IN INTO A FILM- YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT. THAT'S NOT WHAT
THESE BILLS TRYING DO. I THINK
IT THE LANGUAGE IS CLEAR WE'RE
TO ME. THAT MORE CLEAR- BUT I
JUST DON'T. I DON'T CONFUSED
TO. I DON'T KNOW. MY DEAREST
FOR AND HOW WOULD WANT THE- TO.
OR SELL. TENSION LEE VERY SO
AND IN CAL- AND HAVE THE- FOR
CD. TO HAVE SO SPACE ESPECIALLY
IN LIGHT OF WHAT WE JUST WANT
THROUGH WITH COVERT SO I'M
HOPING WE WORK THIS OUT- AS FOR
THE HI WE CAN. ANY OTHER
TESTIMONY LATER BUT I'M REALLY
DO. FRANKLY WITH THE- SOME OF
THE TESTIMONY I HEARD FROM FOR
MINER REYES YOU I THOUGHT WE
GOT OFF ON A DIFFERENT FOOD AND
WE'RE GOING TO TURN OPERATING
GOOD. IN NO ONE WAS TO A LEGEND
FALSE BUT- YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
THINGS HEARD THERE I DON'T KNOW.
I YEAH I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT
BUT I JUST DISAPPOINTING.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ARE.
CENTER UNTIL VOCAL. LIKE TO GO
FIRST YEAR OKAY- THANK YOU
STERN FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE
FOR AND- I UNDERSTAND THE
ENTIRE OF BILL I DO HAVE A
QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO. AB
THE REASON FOR THE EXTENSION IN
THE BILL WHICH ONLY APPLIES TO
THE ASSOCIATION OF ZOOS AND
AQUARIUMS THE AZ EIGHT BUT NOT
THOSE DO A LOGICAL ASSOCIATION
OF AMERICA DISEASE Z. EIGHT A-
WOULD YOU CONSIDER EXPANDING
THAT EXCEPTION TO BOTH. AS
CHAIR ROTORK OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER TROUBLED AT
THE SIX I THINK YOU WERE FOR TO
IN TWO ONE- TO ONE FIFTY. B. E.
TO. THANKS TEN OF THE BILL
THANK ITS MENTION IN YOUR TO
THE AMENDMENT- DOESN'T EXEMPTS-
ANY PARTICULARS DO AND
CERTAINLY NOT AS THE OPPONENT.
SORRY THIS IS THE WE HAVE THAT
LINE OKAY YOU- SO IF YOU THERE
ARE JUST READ BRIEFLY LANGUAGE.
IT'S THAT THERE MAY BE AN EGG
OR BAD SHORT MAYES STICK RISK
SPEECH PERMIT FOR A LIVE WHILE
THEY'RE- THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
BE PRO. RIGHT SO THAT WE IT
OTHERWISE MY MIGHT BE BETTER
OTHERS NOT IT DOES RISK. ONLY
ON A CASE BY CASE IS THE CASE
BASS. ONLY TO A UNIVERSE
COLLEGE GOVERNMENT RE A OR BODY.
I AND- CONDUCTING BONNEFOY MET
OR- RE THAT NOT OTHERWISE BE.
WITH THE FACT THAT LIE WHILE
THEY'RE- SO THIS IS NOT AN EXAM
FORCE- TEACHING DO IN MY IS. IT
WOULDN'T APPLY INSTANCE KNOW
THE OUT MORE POOR DO I REALLY
REALLY JUST. TO HEAR THAT OF
NAME CALLING A SERIOUS AND-
HEARING THIS IS ABOUT A-
RESEARCHING. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT TOO WAS VERY AND
SOME OF THE FILES ALLOW. THAT
DO VERY. HIGH RISK BUT SIRIUS
IN NASA RE. WITH SAY STATE BATS
WITH COVERT- YOU HAVE TO CAN.
MEDICAL OR SO. RE AND A VERY
HIGH BAR YES IF GET A SAID PER
ON THAT SO I DON'T THINK THIS
IS A BROAD EXAM SAVE. ALL ZOOS
CERTAIN KINDS IT'S REALLY NOT
ABOUT ZOOS ABOUT- THESE.
RESEARCH SINCE ARE THE THERE'S
ABOUT SEVEN THEM UP CALIFORNIA
NOW. AND HOW THE M. SO. THE
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND-
RT RATE IN. OF ANIMAL AND ANNA
PRODUCTS TO PREVENT SPREAD OF
ZERO. SUED NAS. AND IPOD FOR
THE- IF I DON'T A CAREER. WHAT
IS THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL IN A
TO WHAT WE ALREADY HAVE IN
PLACE WHY NEED FOR THAT. WE
DIDN'T FEEL THE CDC DID. WORK
HI- ON DURING A CO CRISIS- ON
THE FRONT END AND WE THINK THAT
WE'VE GOT MAJOR AND KERR. GIVEN
WHAT THE LOWER IMPORT EXPORT- A
STATE WE ARE IN THE LEVEL OF
TWO COMING IN AND OUT OF THIS
BOTH FOR OTHER STATES INTERNET.
FROM THAT ARE PORTS INSTANCE
ASSEMBLY REAL TO STAY WAY A-
ISSUE WILDLIFE FIRST TO HELP DO
THAT OR WITH ANY STATE BASED.
SEEMS A GENERAL OF DUTY ON
SOMETHING HAS PART HEALTH RISKS
AND CAL SO WANTED TO SEE THE
NECK AND THEN FORZA IN. OUR A-
TO DO WHAT THEY DO. TO PREVENT
THAT FROM TAKE ROOT. SO THIS
YEAR IT DID EVERY FOR DO YOU
HAVE TO PAY A LIST OF ANIMALS
THAT MAY NOT BE IN OR TO INTO
THIS. I WOULD INSTEAD REQUIRE
THE DF NOW LATER THAN DECEMBER
FIRST TWENTY TWO TO ESTABLISH A
LIVE OF ANIMALS THAT MAY NOT BE
PROCESS OR TRANSPORTED WITH THE
STATE OF IMPORTED INTO THE
STATE. IS IT SIR IS A QUESTION.
ARE YOU READING FROM ANALYSIS
YES YES IT THIS IN LIEU. IS
THIS. I'M SORRY IS IT INCLUDES.
YES IS IT IN LIEU SO INSTEAD OF
PUBLISHING AB IT SAYS HERE THAT
IT DELETES A REQUIREMENT FOR
THE DFW TO PUBLISH A LIST OF
ANIMALS BUT MAY NOT BE IMPORTED
OR TRANSPORTED INTO THE STATE.
AND WOULD INSTEAD REQUIRE THE
DFW NO LATER THAN DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST ESTABLISH A LIST
OF WILD ANIMALS THAT MAY NOT BE
BUSINESS PROCESS TRANSPORT
WITHIN THE STATE OR IMPORTED
INTO THE STATE IS THIS CORRECT.
IF YOU'RE READING SOMETHING
ELSE JUST WOULD ASSUME. CREEK
IN A WAY. TO THAT SOUNDS ABOUT
RIGHT. ANDERSON. OKAY INTO FOR
CLARITY FOR- THIS BILL REQUIRE-
THE RECORD- THAT THESE BE IN IN
THE LIST PRIOR TO BE FORMAL-
ABOUT SURE THE WORD WOULD.
FORMALLY DIDN'T DIE. TO BE THE
CARRIERS OR JUSTICE. OF BEING
CARRIERS. IF THERE'S A MAJOR
PANDEMIC AND WE KNOW THAT
CERTAIN ANIMALS OR CARING THAT
DISEASE THAT'S WHEN THEY WOULD
GET LISTED BASED ON A SIZING
EVIDENCE SO WOULDN'T BE IT
WOULDN'T SAY- THIS PART ANIMAL
MAY HAVE COLLUDED. IT WOULD SAY
THAT THEY A COPAY BREAK AMONG
OR WHATEVER THEN KOBE GOING TO
BE AMONG YOU KNOW THIS CLASSIC
OF OR- THESE KINDS OF AVIANS
ARE THESE KINDS BATS OR IN THE
MAIL THESE PER MAN. AND THEN IT
THAT RESTRICTED THEY WOULD END
UP ON THAT WRIST SPEED LIST
FROM THAT CDF FOR. AND THEN IF
YOU KNOW IF YOU COULD THAT
THERE'S NO LONGER A MAJOR
OUTBREAK WE YOU GET A THAT THAT
RESTRICTED LIST BUT IT'S ONLY
SUPPOSED TO BE FOR. THIS IS BE
A SORT OF CATCHALL WAY TO. A
WHOLE WHOLE BUNCH OF ADAM- THIS
IS ABOUT THERE HAS TO BE A NO-
I FORGET I'LL GO BACK AND READ
THE BILL BUT IT'S A- IT'S A NEW.
UNKNOWNS. IT WOULD NOT ACT UPON
THAT KNOWLEDGE. PASS ENOUGH IN
THERE FOR IT WE HAVE A NEED FOR
THIS PARTICULAR BILL THAT YOU
SUBMITTED THAT'S MY ARGUMENT
YEAH. I DON'T TO DEFER THAT TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO YEAH.
I MEAN WE DON'T THEY WE HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP THERE SENATOR WE
REALLY DIDN'T USED IN THE IN
THE PAST WE'VE NOT. HAD A LOT
OF- WE HAVE NOT HAD. OKAY AND
LASTLY M. WOULD YOU MIND JUST.
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT- THE LEAD OPPOSITION FROM
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL HAD. GIVEN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THEIR CONCERNS. I YEAH I'LL
HELP OF NOT REPETITIVE BECAUSE
THEY ARE YOU KNOW SENATOR COM
LOG ARRESTED SIMILAR QUESTION-
LEAVING WANTED DID EVERY NEEDS
TO BE BASED ON A PEER REVIEWED
STUDY- AND THEY THEY WANTED TO
POSITION NOT TO BE A PART OF
THE BILL. AND I'M NOT SURE AND
WE CAN GO BACK TO THE MATH IF
YOU ARE ONE I AM REALLY IF THE
INTELLIGENCE OF THE CHAIR HERE
I WANT TO TAKE. HER TAKING WAY
TOO MUCH TIME WITH THIS BILL-
BUT- I'M HAPPY TO GO BACK TO
THEM BUT I THINK THOSE WERE THE
CENTRALISSUES- WE'RE GOOD ON
STRIKING POSITION. THE PEER
REVIEWED EVIDENCE I THINK IT IT
JUST TAKES TOO LONG TO GET THAT
KIND OF STUDY DONE AND IT'S
REALLY NOT. WHAT IS THAT THE
HOPE WE'RE LOOKING FOR WE WANT
JUST SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
BE NIMBLE ENOUGH TO ADDRESS A
MAJOR PANDEMIC OUTBREAK. SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE BASING ON
SCIENTIFIC NOT THE PEER
REVIEWED BUT AGAIN I'M I'M VERY
UP FOR WORKING THROUGH ALL THAT
WITH THE- WITH THOSE CONCERNS.
THE SENATOR STERN. YEAH WIENER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- SO
THIS IS THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE BUT I'M A LITTLE. LITTLE
BIT CONFUSE AND SENDING OUT
SOME CLARITY SO WHEN IT COMES
TO AND WE KNOW THAT- VIRUSES-
THAT'S WHERE FOLKS NOTING
VIRUSES BUT ALSO CAN BE
BACTERIA. CAN JUMP BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN SPECIES AND
THAT'S ALWAYS. IN THE CASE OF
DOMESTICATED ANIMALS AND WILD
ANIMALS- AND IT'S- YOU KNOW WE
KNOW. FOR EXAMPLE THAT HIV-
CAME FROM- FROM A JUMP FROM WE
THINK FROM HEAPS TO HUMANS- AND
THEN STARTS TO SPREAD. THE ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES WE OFTEN IT
WOULD BE PROBABLY PRETTY
EXCEPTIONAL THAT WE WOULD KNOW
THAT. QUICKLY ENOUGH TO ISOLATE
HER KEEP AWAY FROM THOSE
ANIMALS BEFORE IT SPREADS SO
WITH HIV I THINK IT HAD
PROBABLY JUMPED DECADES. BEFORE
WE EVEN KNEW WHAT HIV WAS I
THINK IT WAS LIKE IN THE
THIRTIES OR FORTIES SAY THEY
THEY THANK BUT IT JUMPED FROM I
THINK IT WAS CHIMPANZEES TO
HUMANS. AND THEN WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHAT HE SAID HE WAS
UNTIL LIKE NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHTY ONE. BY THE TIME WE HAD
THE FIRST INDICATION SO MANY
YEARS LATER OBVIOUSLY WAY TOO
LATE TO DO ANYTHING- ABOUT
CHIMPANZEES AND HIV- AND WITH
CODED- YOU KNOW AT THE
BEGINNING THERE WAS A- MEDIA
SORT OF. I DON'T KNOW HOW IT
WAS A LITTLE BIT SPECULATIVE
ABOUT THE WET MARKET AND- AND
WHAT I UNDER ALL WITH DIFFERENT
OPINIONS ABOUT WHICH ANIMALS IT
MIGHT HAVE COME FROM OTHER WAS
FROM A DOCTOR FROM A PACK.-PANGOLIN THE FROM PRONOUNCING
IT. CORRECTLY AND BY THE TIME
AND FRANKLY BY THE TIME WE WERE
EVEN TALKING ABOUT THAT CODE
WAS ALREADY LIKE OUT THE GATES
AND BECAUSE OF INCOMPETENCE. IN
VARIOUS COUNTRIES INCLUDING OUR
OWN- IT WAS ALLOWED TO SPREAD.
SO I DON'T KNOW. HERE E. A LOT
OF TIMES ONCE WE REALIZE THAT
THERE ISN'T THAT THERE IS. A
REASONABLE CHANCE THAT
TAXONOMISTS IS THE SOURCE OF
THE VIRUS THEY MIGHT BE. MONTHS
OR YEARS OR EVEN DECADES LATER
WHEN IT'S TOO LATE. TO STOP THE
SPREAD. AND THAT. DOESN'T MEAN
WE SHOULDN'T DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT BUT I JUST WANT A CERTAIN
NOTE THAT- THAT IT'S NOT IT'S
NOT LIKE A BROOM THE SENATE WAS
DOING AND WE TO SEAL IT OFF AND
IT'S FIXED OBVIOUSLY THAT.
DIDN'T WORK WITH COVETED DIDN'T
WORK WITH HIV- THE OTHER- HE
SAYS OF IF YOU COULD MAYBE JUST
BRIEFLY COMING UP IN THE P.
SPECIFICALLY ON ON SECTION SEE-
ONE IN THREE AYE AYE I'M A
LITTLE CONFUSED BECAUSE THEY
SEEM INCONSISTENT ONE OF THEM
REFERS TO- THE WITH THE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE SUGGESTS.
SO IN OUR TRANSMISSION-
RESPONSIBLE FOR A NOVEL NOT
PREVIOUSLY REPORTED READILY
TRANSMISSIBLE HUMAN DISEASE.
AND THREE TALKS ABOUT JUST
DISEASE- READILY. DISEASES IN
GENERAL DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
NOVEL SO WHY IS ARE YOU TIME A
NOVEL DISEASES HERE. OR TALK
ABOUT ALL DISEASES HERE- AND
DOES IT HAVE TO ONLY BE A
SERIOUS DISEASE- BECAUSE THERE
COULD BE DISEASES THAT. COME
FROM AN ANIMAL THAT ARE ARE
VERY VERY VERY MINOR- AND SO
I'M JUST CURIOUS IF YOU COULD.
CLARIFY- THAT. SB TWO IF THAT'S
WHAT IS I'M SORRY MR CHAIR.
RIGHT HERE OKAY- MAYBE I DON'T
KNOW IF BERNIE CUMMINGS IS
STILL ON THE LINE MAYBE COULD
BE COULD WEIGH AND I'M HAPPY TO
GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF. EXTRA
DETAIL BUT IF YOU'D INDULGE ME.
YES I AM ON THE LINE. MR THE
APPEARANCE. RIGHT HERE USER
WITH THIS OKAY. YEAH THANK YOU
YES FOR CLARITY ON WHAT THE
BILL TRYING TO DO AND STOP OR
START AN EARLIER QUESTION ON
LIFE MARKETS VERSUS OTHER PARK-
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT READ
MORE BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE IS
THAT A PORTION OF THE EXISTING
LAW. DEALING WITH LIFE MARKETS
IT'S PART OF THE PENAL CODE-
THE QUESTION IS EXISTING LAW
THAT DEALS WITH WILDLIFE IMPORT
MORE BROADLY PART OF THE
FISHING GAME AND THAT'S WHY THE
BILL ANALYSIS THAT YOU THOUGHT.
ABOUT THIS ON THE LIVE MARKETS
PART IN-
COMMITTEE EXISTING LAW ALREADY
CREATE RESTRICTED SPEECHLESS I
HAVE A PROVISIONS REQUIRE
PROHIBITED SPECIES. THE
RESTRICTED SPECIES LEFT UNDER
EXISTING LAW TALK ABOUT PUBLIC
SAFETY THE PART OF THE LANGUAGE
IN HERE IS TO ENSURE THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH IS ALSO A FACTOR
IN WHETHER OR NOT TO PUT A
SPECIES ON THE RESTRICTED LIST
AS WELL AS WEATHER CONDITIONS
PERMIT OR NOT- THE PROHIBITED
SPECIES LIST WHICH IS STRICTER-
HAS NEVER BEEN IMPLEMENTED
THAT'S WHY THE PORTION OF THE
BILL THAT CUTS THAT DEADLINES
IN THEIR- SEARCH SOMEONE ELSE
QUESTION- IT THE MOST RECENT
QUESTION OF THE DAY. THAT
NUMBER ONE VERSUS NUMBER. THREE
INFECTION FEET. I THE IDEA THAT
IS IF THERE'S A SPECIES THAT'S
BEEN DETERMINED TO BE
CRITICALLY HIGHER. THAT THIS
GIVE THE AUTHORITY TO ACTUALLY
SUSPEND PERMITS YES IF THE
ANIMALS ARE ALREADY CIRCULATING
OUT THERE- OR IF THERE'S A
PERMIT FOR MULTI YEAR. A PERMIT
THAT ALLOW THAT ALREADY BEEN
ISSUED THAT ALLOWS IMPORTATION
BUT IT HASN'T HAPPENED YET
THAT'S WHAT ONE IS ABOUT- PRINT
THREE. IS THE IDEA THAT CERTAIN
SPECIES ARE HIGHER RISK OR NOT.
SO THAT THE COURT ON THE LAST
THE IDEA IS YOU CANNOT. THEY'RE
ON THE LIST THE REASON THAT
THE- YOU CANNOT ISSUE A PERMIT
UNLESS. THE ENTITY RECEIVING
THEM HAS. THE ABILITY TO DO THE
TREATMENT TESTING QUARANTINE
THINGS OF THAT SORT- AND SO. IN
THAT SENSE IT'S NOT A TRUE
PROHIBITION IT'S A PROHIBITION.
UNLESS YOU CAN DEAL WITH IT YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE COMMONSENSE
EIGHTY METRIC- AND THEN PERHAPS
THAT THE LAST THING I WOULD TRY.
TO CLARIFY ON THE QUESTIONNAIRE
AS A. M. C. A. AZS EXEMPTION.
AND AVIATORS BURKE A LARGE
SUITS LIKE AND EAGER TARA THAT
INDICATIVE LAW SO THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE THAT ALL- THE
END THAT THAT TAKES UNDER
EXISTING. IS PART OF CALIFORNIA
MANY STAY THAT CAN FEDERAL LAW-
THAT'S LONG BEEN WRECKED WE DO
NOT WANT TO CHANGE THAT AT A
PRACTICAL MAN THE COME. BY THE
SMALLER THE- CREATE ALMOST
DOESN'T REALLY MATTER BE. THE
AS THE ACRE EXISTING ADA. GOES
AWAY FOR SPECIES THAT ARE. AT
HIGH RISK AND SO THEY WILL NEED
PERMITS TO SO REALLY THE
OPPOSITION- ON THAT IS. YOU'RE
NOT. NOT UNDERSTANDING THEIR-
ADMITTEDLY COMPLICATED EXISTING
LAW- ARE MISCHARACTERIZING I
DON'T THINK IT WILL HAVE ANY OF
THE IMPACTS THAT. THE GROUPS
COMPLAINING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I BELIEVE THIS
WHAT THAT WAS MISTER CUMMINGS
RIGHT YES THANK YOU MR CAMERON
IS COMING. ANOTHER WINNER DO
YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
THE FINNER COME OVER THE
QUESTIONS- YES PLEASE YEAH IF I
COULD JUST BUT TO THE QUESTION
ABOUT. LIKE HOW THIS WILL WORK
IN PRACTICE AND HOW IT'S GOING
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PRACTICE AND SOME OF MY
EXAMPLES ABOUT. COVETED EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS REASONABLY
QUICKLY WE SUSPECTED BOTS ARE
PANGOLINS ALTHOUGH WE DON'T
KNOW REALLY WHERE I WAS COMING
FROM AND THEN. DECADES AFTER
JAPAN'S DEFEAT. ARE THERE ARE.
SITUATIONS WHERE YOU THINK WE
WOULD KNOW QUICKLY ENOUGH THAT
TAKING THAT ACTION WOULD
ACTUALLY. WHAT MAY MEANINGFULLY
PROTECT HUMAN PUBLIC HUMAN
HEALTH. I'M COMING TO GET HI
OKAY TRY TO. YES LET ME AS THE
CHAIR THE CHAIR IF THAT'S
ALRIGHT IF YOU YES ABSOLUTELY
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
JERRY BROWN- YES YES HELLO AND
IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES YEAH
YOU KNOW THE- IT MAY BE TOO
LATE BUT THERE ARE CATEGORIES
OF SPECIES THAT WE KNOW ARE
HIGH RISK PARTIAL BATHS WHICH-
ALMOST CERTAINLY IS THE ORIGIN
SOURCE OF HOPE AND HAVE
IDENTIFIED BY THE RECENT WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION- REPORT-
THOSE WOULD PROBABLY. THAT
WHOLE CATEGORY PATH SHOULD
PROBABLY BE PUT ON THE
PROHIBITED SPECIES LEFT WHERE
THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN IMPORT A
LIFELINE IT EXPERT RESEARCH
INSTITUTE IN THE US
SPECIFICALLY TO LOOK AT THE
PIZZA- FOR SPECIES LIKE THAT WE
CAN PROACTIVELY DO. IF YOU LOOK
BACK TOFACE BARS- ULTIMATELY
LANCASTER SAID THAT- BUT IN A
DAY IT MAY BE TOO LATE. TO STOP
THAT PARTICULAR OUTBREAK BUT
THAT WOULD ELEVATE THAT
CATEGORY OF ANIMALS TWO ONE FOR
HARBOR DISEASES. THAT ARE
READILY TRANSMISSIBLE HUMANS
THAT WOULD PUT THEM ON THE
RESTRICTED LIST IF THEY'RE NOT
ALREADY THERE AND YOU KNOW IT
WOULD THEREFORE BE HARDER TO
GET A PERMIT FOR SO IT IT. IT
IS A DIFFICULT THING AND THAT
YOU KNOW THERE'S THE BILL THAT
JUST PASSED OUT FEDERAL LEVEL-
DEVELOPS FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE BODY HOW BEST TO DO
THAT- BUT- AMONG THE THINGS
THAT YOU KNOW HAVE BEN CALLED
FOR BY THE WHL LOCATED. YEAH A
BAN ON LIVE MARKETS FOR MANY
SPECIES AND- MUCH GREATER
RESTRICTIONS ON LIFE SPOTLIGHT
TRADE MORE BROADLY THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS. TO DO IN A
WAY THAT ALLOWS. OKAY THANK YOU
CONTINUE HAPPEN. THANK YOU. THE
QUESTIONS LOOKING. SPONSORED
MISSED CHAIR I GUESS I JUST HAD
A QUESTION GIVEN ALL OF THE-
THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE COME UP
FROM- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
IF IT TOM. IF THE AUTHOR IS
OPEN TO USING MORE TIME TO TRY
TO ADDRESS THEM. SENATOR STERN
CAN YOU ANSWER THE QUESTION.
I'M SORRY USING MORE TIME HERE
TODAY WELL NO NOT TODAY BUT
MAYBE CONSIDERING MAKING THIS A
TO YOUR BILL- I HAD NOT
CONSIDERED THAT- YOU KNOW GIVEN
THE GIVEN THE URGENCY OF THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS WORD JUST
GETTING THROUGH I'M REALLY. I
WOULD APPRECIATE. CONSIDERATION
AND EVEN IF FOR SOME REASON YOU
ALL SEE DON'T SEE FIT TO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE THAT AND
SEEK RECONSIDERATION AT THAT
POINT BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT-
THE MATTER AS SUFFICIENT
URGENCY THAT IT IT PROBABLY
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO WAIT WE
SPENT TWO YEARS WORKING ON THIS
BILL- LAST YEAR AND IT
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE SESSION
IT MADE IT THROUGH BOTH HOUSES-
WITH. MANY VOTES FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE STILL ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND- MADE UP THE ASSEMBLY FOR
WITH GARY SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT
AND JUST DIDN'T GET TO OUR SIDE
QUICKLY ENOUGH SO- I GET THAT
NEW THINGS COME TO LIGHT BUT
I'M HOPING THAT THE URGENCY
THAT WAS PRESENT IN LAST
SESSION REMAINS TODAY SO.
EITHER WAY I THINK I'M I'M- I'M
UP FOR A I'M UP FOR A VOTE. IF
THAT'S THE WILL OF THE
COMMITTEE. ARM FROM THE
OPPOSITION IS MATT BROOCH STILL
ON THE LINE. I AM I NEED TO
KNOW WHAT AMENDMENTS- HE'S TOOK
A SERIES OF AMENDMENTS WHAT
AMENDMENTS ARE STILL LACKING IN
ORDER TO REMOVE IT. YOUR
OPPOSITION. MR HERE I THINK YOU
KNOW I'M JUST A BIT OF HISTORY-
WE'VE BEEN ENGAGING- AND
ENGAGING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
CENTER STERN'S. OFFICE TO HAND
HIS STAFF YOU KNOW FOR THE LAST
YEARS SO ON THE BILL- YOU KNOW
FIRST WE ARE LOOKING FOR AN
EXEMPTION FOR THIS FILM AND
TELEVISION INDUSTRY WHICH HE
YOU KNOW HE DIDN'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE DOING I THINK THE
EXEMPTION HE THOUGHT WHICH TO
GRIND- WHICH YOU KNOW IT'S A
LITTLE PERPLEXING ASK BECAUSE-
I'M I DON'T THINK THAT. THERE'S
ANY INTENTION HE'S MADE CLEAR
IT'S NOT HIS INTENTION TO CATCH
US BACK HOME AND WE DON'T THINK
IT IS INTENTION. ALSO NOT AWARE
OF THERE BEING AN ISSUE IN OUR
TRANSMISSION OF DISEASES BEING
A PROBLEM IN HOLLYWOOD OR SICK
ANIMALS BEING A PROBLEM
HOLLYWOOD AND SO WHAT WE WE'D
COME BACK IN ACCURATE ASKED FOR
HIS OFFICE MOST RECENTLY WITH
BASICALLY AN AMENDMENT BIG
CAPS. THE EXISTING AUTHORITY
THAT PROTESTED WITH THE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT STATE TO CREATE
THIS LAST TIME BUT THAT
WOULDN'T ADD NEW POWER THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
COULD PROHIBIT THE POSSESSION
OR TRANSPORTATION WITHIN THE
STATE BECAUSE LIKE THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT OUR MEMBERS DEAL.
ENDS AND ARE ARE VERY WORRIED
ABOUT AND I GUESS THERE'S A
REAL CONCERN AMONGST OUR
MEMBERS THAT THIS IS KIND OF
THE YOU KNOW PROVERBIAL CAMEL'S
DOES NOT I KNOW IT'S UNDER THE
CLASS- AND THAT YOU KNOW IT WAS
ABOUT WHAT MARKETS LAST YEAR.
AND NOW IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
ABOUT YOU NOT A TRANSMISSION
AND OUR MEMBERS ARE JUST
WORRIED ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
THEY HAVE- A JOB AT THE END OF
THE DAY AND SO YOU KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE SENATOR AND WE HAVE BEEN
BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO GET OUR
POSITION OUT THERE- ON RECORD
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO BACK
SECTION. SECTION THREE AND.
SHOULD BE IN THURMOND AND- HI
THAT WE PROPOSED TO BE. WE
VISITED ADDED. STATUTES OKAY-
AND WILLING TO WORK SENATE ON
THIS TIME. ISSUE A PEER REVIEW
I DON'T THINK WE'RE- WORD MARY
DID THAT ALL WE JUST WANT TO
SURE THEY HE IS A JUSTICE THAT.
BORN OUT OF THE YOU KNOW
SCIENCE AND THAT ISN'T CARBON.
AND ISN'T USED TO START OF I
YOU KNOW. POTENTIALLY- I
REMEMBER. OUR CONSIDER STERN ON
OUR TO HAVE GREAT CONCERNS
BASED ON MY UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THIS BILL WAS FOR WHAT HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED TODAY CHEL IN
LIGHT OF WHAT HAS JUST BEEN
MENTIONED BY MR BURROWED WERE
ARE YOU AND ADDRESSING THOSE
CONCERNS I WAS ALSO AN
IMPRESSION BY- FOLKS THAT ALL
THE MOMENTS THAT WERE COMMITTED
TO AND NOW TO RESOURCES I'VE
GOT TO BE TAKEN TO IS THAT IN
FACT. THE CASE CAN YOU CHECK
THAT THAT MAY BE ONE OF THE
OTHER ISSUES HERE IS WE DIDN'T
HAVE TIME BETWEEN. COMMITTEES-
TODAY TO GET THOSE. JOHN AND IN
THE CRANK- IT WAS TOO LATE TO
STOP RAGING IN THERE WAS
NOTHING OPPORTUNITY ANALYSIS
SO- BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR THAT
THE PIECES OF THE AMENDMENTS
WILL WORK WE WERE TAKING A
COMMITTEES REQUESTING THAT IT
TEAMSTERS REQUEST WE'RE
REMOVING A THREE YEAR STATUTE
ON OCCASIONS WERE ALLOWING A
WARNING FOR FIRST VIOLATIONS ON
A WET MARKET SIDE. WERE STATING
THAT BASIS MUST BE ON
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE BASED ON
CREDIBLE SCIENCE BUT AGAIN MR
BROADEST POINT VERY OPEN THE
WORKING THERE AS LONG AS IT'S
TIMELY TO SENATOR WIENER'S
POINT WOULD SUMMIT ONE ONCE I
GET DELETED MANY MONTHS OR
YEARS. OUT THAT THE TEACHERS
REQUEST REMOVING POSSESSION
FROM SECTION THREE OF THE BILL-
AND ALSO AT THE REQUEST OF THE
TEAMSTERS ARE MOVING IN THERE
AT INTENT LANGUAGE- SOMEONE'S
ENTERING RECEDING LIKE RELATED
TO POSSESSION SO. I'M I'M
HOPING WHAT I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THE OTHER ELEMENTS
ARE I DID HAVE A CONCERN WITH
IT STRAIGHT OUT EXEMPTION JUST
FOR ONE INDUSTRY WHERE UNITED
WANTED CERTAIN INDUSTRIES ONE
OF OR NOT WELL I'VE DEEPLY
CARSHALTON ENTERTAINMENTS
RENDON I THINK THAT WOULD BE.
FAIR BUT I'M OPEN. MR PEROT. TO
WHAT TAKE IF THOSE OF MY YOU
JUST STAY IT WILL THAT
ALLEVIATE YOUR CA. AND I MEAN I
THINK THE ISSUE IS THAT SORRY
GO AHEAD MISTER NOT GONNA
ANSWER CAR CONSULTANT- ARE WE
CAN WE IMPOSE THOSE AMENDMENTS
HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE. YES
REPORT THAT HE'S ALREADY TAKEN
OMINOUS COMMITTEE SO THEY'LL
CROSS OUT WITH THIS COMMITTEE
IN ANY ADDITIONAL ONES THAT. I
THOUGHT MR PEROT WAS SPEAKING
YOU CAN'T YOU CAN NEED- AS A
COMMITTEE CAN PUT ON OTHER
AMENDMENTS IF THERE'S OTHERS I
THINK IT TOOK CARE OF THE
POSSESSION ISSUE THAT. MR
BROADHEAD AND THEN A- AND THEN
THE ISSUE ABOUT THE SCIENCE
ALTHOUGH IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
STILL. THERE WERE TAKEN A STEP
TOWARD THAT THE AUTHORS GIVEN
THE MOMENTS THAT TAKE A STEP
TOWARD THAT. AND THEN. WE'LL
SEE IF THAT GOES FAR ENOUGH. TO
I WANTED NO THE PROTECT THEM
FROM THE AUTHOR ARE YOU WILLING
TO TAKE THOSE ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS TO ALLEVIATE THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED BY MR BROUGHT. YES I
THINK SO I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE GO THE
EIGHTY COULD YOU CLARIFY ONE
MORE TIME WHAT WHAT EXACTLY
DOES WOULD BE I DON'T MEAN TO
BELABOR THE SOME SARDINES. I'M
NOT SURE EXACTLY WHAT YEAR IS
IT OKAY IF I. ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. YES MISS BROKE PLEASE
ANSWER THE QUESTION. OKAY SO
UNDER SECTION THREE THE BILL
AMENDS SECTION TWO ONE ONE NINE
OF THE FISHING GAME CODE
ALREADY ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT
TO PUBLISH A LIST FROM TIME TO
TIME- YOU KNOW ANIMALS THAT
CANNOT BE IMPORTED INTO THE
STATE. I'M IN IT WE BELIEVE
THAT UNDER LIKE EXISTING RIDE
THE DEPARTMENT IS DOING THAT I
THINK THAT MAYBE ONE OF THE
SPONSORS DISAGREED BUT WHAT
I'VE HEARD FROM OUR ANIMAL
TRAINERS AND THE LOCALS THAT
THEY ARE DOING THAT AND YOU
KNOW THE DAY LANGUAGE IN
SECTION THREE GOES BEYOND JUST
POSSESSION A CRITICAL
TRANSPORTATION WITHIN THE
STATE. IT GOES TOWARDS COMING
UP WITH THE LATEST- BY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SO OUR APPS COULD BE
THAT THEN MANAGE TO SECTION
THREE THAT HAVE TO DO IT- WHICH
NOT ONLY ON IMPORTATION BUT
ALSO PRODUCTION AND
TRANSPORTATION WITHIN WORK TO
THE STATE- BEAT BE STRUCK FROM
THE BILL SO THAT THEY
DEPARTMENT JUST HAS ITS
EXISTING AUTHORITY. AND THEN ON
THE ISSUE OF PEER REVIEW OUR
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE WE'RE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH SENATOR STERN- ON
SOMETHING. THAT MAKE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT IS THE
STATUTORY DEFINITION OF
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE RIGHT IS
THE- TERMINATION BEING MADE IN
A WAY THAT YOU KNOW I'M DEBTS
BEING ABLE TO BE CONFIRMED BY
THE MORE THAN ONE ALL RIGHT
SCIENTIFIC JOURNAL I DON'T I
DON'T THINK WE REALLY HAVE AN
IDEA WE JUST WANT THE CERTAINTY
OF KNOWING. THAT THESE
DECISIONS. AREN'T BEING MADE
ARBITRARILY. TO FIND UNDERSTAND
GROW YOU WANT TO STRIKE THREE
AND LET THE KERN LAWS STANDARD
AS IS AS IT RELATES TO THE
THORNY OF FISHING GAME. I'M
FISH WALLER YEAH. MR STERN ARE
YOU AMENABLE TO TAKING ADAM
EMINENT STRUCK IN THAT SECTION
OUT. IF IT'S THE WILL OF THE
CHAIR AND IT'S TO WILL IS HERE.
THEN YES. AND OKAY AND AS IT
RELATES TO THE GOOD FAITH
EFFORT OF WORKING WITH
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE AND BETTER
TO FIND THAT I GUESS YOU WILL
HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD IF IT'S
CHILLY THIS COMMITTEE HERE
TODAY IS WE HAVE A COMMITMENT
FOR ME TO DO THAT. YOU DO
INDEED MISTER MAKER WITH THAT
UNDERSTANDING- IS ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS IN
REGARDS TO THIS MEASURE. IN
CHINA- CENTER STERN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU FOR
THE GREAT DIFFICULTY AND- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT. A
CONSULTANT ARE YOU CLEAR ON THE
MOMENTS THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
IN ASKING FOR GOING FORTH IN
THIS COMMITTEE. YES I AM THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE HAD GIVEN ME
THE OTHER MOMENTS IN WRITING
AND THEN I UNDERSTAND THIS ONE
SO THANK YOU CAN. UNDERSTANDING
IN WHICH SENATOR WINNER. WE
SHOULD THE SIDE DIALOGUE I
THINK. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
SUBJECT AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR BRING YOUR FORWARD AND
SPONSORS- I DO THINK THE BILL
NEEDS- SOME WORK ON HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT. TODAY TO KEEP THE
CONVERSATION GOING AND THEN
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE. WHEN IT'S ON THE FLOOR
BUT I'M CONFIDENT THAT THE
AUTHOR WILL BE ABLE TO WORK IT
OUT. I UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE
A TO PASS AS AMENDED- BY THIS
COMMITTEE- TO APPROPRIATIONS-
MADAM. CONSULTED PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON B. THREE SEVEN SIX.
SB THREE SEVEN SIX TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD HI I PROVIDE CHOI
BOGUE. NOT NOT VOTING HI OKAY
SO. TOBA II COM LONGER HI FROM
LONGER AYE SKINNER. SKINNER AYE
WIENER WIENER I'D BILLS. FIVE
ZERO. FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO LET
MEASURES OUT HUNG
CONGRADULATIONS CENTER STERN
NEXT UP IS SENATOR ALAN WITH.
HIS MEASURE SB. FORTY THREE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR. THIS COMMITTEE
WILL REMEMBER VERY WELL BOTH
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN THE ENACTMENT OF TO
LAWS POPULARLY KNOWN AS THE
CALIFORNIA RISE ACTS THE COURSE
WORK- WHERE THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR REPEATED AND- SERVER
THE GOVERNOR LEGISLATURE
DECIDED TO- TO GET RID OF
DEMONSTRABLY INEFFECTIVE
CRIMINAL AND SENTENCE IN
CRIMINAL SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS THAT ADDED THREE
YEARS OF INCARCERATION
DEFENDANTS. FOR EACH PRIOR DRUG
OFFENSE THAT WAS AS B. ONE
EIGHTY WHICH IS THE FORMER
CHAIR HOLLY MITCHELL'S BILL AND
THEN ALSO AN ADDITIONAL ONE
THAT- ADDED CENTER WIENER. I
TOOK ACROSS THE FINISH LINE SB
ONE THIRTY SIX- WHICH WHICH
REPEALED THE ONE YEAR OF
INCARCERATION FOR EACH PRIOR
PRISONER FELONY. JAIL TERM.
SAYS RECOMMENDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE ON
REVISION PENAL CODE I THINK OUR
OUR CENTER CALM UNDER SERVED ON
THAT COMMISSION COMMITTEE. SB
FOUR EIGHTY THREE WILL
RETROACTIVELY APPLY THESE RISE
ACCESS TO PEOPLE CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA JAILS AND PRISONS.
WHO WERE CONVICTED PRIOR TO
THEIR ENACTMENT. THERE'S A
ROBUST BODY OF RESEARCH THAT
FINDS IT LONG PRISON AND JAIL
SENTENCES- REALLY DON'T HAVE A
DEMONSTRABLE POSITIVE IMPACT ON
PUBLIC SAFETY. ATTY WE
CERTAINLY KNOW THEIR. THEIR
INJURIES TO FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES TO. IN CAN OF COLOR.
I OF COURSE YOU ALSO KNOW THAT
ARE TURNING FROM ACROSS OUR
FACE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS. NOW
WHEN THEY TO FIND JOBS AND
HOUSING AND THERE'S A LOT OF
CHALLENGES WITH FAMILIES AND
SOCIETAL REINTEGRATION- YOU
KNOW THERE'S BEEN STUDIES BY
THE U. S. SENATE SEAT
COMMISSION THAT FOUND THE
RETROACTIVE APPLICATION OF
SENTENCE REDUCTIONS IN THE
FEDERAL SYSTEM HAD NO
MEASURABLE IMPACT ON RECIDIVISM
RATES AND THAT'S- MOST RELEVANT
TO THIS BILL. I THERE WAS AN
ANALYSIS OF THE PRISON
POPULATIONS IN MARYLAND
MICHIGAN FLORIDA THEY CAME TO
SIMILAR CONCLUSIONS. SO IT'S IN
LIGHT OF THIS RESEARCH AND THE
GUIDANCE OF A WIDE ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE. ON REVISION OF THE
PENAL CODE THAT WE- WE
BASICALLY COME FORWARD WITH
THIS BILL THAT DEFIES THE LAW
EQUALLY BY RETROACTIVELY
REPEALING INEFFECTIVE THREE
YEAR AND ONE YEAR SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WE'VE ALREADY
REPEAL. MOVING FOR THE IDEA
BEING THAT WE- HAD SO MUCH AND
HAVE A MORE TIME IN PRISON JUST
BECAUSE THEY WERE SENTENCED. IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN INSTEAD OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- FOR THE
EXACT SAME CRIME. AS SO IF IT'S
GOOD ENOUGH FOR THOSE CASES
MOVE. IT NOT A BIG ENOUGH- TO
PLAY RETRACT IN THE COURSE THIS
DOESN'T. CHANGE ANYTHING WITH A
GOOD O THE- PRISON TERMS IN
AND- IN ANYTHING WITH REGARDS
TO OTHERS AND HANSON. THAT NOT
ALREADY BEEN PROOF BY THE SIDE.
AND THE TO RISE ACCESS THE ONE
EIGHTY SB ONE THIRTY SIX. SO
JOINING ME TODAY IS WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE OR CENTER JOHNSON.
ON BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN. AND
ALSO THE TIME EVERYONE. WELL
THAT YOU COULD CARRY ON WITH MR
IF WITH CHECK. OKAY DO WE HAVE
A JOHNSON WE HAVE ON THE TWO.
HERE SO WE ARE STARTING A SEVEN
JOHNSON AND THIRTY TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES ON THE CORRECT. YES
WHICH JOHNSON ARE YOU PREPARED.
YES I AM THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M BALLIN
JOHNSON AND I WILL CALL LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN. AND CRAPPIE PROGRAM
COORDINATOR. A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
ALLEN BEATTY ALEX THE STATE
ORGANIZED COMMUNITIES IMPACTED
BY THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND WE ADVOCATE TO RELEASING
CARCERI THE PEOPLE. RESTORE
HUMAN AND CIVIL RIGHTS AND WE
WORK TO REUNIFY FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. I AM ALSO SENDING
CARDS THREE. ABOUT FIFTEEN
YEARS IN AND OUT. I USED TO BE
A BIG SOME OF THESE
ENHANCEMENTS BECAUSE OF MY PAST
DRUG ADDICTION. I WOULD ALWAYS
GIVE A PRIOR DRUG ENHANCEMENT
ON TOP OF THAT ADDITIONAL TIME
WHICH WAS SO UNFAIR BEST WE CAN
BE DONE HAVE. ALLOW EXTRA LONG
AND I MISS. IT THANK YOU
NOTHING FOR MY- SHE- THESE
ENHANCE IT DIDN'T TO HELP. ME
HELP ME BEAT MY DRUG ADDICTION
OR ANYTHING THE WHOLE TO HELP
HOLD MY FAMILY WHILE I WAS
FORCED TO SERVE EXTRA TIME. THE
THING. THE THING IS PRESENT
BEARD NOT ONLY TRAUMATIZED ME
IT HURT MY CHILDREN AND MY
YOUNGEST SON WHO I STILL HAVE
RELATIONSHIP PROBLEMS. BECAUSE
OF THE LONG SEPARATION TO PUT
UNDER BERRY AND HANDLE I WAS
GIVEN. TWENTY SEVENTEEN I SPOKE
WITH GORDON SB ONE EIGHTY TO
REPEAL THE ENHANCEMENT BECAUSE
IT WOULD APPLY TO TARGET. AND
HARM DOWN THESE RATHER THAN
GIVE UP THE SPORT THAT WE NEED.
CALIFORNIA DID THE RIGHT THING
WHEN THEY REPEAL THE
ENHANCEMENT. AND WE AND WE CAN
DO THE RIGHT THING AGAIN FOR
ALL THE FAMILY STILL. WE NEED
TO BE HURTING BECAUSE FROM
ABOUT. WHAT ROLE AT EYEING
ELIMINATION OF THE THREE IN ONE
YEAR. AND TOP OF THE FAMILY.
I'M GETTING. GOING TO THE SAME
HARDSHIP AND PAIN THAT MY SON
AND I FINISHED FOR THE DAY. YOU
NOW HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO THE
REST OF THE WORK TERM CHIU.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
ALLOW FAMILIES TO BE BUILT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY THE VICE THAT.
THANK YOU NEXT UP IS THE TASHA
MINSKER. THANK YOU SHARE AN
ATTACHMENT- I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE AT
THE INVITATION OF THE SENATOR
TO ENTER ANY TECHNICAL OR LEGAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NOW WILL GO TO
THE HEARING ROOM HERE IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE I SEE NO WITNESSES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR EIGHT THREE WILL GO
TO OUR OVER FULL ROOM THERE'S
NO ONE THERE AS WELL. NOW LET'S
GO TO THE MODERATOR INTO THIRD
CALL URGING Q. IN SUPPORT OF.
FOUR EIGHT THREE. BOB REITER. I
APOLOGIZE I HAD MAYBE A TIME-
FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOUR EIGHT THREE. PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO IN LINE FIVE HUNDRED THREE
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE CAL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. BLIND
OF FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE.
GOOD EVENING SENATORS AND DANTE
DIMARTINO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHT THREE THANK YOU. HELLO
LINE. THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY
NAME IS BRUCE WARD I'M POLICY
COORDINATOR WITH CALIFORNIANS
AND I WOULD LIKE TO READ OFF A
LIST OF ME TOOS- FIRST WE HAVE-
FACE AN ACTION EAST BAY. WE
HAVE SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIA.
ALLIANCE THE CALIFORNIA. SIGN
UP FOR REGIONAL DOCTOR THIRDS
AREA.
ARE YOU GETTING THE GLORY
OPPORTUNITY FOUNDATION AND
PREVENTION AT THE INTERSECTION
THANK YOU. DUE TO THIS. BLINDER
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTEEN
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. BLIND. FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE. GOING
BACK TO THE STORE CO SPONSORS
CONTINUE TO SHORTLISTED GROUPS
OF WARRANTY NINETY RECORD TO
HELP KEEP HEARING OFFICIALS
LONG- CALIFORNIA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS COME SPONSORED
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE ALSO
SUPPORT ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
SAMPLES GO PUBLIC DEFENDER. I
NEED ACTION DIEGO LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN PREVENTION AT THE
INTERSECTION INITIATE JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY JUSTICE NATIONAL
CETER FOR YOUTH LAW AND.
ACTUALLY JUSTICE COME THANK YOU.
AND LINE OF. FIVE EIGHTY TWO.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
DISPATCHES CHECK THE LINE ONE
MORE TIME FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THREE SEVEN. I'M
SORRY FORTY THREE. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOUR EIGHT THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE ZERO AND WE HAVE
ANOTHER COMMENT FROM LINE FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MERRY MORENO FAMILY-
IMPACTED BY- INCARCERATION OUT
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUENTS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE ALL
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM WITH
THEIR LINE NUMBER. IN LIGHT OF
FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR. BUT
SURE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AS FUNDING IS ON BEHALF OF THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY THREE THANK
YOU. AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU NOW LET'S G TO
OPPOSITION I SEE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES ARE LISTED IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE HERE
AND FORTY TWO OH THREE. NOR IN
TWENTY FORTY SO MODERATE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES INTO
THEIR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OF AS P. FOUR EIGHT THREE. OR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FOUR EIGHT THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. WE HAVE
NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT
THIS TIME. I WOULD HAVE
STRIPPED THE LARGEST ONE MORE
TIME GIVE IT A MINUTE AND WE'LL
MOVE ON. SURE FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. FOUR EIGHT
THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. BACK COMMAND AGAIN A. ONE
ZERO. AND THERE ARE STILL NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THAT
CROWDED THERE NO TAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
WINNER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I DON'T REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR. BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- WE- USING
KNOWLEDGE OF THE BEGINNING
MYSELF AND CENTER MITCHELL
ANNOUNCE SUPERVISOR MITCHELL-
CENTER SKINNER- YOU KNOW
SOMEONE IN OUR CALL IS A WHOLE
BIG GROUP EFFORT TO GET BOTH OF
THOSE- CENTER BROUGHT THE
CHAIR- BIG GROUP EFFORT TO GET
BOTH OF THOSE BILLS- PAST- AND
IT'S- JUST SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THESE ENHANCEMENTS ARE.
ABSOLUTELY FUELING MASS
INCARCERATION AND THEY REALLY
DON'T DO ANYTHING TO MAKE
ANYONE SAFER- AND YOU KNOW YOU
SHOULD DO THE TIME FOR THE FOR
THE CRIME YOU TO BUT WE START
STOCKING ON ENHANCEMENT AFTER
ENHANCEMENT AND THEN ALSO TO.
TWO OR THREE YEAR SENTENCE
BECOMES AN EIGHT OR TEN YEAR
SENTENCE AND COSTLY AND IT'S
MAKES IT HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO
REINTEGRATE- ONCE THEY COMPLETE
THEIR SENTENCE. AND IT JUST
MAKES. NO SENSE AT ALL AND SO
WAS THAT WE'RE THEM IN A TENT.
THAT YOU'RE- NOW BECAUSE THIS.
FOR TO APPLY RETRO TO THOUGH ON
ABOUT REQUESTED A CALL. PROCESS
AND SO. I MOVED THE BILL. THANK
YOU WE HAVE A MOTION SENATOR WE
ANY OF DISTANCE ASCRIPTION ON
BASED ON THE ISSUE SO. THANK
SOMEONE A THE AUTHOR CURING IT
ALL WELCOME HIM TO THE- OR CALL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM POLICY.
AND BUT IT'S TRUE ONE. FIVE
WHEN WE- CHANGE THE LAW GOING
FORWARD. THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
NO DIFFERENT THAN REALLY FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO ALREADY WERE
CONVICTED UNDER THOSE THINGS SO
IN OTHER WORDS IF WE REALIZE
THAT. THAT IT WHATEVER FOR
WHATEVER REASON WE MADE AN
ERROR IN OUR SENTENCING AROUND
PARTICULAR FOR OUR THE WAY WE
ARE BROUGHT A PARTICULAR PART
OF THE PENAL CODE AND THEN WE
CORRECTED TO HAVE OTHER PEOPLE
LANGUISH THAT WERE SENTENCED
PRIOR WHICH YOU OF COURSE MADE
THAT POINT IN YOUR- COMMENTS IT
JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE SO THIS
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO AND
APPRECIATE IT. I WILL BE
SUPPORTING. GREAT THANK YOU
JUST A QUICK COMMENTS QUESTIONS
ON THIS MEASURE CENTER DROVE
OFF. SO I'M JUST KIND OF
CURIOUS AS. TO Y. V. THE NOTION
OF. SEEKING TO REMOVE THESE-
THESE- ENHANCEMENTS TO TREAT
REPEAT OFFENDERS- IN MY MIND
AND I I'M NEW IN A FAIRLY NEW
TO THIS COMMITTEE HAS HEARD
PRETTY NEAR THE PERSON
EVERYBODY HERE BUT I JUST KIND
OF CURIOUS AS TO. I WOULD THINK
THAT IF IT'S A REPEAT OFFENDER.
THE CONSEQUENCES SHOULD BE
STRICTER. ON THAT AND NOT NOT
LESS RESTRICTIVE ON THAT AND-
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
LOGIC BEHIND THIS BILL- BECAUSE
I IN MY MIND IT TO RELEASE IS
NOT MAKING. SENSE ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO REPEAT
OFFENDERS I CAN I CAN. FENTON
THE NOTION OF THE UNDERSTANDING
OF A FIRST TIME OFFENDER BUT
WITH REPEAT OFFEND WITH THE
REPEAT OFFENDER. THE FIFTY TWO
YEAR AND TOOK JUST TO CLARIFY
CENTER ARE YOU WHEN YOU SAY
YOU'RE TRYING TO SEND THIS BILL
IN JUNE. R. J. A. U. GRAZING A
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RISE ACTS
LIKE A SPEED. ONE EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY SIX OR OR IS IT IS YOUR
CONCERN WITH. NOW THAT THOSE
HAVE BEEN PASSED- WHICH SET THE
STANDARD FOR REPEAT OFFENDERS.
IT FILE IN A LIMITED WAY
BECAUSE THERE'S OTHER WAYS THAT
PEOPLE'S. DEFENDERS SENTENCES
CAN CAN CERTAINLY BEING ENHANCE
IT EVEN UNDER CURRENT LAW ALL
WE'RE DOING HERE IS HE'S
APPLYING THE EXISTING LAW
RETROACTIVELY. SO THAT SO THAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT. COULD BE GIVEN
A OF A LONGER SENTENCE JUST
BECAUSE THEY WERE CONVICTED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN AS OPPOSED TO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SO NOW IF
YOUR IF YOUR QUESTION IS ABOUT
THE BROADER QUESTION WHY IT IS
WE REPEALED- THE SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS FOR CERTAIN TYPES
OF REPEAT OFFENSE WE I MEAN I
CAN WE CAN. HEAR YOU HAVE WE
GOT SEVERAL PEOPLE ON THIS
COMMITTEE YOU CAN SPEAK-ELOQUENTLY ABOUT- WHY IT WAS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY FOR
NASA THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE
SENATE. I BELIEVE THAT IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE FOCUSED ON OR OR IS
IT. YES SOME BOTH ON THAT ON
THAT AND RETROACTIVELY AND
BECAUSE I MEAN THIS IS.
OBVIOUSLY A FOLLOW UP TO THAT
BUT- IN ESSENCE IT'S STILL.
YOUR ADDRESSING THE ISSUES OF
REPEAT OFFENDERS RIGHT WOULD
YOU DO WHAT DO WOULD YOU MIND
IF I ASK OUR COLLEAGUE WHO WHO
CARRIED THE BILL ON THIS-
CENTER WINNER. ABSOLUTELY SO.
SO FIRST OF ALL JUDGES ALREADY
HAVE THERE'S A RANGE OF
SENTENCES EVERY SET EVERY
FELONY THEY COMMITTED AS A LOW
MIDDLE AND HIGH ENDS WHERE THEY
CAN SOLICIT MY IDEA I'M JUST
MAKING THIS UP TO TWO YEARS
THREE YEARS FOUR YEARS
DEPENDING ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES
AND SO THE JUDGE CAN ALREADY
LOOK BACK AT SOMEONE'S RECORD
IN ADDITION THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THE CRIME AND SIGNS ON THE
HIGH END OF THE RANGE OR THE
LOW END OF THE RANGE SUGGESTS
JUDGES ALREADY HAVE DISCRETION.
IN ADDITION WHEN YOU COMMIT A
CRIME YOU HAVE THE SENTENCE FOR
THAT FOR THAT CRIME AND THAT IS
WHAT IT IS IF YOU ALREADY DID
THE TIME FOR LAST CRIME THE
THINKING AS IF YOU DID THE TIME
WHATEVER THE LAW CENTER LAST
CRIME. BUT SAY WHATEVER EITHER
TEN YEARS LATER YOU COMMIT
ANOTHER CRIME YOU DO THE QUOTE
THAT THE TIME FOR THAT THESE
ENHANCEMENTS WERE ESPECIALLY
THE ONE YOU'RE IN HOUSING WHICH
IS A BILL THAT I CARRIED TENDED
TO BE FOR LOWER LEVEL OFFENSES
BECAUSE FOR MORE HIGHER LEVEL
OFFENSES- TO THE OTHER
ENHANCEMENTS THAT ARE MORE
SERIOUS SO WHAT THIS IS DOING
WAS OFTEN TURNING LOW LEVEL
CRIMES- INTO A VERY LONG
SENTENCES ABOUT WAS THE IDEA.
BEHIND REMOVING IT PEOPLE CAN
STILL GET PRETTY YOU KNOW
SERIOUS SET SENSORS FOR
COMMITTING A FELONY BUT BUT YOU
KNOW THE. THE THOUGHT IS.
ACTING OUR PRISONS PEOPLE. YOUR
CALIFORNIA WENT ON A- SPREE
WERE WE WENT FROM PRISON OF
THIRTY ONE PRESS. AMHERST OVER
CROWD BECAUSE- INSTEAD OF
HAVING RATIONAL SENTENCING WE
DO A PUNISHMENT. EVERYTHING
BECAUSE OF ENHANCEMENTS. WAS A
REALLY LONG SENTENCE AND WAS
PACKING OUR PRISONS AND- BUT IT
JUST WASN'T WORKING SO THIS IS
REALLY- ANTI MASS INCARCERATION
MEASURE. YOU'RE FINE YOUR OKAY
THANK YOU HOGG SOONER ALLEN I
JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR THIS
MEASURE I THINK- ISSUES PROVEN
THAT ENHANCEMENTS AS STATED BY
PREVIOUS- A MEMBERSHIP OF THIS
COMMITTEE- THROUGH VERY LITTLE
IF ANYTHING AND- DETERRING
CRIME. AND- WE JUST. FIND
OURSELVES AGAIN WITH- HAVING
ASKING PEOPLE TO SERVE LONGER.
TIME IMPRISONED SOMETIMES FOR
VERY MINOR OFFENSES AND YES
MIGHT BE- REPEAT OFFENDERS BUT
THERE INDIVIDUALS YOU'VE
ALREADY DONE A TIME SHOWN THAT
THEY HAVE MADE A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT IN. TRYING TO
REHABILITATE THEMSELVES AND I
THINK THAT'S THE GOAL OF YOU
KNOW WHY WE SEND PEOPLE TO
PRISON AND- HOPING THAT THEY
COME OUT BETTER BUT AGAIN
ENHANCEMENTS DON'T CHANGE THE
MINDSET OF SOMEONE WHO IS
PLANNING ON COMMITTING A CRIME
SHOW ARE. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORT IN CONTINUING-
RESTORATIVE JUSTIN OPPORTUNITY
SO ON ON THAT NOTE WE HAVE A
MOTION DON'T ARE WE SEEKING A
MOTION ON. DO PASS. TO
APPROPRIATIONS- WE A MORE. BY
SENATOR TOM LARDER. ON THIS FOR
EIGHT THREE IT'S TO PASS TO
RECUPERATION CONSULTANT I WILL
FIRST CENTER OUR WHICH OUGHT TO
CLOSE. SHE THE WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE INCREDIBLE
INTERESTED EXIST AMONGST THE
MEMBERS ON THIS TOPIC AND- YOU
KNOW I MEAN YOU KNOW THE DAY
FAIR AND COMPLETE REPEAL OF
SETTINGS ENHANCEMENTS ARE. IT'S
RECOMMENDED BUYING BY MANY
EXPERTS WE'VE GOT LOTS OF DATA
AND STUDIES ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT THE CHAIR MENTIONED- IT'S
GOING TO MODESTLY REDUCE PRISON
AND JAIL POPULATIONS BUT ALSO
ADVANCE FAIRNESS AND- M. AND
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S- THERE'S
FAIRNESS ALSO TEMPORARILY- WELL
NOT. THIS DEMONSTRABLY
IMPACTING RECIDIVISM SO WITHOUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU. CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THIS MEASURE
SB FOUR EIGHTY THREE ALLEN DO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHOKE. JOB OF NO
CALM WATER I FROM LIKE- I
SKINNER. BY SKINNER AYE WINNER
RIGHT WE AYE FOR ONE. SKINNER
IMAGES OUT THE ONE GRADUALLY.
AND IT WAS BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION MEMBERS IN OUR AGE TO
GET THROUGH THE SLOTS FROM A
MEASURE THAT WE FAIL TO GET A
MOTION ON S. B. STE THREE SEVEN
SIX- THAT WAS THE STERN BILL
ARM. WE JUST PREVIOUSLY HEARD
IS THERE A MOTION- ON THAT.
MEASURE. THREE SEVEN SIX SEVEN.
IT WAS YOU MAKE A MOTION SIR SO
I CAN MAKE THE MOTION NOW BUT
WITH ALL THE MOMENT YES CHAU
MARGARET THINK IT WAS BROUGHT
TO OUR ATTENTION I REMOVED
TENSION IT'S OKAY IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CERTAIN WIENER ON SB
THREE SEVEN SIX EIGHT DO PASS
AS AMENDMENT IT MEANT. IT IS
THE MINUTES BEING TAKEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE. SO WE'VE TAKEN IN
COMMITTEE- DO PASSED.
APPROPRIATE ALL RIGHT SB THREE
SEVENTY SIXTY PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD HI-
BOGUE. COPY THAT OF GOD COM
LONGER KAMLAGER AYE SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE WIENER HI. AND ZERO
THE MEASURES UP TWO G. NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO LAOS I DON'T
HOPEFULLY OF THE NIGHT. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE BEST FOR
LAST WE JUST SAVED IT FOR LAST.
BURGER KING  CURIOUS AS TO THE
STATEMENT THAT YOU JUST MADE AS
HOPEFULLY. WHAT IS IT. YOU JUST
STATED HOPEFULLY. OUR. RIGHT
CENTER ROAD FOR A WALK ON THE
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO HEAR YOUR
PRESENTATION ON SB FOUR TWENTY
ONE. THANK YOU MEMBERS ARE AS
STATED I'M HERE TO PRESENT US
BEFORE THIRTY ONE WHICH AIMS TO
WE HOPE IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY
BY REDUCING OUR- DRIVING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE- WALLONIAN
OFFENDERS A PATH TOWARD
REHABILITATION THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A SPECIFIC SAFEGUARDS
FOR DO YOU WHY OFFENDERS
PARTICIPATING IN CALIFORNIA'S.
MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION PROGRAM-
IT WOULD PRESERVE THE ABILITY
FOR FIRST TIME OFFENDERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN A PROGRAM WHILE
ALSO ADDRESSING PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS WITH CURRENT PROGRAM.
IN THIS IS A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM
WHEN AB THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR
WAS PASSED AND ENACTED LAST
YEAR COURTS WERE GRANTED THE
DISCRETION TO PLACE FIRST TIME
MISDEMEANOR OFFENDERS AND IT
DIVERSION PROGRAM. HOWEVER
THERE WAS MANY CONCERNS OVER
REYES SHOULD DO THIS AND IT
PULLS NO LIMITATIONS ON
ELIGIBILITY A REPEAT DUI.
OFFENDERS FOR DIVERSION.
ALLOWING THEM TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR DIVERSION OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WITHOUT BEING IDENTIFIED
AS A HIGH RISK RISK CHRONICALLY
IMPAIRED DRIVER THAT WAS NEVER
THE INTENT. GOVERNOR NEWSOM
MADE A NOTE OF THIS WHEN HE
SIGNED THE BILL- AB THIRTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR AND URGED THE
LEGISLATURE TO REMEDY THIS
ISSUE THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE INSTRUCTOR
COMPROMISE SPECIFICALLY IS.
BILL WOULD DO THE FOLLOWING.
LET ME THE VIRGIN TWO PEOPLE
WERE NO. D. Y. CONVICTIONS WHO
HAVE NOT COMPLETED A DIVERSION
PROGRAM IN THE LAST TEN YEARS.
REQUIRES AS A CONDITION OF THE
VERSION THAT THE DEFENDANT
INSTALLS AN IGNITION INTERLOCK
DEVICE FOR TWELVE MONTHS AND
PARTICIPATES IN EDUCATION AND
COUNSELING PROGRAMS. REQUIRED
TO DIEM DO YOU THE DMV TO
PROVIDE DIVERTED. ADDRESSED IN
THE TRACKING OF D. U. I. ARREST
AND CONVICTION DATA. AND IT
COUNTS DO YOU ARE VIOLATIONS
THAT ARE DISMISSIVE VIA THIS
PROGRAM THE DIVERSION PROGRAM
AS A PRIOR CONVICTION FOR THE
PURPOSES SUBSEQUENT DO YOU AYE
CONVICTIONS. HERE TO TESTIFY TO
FIGHT TODAY WITH US WAS MARRIED
KLOTZBACH- WITH MOTHERS OF
AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING AND
DINNER AND GROUND DOLE WITH THE
FOUNDATION FOR ADVANCING
ALCOHOL RESPONSIBILITIES.
MEMBERS I THINK WE WOULD AGREE
ARE HOPING ANGRY THAT THIS IS A
FAIR AND JUST MEASURE TO HELP
PROMOTE PUBLIC SAFETY BY
REMOVING THE ABILITY- BILLY FOR
DIVERSION PROGRAMS OR
REHABILITATION SO- ON THAT NOTE
I RESPECT LAST FRIDAY. THANK
YOU SENATOR. WE WILL NOW MOVE
FORWARD WITH- OUR LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS MERRY CLOTS BACK FOR
MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING.
A CHECK SORRY MOTHERS AGAINST
DRUNK DRIVING BOARD MEMBER
PLEASE PROCEED. IT IS CLOSE
BACK ARE YOU ON THE LINE. HELLO
THIS IS THE OPERATOR WE DO NOT
SHOW HER ON THE LINE WE DO HAVE
A DARING GROUND ALTHOUGH OKAY
WE HAVE AND OUR SECOND LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS DURING THE
GROUND- FROM THE FOUNDATION OF
FOR ADVANCING ALCOHOL
RESPONSIBILITY. OF THE P. OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AND
TRAFFIC SAFETY- MR RUNDLE
YOU'RE ON THE LINE. I AM CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES- PLEASE-
PROCEED WITH TORONTO. IT SIX
BILLION. PLEASE PROVIDE THIS
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
MISTER RANDALL CAN YOU HEAR ME.
I CAN HEAR YOU WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY
SIR. YES GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY TO
TRYING TO GET US ON THEIR.
MISTER RHONDA CAN YOU HEAR ME
YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. OKAY I AM. BARCLAYS
HEAD. GOOD EVENING SHERMAN
BRADFORD AND DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU TODAY. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
OKAY I CAN HEAR THE OPERATOR
BUT I'M NOT SURE YOU CAN LIMIT.
MISTER MODERATOR WOULD YOU LET
MR RUNDLE NOW THAT HE IS BEING
HEARD AND CAN PROCEED WITH THIS
TESTIMONY. BURKE OFFICE IN
NORTHWESTERN RUNDLE A YOU ARE
BEING HEARD AND YOU CAN PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. OKAY I'LL
START OVER. GOOD EVENING
SHERMAN BRADFORD AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY BEFORE YOU TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE SENATE BILL FOR
TWENTY ONE. WHICH MAKES A
NUMBER OF ENHANCEMENTS TO THE
CURRENT CALIFORNIA MISSIONARY
LOCK LAWS WHICH WILL SAVE LIVES.
FROM THE PREVENTABLE TRAGEDIES
OF IMPAIRED DRIVING. THE RECORD
MY NAME IS DARREN D. GLENDALE
VICE PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS TRAFFIC SAFETY FOR
THE FOUNDATION FOR DANCING OF
COAL RESPONSIBILITY OR
RESPONSIBILITY .ORG.
ORGANIZATIONS JOINING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE THE
COALITION OF IGNITION INTERLOCK
MANUFACTURES. RECORDING ARTISTS
AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING WE SAVE
LIVES DISTILLED SPIRITS COUNCIL
OF THE UNITED STATES WERE
DISCUSSED. RESPONSIBILITY DOT
ORG IS A NATIONAL NOT FOR
PROFIT THAT LEADS THE FIGHT TO
ELIMINATE DRUNK DRIVING AND
UNDERAGE DRINKING IS FOUNDED BY
SOME OF THE LEADING STORES IN
THE UNITED STATES. ACCORDING TO
THE MOST RECENT DATA FROM THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION STATE HOLIDAY
ANALYSIS REPORTING SYSTEM
CALIFORNIA. IS ABOVE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR IMPAIRED
DRIVING FATALITIES. DO YOU RATE
YOUR TELEVISION CALIFORNIA HAVE
INCREASED 8% OVER THE LAST
DECADE AND GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION. AND DRIVING IMPAIRED
BY MULTIPLE SUBSTANCES AS AN
EVER INCREASING PROBLEM WITH A
HIGH RISK CRASH RISK. CURRENTLY
THIRTY FOUR STATES AND THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA REQUIRE
IGNITION INTERLOCKS FOR ALL
DELIGHT OFFENDERS SIMPLY PUT
THE COMMISSION INTERLOCKS ARE
ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
COUNTERMEASURES AVAILABLE TO
STOP DRUNK DRIVING BEFORE IT
BEGINS. ADMISSION INTERLOCAL
WIREIMAGE PROVIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN PROACTIVELY
STOP DELAY TRIPS FROM BEING
INITIATED IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND THEY MONITOR DRIVERS
THROUGH THE DURATION OF THE
TRIP. THIS IMPORTANT
IMPROVEMENT THE CURRENT LAW HE
CALIFORNIA ALLOWS OFFENDERS
SOCIAL WORK AND FAMILY
OBLIGATIONS WHILE PROTECTING
THE PUBLIC. WE SEEM TO RESEARCH
FINDINGS SHOW THAT BETWEEN
FIFTY AND 75% OF SUSPENDED OR
REVOKED RIGHT WHICH WILL
CONTINUE TO DRIVE. THE FLIGHT
HELPS CLOSE THAT GAP AND MAKES
CALIFORNIA ROADS SAFER. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS AND
LEADERSHIP TO REDUCE IMPAIRED
DRIVING IN CALIFORNIA. MERGERS
WITH PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL FOR
TWENTY ONE INTO LAW THIS YEAR
IT WILL PREVENT DELIGHT REDUCE
CRASHES AND SAVE LIVES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
RUNDELL AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO OUR FIRST LEAD WHICH-
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. MERRY CLOTS
BACK ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I AM
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY MA'AM. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MERRY CLASS BOX I AM A
LITTLE MORE RESIDENT FORMER
NATIONAL BOARD MEMBER OF
MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING
I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR TWENTY ONE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR OFFERING
THIS LIFESAVING PROPOSAL SB
FOUR TWENTY ONE HONORS THE WISH
THE GOVERNOR TO FINE TUNE. SB.
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR TO
ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR DRUNK
DRIVERS. THE FLOOD DISTRICT
LEAD VERY PERSONAL. I HAVE
WORKED ON REFORMING DRUNK
DRIVING OFFENSE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN. AFTER CLASS BALK IF MY
SON IS GONE TODAY BECAUSE THE
REPEAT DRUNK DRIVER CHOSE. TO
DRIVE DRUNK AGAIN THIS TIME ON
A SUSPENDED LCENSE MEANT TO
KEEP THEM OFF THE ROAD. HELLO
MY FIFTY TWO PORT ONE AUTHORED
BY SENATOR BRADFORD COULD HAVE
SAVED MY SON'S LIFE. ALLOWED TO
MOVE FORWARD SB FOUR TWENTY ONE
WILL SAVE AND CHANGE LIVES. IT
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT MOST
FIRST TIME DRUNK DRIVERS DO NOT
BECOME REPEAT OFFENDERS. TODAY
MOST FIRST TIME OFFENDERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ALLOWED TO DRIVE
WITHOUT PROVIDING PROTECTION TO
THE PUBLIC. WE KNOW WE CAN'T
JUST SUSPEND LICENSE AND HOPE
FOR THE BACK. UP 275% OF
OFFENDERS CONTINUE TO DRIVE ON
A SUSPENDED LICENSE. WITH
CURRENT LAW WE ARE HOPING. THEY
WON'T MAKE THAT MISTAKE AGAIN
HOPE IS NOT A STRATEGY THAT IS
A RECIPE FOR RECENT EVENTS IN
AND DAY OUT. SB FOUR TWENTY ONE
WILL PROVIDE A MUCH NEEDED
OPPORTUNITY FOR REHABILITATION.
FOR THE FIRST TIME DRUNK
DRIVERS ENTERING INTO THE
DIVERSION PROGRAM. ADMISSION
INTERLOCKS HAVE PROVEN. TO BE A
POWERFUL TOOL FOR
REHABILITATON AND BEHAVIOR
MODIFICATION. PEOPLE LEARN THAT
THEY CANNOT DRINK AND THEN
ATTEMPT TO DRIVE. A DIVERSION
COMPOSED OF SB FOUR TWENTY FOUR
AND CREATES A FRAMEWORK FOR
DIVERSION TO BE IMPLEMENTED
STATE WIDE. VERSION WITHOUT
THESE GUARDRAILS IS CURRENTLY
THE LAW. IT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
SO UNLESS SB FOUR TWENTY ONE
BECOMES LAW. FOR FIRST TIME
OFFENDERS. IN A NON INJURY
CRASH DIVERSION ALLOWED A
SECOND CHANCE. WITHOUT
GUARDRAILS PARTICIPANTS AND
DIVERSIONS ARE SET UP TO FAIL
AND BECOME REPEAT OFFENDERS. SB
FOUR TWENTY ONE RANDAMIE REMEDY
THIS FAILURE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS ARE ABLE
TO HAVE THE OPTION OF.
DIVERSION WITH UNIFORM
STANDARDS. WHY DRUNK DRIVING IS
ONE TWO. BY AND I FOR TWENTY
ONE. COULD CONTINUE TO MAKE SIX
PROGRESS THE STOCK DRUNK
DRIVING. THANK AGAIN SHERMAN
BRAD. I CALL ALL LAW TO ADVANCE
THE LIFESAVING LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS LOTS
BACK FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
WE'RE GONNA NOW BEGIN WITH WITH
THE SAYS HERE IN SUPPORT- IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEEN
NONE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
TWENTY ONE. SCENE NINE. THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
TWENTY ONE. WE WILL BEGIN PART.
FOR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. FOUR TWENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO. THANK YOU
MODERATOR IN WHEN THE TIME IS
RIGHT WOULD YOU PLEASE GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
PLEASE. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ONE
COMMENT. THANK YOU MODERATE IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
AND CALL THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
INDIVIDUAL WHO WILL CONTINUE.
BLINDER FIVE HUNDRED NINETY
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS NAMELY THE JOURNAL
THANK YOU CAPTAIN A THIRTIETH
ON BEHALF OF BOTH
RESPONSIBILITY .ORG AND THE
DISTILLED SPIRITS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MISTER MODERATE
IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND CHECKING
THE LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
ASSURE OURSELVES THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT
WITNESSES FOR SB FOUR TWENTY
ONE. SURE FOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR TWENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE BENDS
HERO. BACK COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND THERE STILL ARE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION- WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES I
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
CNN ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES ERA
TWENTY FORTY WHO WAS TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION SB FOUR TWENTY
ONE. SEEN NONE. THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROPERTY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR TWENTY
ONE WE WILL BEGIN. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FOUR TWENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. BACK COMMAND
AGAIN ONE BEN ZERO. THANK YOU
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD AT THE
RIGHT TIME PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE NO- WITNESSES AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND CHECKING THE
LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
REASSURE OURSELVES THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR TWENTY
ONE PLEASE. FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. FOUR TWENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
THERE ARE STILL NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR- WE WANT TO THANK ALL
OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES WHO
TESTIFIED THIS AFTERNOON WILL
NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO OUR MEMBERS DO WE HAVE ANY.
DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. SEEING NONE- CENTER
BROUGHT FOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND THE WITNESSES
WHO TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE AGAIN THIS IS JUST
A- COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT
PROVIDES AN OPTION TO FIRST
TIME OFFENDERS TO. AFFORD THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO- USE A
INTERLOCKING DEVICE AS A
DIVERSION PROGRAM VERSUS VERSUS
HAVING A SUSPENDED LICENSE I
THINK IT MAKES OUR ROADS SAFER
AND IT LEADS TO- ELIMINATING
SOME OF THE FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS
THAT WE KNOW ON IT SOMETIMES
FOLLOW THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE LOSE A SUSPENDED LICENSE
AND LOSE THEIR ABILITY TO GO TO
AND FROM WORK OR- TO TAKE CARE
OF THEIR DAY IN DAY TO DAY
ACTIVITIES OF RAISING THEIR
KIDS AND FAMILY SO I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
SENATOR BRAD. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SB. FOUR TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR KAMLAGER THE
MOTION HAS BEEN MOVED- COUNCIL
OF MADAME CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SB FOUR TWENTY
ONE BRADFORD DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D SHOW BOOK ALREADY-
OVER GUY COME LONGER. ORDER I
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE WE-
WIENER. FIVE TWO ZERO. FIVE
RIGHT FOR MAKING PRO YOU HAVE A
COUPLE CYCLE. SB FIFTY THREE
LEYVA. OKAY S. B. FIFTY THREE
LEYVA- IT MEASURES ON PAUL BUT-
AM I CORRECT IN- AS CENTER
LABOR ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE PASSED OVER BY-
CENTER SKINNER INCOME UNDER. NO
SHE BUT BEFORE WE LEFT BEFORE
WE TOOK THE BOAT SHE TAKEN SOME
OTHER AMENDMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE BUT SHE HAD NOT TAKEN
THE ONES THAT IT'S SENATOR
SKINNER AND KAMAGRA TALKED
ABOUT AFTER THE THIRD RULE WAS
LIFTED. THROUGH WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO INCORPORATE THOSE
AMENDMENTS TO GOING FORWARD.
CENTER SKINNER SO WHILE IN THE
DISCUSSION- WE. WELL I I'LL
EXPRESS I EXPRESS THAT I REALLY
DIDN'T WANT- IT TO FUNCTION AS
A CRIMINAL OFFENSE AGAINST A
JUVENILE ESPECIALLY THE FIRST
TIME AND WEATHER- THE AUTHOR
WOULD. YOU BE WILLING TO
CONSIDER THAT KIND OF CHANGE
AND WHAT- BECAUSE I DIDN'T
REALLY HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
SAY WOULD YOU KNOW WOULD YOU
ABSOLUTELY TAKE THIS MEMORY
NOW- BASICALLY SHE INDICATED
SOME WILLINGNESS BUT YOU KNOW
WE DIDN'T GET INTO A WHOLE LOT
OF DETAIL BUT THEN- IN. IN
CHECKING WITH STAFF AND SUCH.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING BUT WE
HAVE TO HAVE OUR CONSULTANT
CONFIRMED THAT WE COULD GET YOU
THE CHAIR COULD ASK THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. TO
TAKE SUCH AN AMENDMENT. BUT IF
THERE WERE. OTHERS BUT WE
SPECIFICALLY AT LEAST I
SPECIFICALLY WAS RAISING THE
ISSUE AROUND JUVENILES- THE
GOVERNOR- BY TWO RAISED
QUESTIONS AROUND- JUVENILES AND
ALSO- THE CRIMINAL PROVISIONS
THERE WAS A DISCUSSION ABOUT
CRIMINAL VERSUS CIVIL IN THE
AUTHOR EXPRESSED THAT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL WAS TO NOT
JUST HAVE IT ALLOW- FOR- NOT
JUST ALLOWED TO BE A CIVIL
CRIME. BUT THE- SO I DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THAT I HAVE
CONCERNS WITH ADDING NEW
CRIMES- I HAVE CONCERNS WITH
TREATING JUVENILES AS ADULTS-
THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME
CONFUSION BETWEEN IF THE FIRST
IS A MISDEMEANOR AND THE SECOND
IS AN INFRACTION- ED. AND THERE
WAS SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT- A
WARNING FOR JUVENILES AND SOME
OTHER KIND OF- YOU KNOW
CYBERBULLYING TRAINING OR
SOMETHING THROUGH A SCHOOL OR
SOME OTHER DEPARTMENT RATHER
THAN CREATING A NEW PIPELINE
FOR- BOTH JUVENILE BOYS AND
GIRLS- TO ENTER INTO AS A
RESULT OF THIS. BUT- THE
DECISION IS UP TO THE CHAIR. ON
THE NEXT STEPS BECAUSE THE
AUTHOR WAS NOT HERE. IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND ACCEPTING
ANY OF THESE SO MISS KENNEDY
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THE PROCESS IN
WHICH WE NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO
ASSURE THAT THOSE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE- REYES THAT BEING FOR
THE FIRST TIME OFFENSE BE A
WARNING. AND ONLY A FRACTION
FRACTION FOR THE SECOND TIME
OFFENSE AND THAT THOSE
AMENDMENTS FOR SB FIFTY THREE
WOULD BE TAKEN AN APPROACH IS A
WEEK I MEAN THE AUTHOR WE CAN'T
FORCE APPROPRIATIONS
INSTRUMENTS BUT WE CAN EXPRESS
THAT THAT THESE ARE THE THAT
ARE COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE THEM
TO TAKE THOSE AND
APPROPRIATIONS AND- TALK TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT AND
TALK TO THE AUTHORS OFFICE
ABOUT AGREEING TO THAT. IS THAT
THE PLEASURE OF THIS BODY. I
SEE EVERYBODY BOB THEIR HEAD
SO- WE WOULD ASK THE
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT TO
CONSIDER- I WILL RESTATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT- FIRST TIME
OFFENSES BY JUVENILES PIECE
SOLELY A WARNING. AND THAT THE
SECOND OFFENSE IF THERE IS ONE
IS AN INFRACTION THE CORRECT.
IF WE ARE DREAMING OF THAT-
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION I GUESS.
WELL WE ALREADY AND I FIFTH AVE
IS OUT I THINK- AND I DO AND
I'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT THAT
EARLIER THAT STARTING WITH A
WARNING ESPECIALLY WITH KIDS
COULD BE GOOD BUT- BUT I'VE
EVER MY RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE
TO START WITH A CONVERSATION
WITH THE AUTHOR WHO IS A VERY.
REASONABLE PERSON. HOPEFULLY
CAN BE PROPS EVEN AUTHOR- IN A
PART. THE THING THAT ROLE ON
THE MEASURE RIGHT YES OKAY LOOK
RIGHT NOW IT'S A CHOI BOGUE AND
SKINNER VOTING AYE SO BRADFORD.
ARE REDFORD I COME LONGER.
CAMARGO NOT VOTING WIENER.
WIENER AYE SO IT'S FORTY ZERO
ZERO THE MEASURES UP. THE NEXT
ONE IS SB THREE SEVENTEEN STERN.
SO TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
SB THREE SEVENTEEN HAMPTON
RIGHT NOW IT'S- FOUR EYES
SKINNER. IT'S STERN'S. YEAH I
THINK WITH- SKINNER I'VE FIVE
ZERO IMAGES OUT FIVE ZERO AND I
BELIEVE THIS IS THE LAST ONE SB
FORTY ONE BERASAL RIGHT NOW THE
VOTE IS THREE TO ONE WIENER.
WIENER AS FOUR TO ONE EDGES OUT
AS BEFORE ANYONE OUT FOR THE
ONE. I GO THROUGH ONCE MORE.
THAT SHOULD BE IT OKAY MEMBERS
ARE BELIEVE THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS FOR THE DAY SO I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN A PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE
UNABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE RIDING TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. AND
OUR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AN
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. THANK
YOU. AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY. AND I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THAT GENDER FOR
TODAY IN OUR CENTER. SENATE
PUBLIC. SAFETY COMMITTEE STANDS
IN ADJOURNMENT.